foreign
hey everyone welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel in this session we will
be learning Excel but before we begin I
would like to take a quick confirmation
from our viewers as the audio is clear
and the screen is visible if yes kindly
let us know in the chat section and if
there are any issues do let us know so
that we can resolve the issues prior to
beginning
great I see a lot of positive responses
from our viewers I think it's clear to
get started so we do have daily updates
on multiple Technologies and if you're a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological Trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and don't forget to hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn now we will get
started with the agenda for today's
session so we will learn the Excel
fundamentals where we will get started
with some basics of excel where we will
understand the fundamentals of Excel
spreadsheets then we will understand
filters slicers Flash Fill in Excel how
to identify highlight and remove
duplicates in Excel then we will
understand how to lock cells or entire
workbook for the security purposes and
also how to share the access to our
fellow employees or your colleagues then
we will understand goal seek in Excel
then we will understand some more
fundamentals where we will cover
inserting Tech Mark and in case if you
have any presentation or reporting then
how to insert an Excel into a PowerPoint
presentation then we will learn how to
modify cell size for Excel then we will
understand how to group rows and columns
in Excel and how to use them as filters
followed by that we will learn how to
create a drop down list in Excel then we
will learn how to calculate time in
Excel time and age using date Dev
functions followed by that we will
understand the time different functions
in Excel later we will learn how to
calculate average in Excel then the
round of function in Excel count colored
cells in Excel at different dates
watermarks sorting and converting
numbers to words followed by that we
will learn a few more in-depth
fundamentals about rows and columns in
Excel we will learn about AutoFill in
Excel and how to automate spreadsheets
in Excel then we will learn how to
create barcodes in Excel Excel print
page setup formulas and functions repeat
formulas and functions in Excel later we
will type deep into Mis reports in Excel
next we will learn some Advanced
functions in Excel which include lookup
functions xlookup vlookup hlookup then
we will understand how to create a
budget template in Excel and then we
have user forms in Excel and after user
forms in Excel we will learn about mail
and mail merge in Excel and once we are
done with that we will learn data
analysis and regression fundamentals in
Excel then we have macros in Excel Excel
BBA data recovery in Excel and to make
things interesting we will also cover
some interesting shortcuts in Excel once
everything is done we will also cover
some of the latest trending and
important updates in Microsoft Excel
hope I was clear with my agenda now
without further delay we will hand over
the session to our training experts
what as Microsoft Excel so Microsoft
Excel is a software product designed and
developed by Microsoft storing data in
an organized way that is rows and
columns
and Microsoft Excel is also capable to
manipulate data through some
mathematical operations
followed by that
Microsoft Excel is also used to extract
the insights from the data and represent
it in the form of visually appealing
graphs and charts now we have a basic
understanding or an overview of what a
Microsoft Excel software product is
now moving ahead we will understand the
fundamentals of Microsoft Excel
so following are some fundamentals that
you need to know before getting started
with Microsoft Excel so basically when
you install the Microsoft Office in your
computer you will have various Microsoft
products out of which Microsoft Excel is
one of the product so we will be dealing
exactly with that particular product
that is Microsoft Excel so when you get
started with Microsoft Excel this is
what you will see in the first page so
this particular page is called as
Microsoft Excel home page where you will
be having various varieties of sheets
Microsoft Excel will give you some
suggestions based on the type of sheet
you want to work with we will see this
in a better way through the Practical
session so once you get started with the
sheet you will have some more options so
this particular option is called as the
toolbar menu you will have the file home
insert draw paste layout formulas data
review View and help so these are the
tools that you will be using to work on
your data using Microsoft Excel
furthermore we have a toolbar ribbon so
when you select sum or the other option
from the file home insert draw page
layout formulas data review View and
help buttons you will have a ribbon so
for example you can see that I have
selected the Home Tool here so when I
press on the Home Tool this is the
ribbon which Microsoft Excel gives me so
this ribbon has some options in it which
can perform various operations now in a
further a more detailed way we will have
toolbar groups so when you see in the
previous slide we have a complete
toolbar ribbon so this particular ribbon
is segmented into groups so you can see
the first group as paste Cut Copy format
painter etc etc and the second group is
the font the size of the font and to
increase the size of the font to
decrease the size of the font bold
italic underline etc etc and here you
can see the text alignment so each and
every group has separate functions
so each set is called as a group
and I think you can see a small Arrow
option over here so this Arrow option is
used into the toolbar groups when the
group is not able to fit all the
operations or all the functionalities in
one single provided section so when you
click on this particular Arrow Mark you
will have another dialog box so this is
called toolbar more options so you can
see that when I clicked on this icon you
can see a new dialog box which opens me
a new set of operations which are not
able to be fit in this particular group
so we will also see more about this in a
better way in the Practical session now
moving forward we have cell and address
so when you open a Microsoft Excel sheet
you can find boxes so each and every box
is named as a cell and each cell has its
own address for example the highlighted
cell over here has an address B3 so B is
the column name and three is the room
name
and apart from that you can have the
sheet tracker in the bottom left corner
of the Excel sheet where you can
navigate through different sheets
and in the bottom right corner you have
an option of increasing or decreasing
the sheet size so these are the basic
fundamentals of Microsoft Excel that you
need to keep in mind before getting
started so we will have more on this in
the Practical session if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
so now we enter the demo inventory in
Microsoft Excel so we will be using
Microsoft Excel to create a sheet of the
employees in a company
so basically an employee in a company
has employee ID name and designation
salary etc etc so we will be trying to
create the same table using Microsoft
Excel but before that let us understand
the fundamentals of Microsoft Excel
through the Practical demo first so I
have started my Microsoft Excel and this
is how the home page of Microsoft Excel
looks like so you have a blank workbook
over here if you want to create a new
workbook you can select new Option so
Excel will provide you with various
variety of sheets you can see money in
Excel adjustable meeting agenda
streaming show list small business cash
flow and many more if you're not able to
find what you're looking for then you
always have an option of selecting the
particular type of sheet what you're
looking for so you have various options
if it's business if it's personal if
it's planners and trackers list budgets
charts etc etc so let's imagine that you
wanted something from business so just
by clicking at business option the Excel
will load a variety of sheets related to
business options so this might take a
while so you can see that the Excel is
loading few types of sheets
so you can see that Excel has provided
us with some online varieties of sheets
for example any calendar business
expenses Channel marketing budget budget
summary report blue product list etc etc
you can see construction proposal
invoice your name at Excel has got it so
Excel will provide you with some variety
of options based on your requirement now
for this session let's get started with
a blank workbook which looks something
like this since this tutorial is based
on the fundamentals we'll go with the
blank workbook
now over here you can see the toolbar
that we discussed earlier that has the
file home insert draw paste layout
formulas data review View and help so
this is the toolbar and under the
toolbar I have selected home and you can
see this is the particular ribbon what
we discussed about this particular
ribbon belongs to home page and when you
select file option you'll get back to
home and if you select insert option
you'll have another different ribbon
with different groups etc etc so every
particular tool has different ribbons in
them and remember the extra options that
we discussed when you press over this
Arrow key this is it so when you press
the arrow key you'll have few more
settings which cannot be fit in this
particular section of groups so you can
have some variety of options over here
of changing the font changing some FX to
the text font size and font style etc
etc apart from this we have also
discussed about the cells in every sheet
so this particular cell has an address
so you can see the address over here
which is B3 so B happens to be the
column name and three happens to be the
row name now we also had a discussion
about the sheet tracker right now we
just have one sheet if you want multiple
sheets you can just feel free to select
on the plus option which will always
create you some extra sheets and you can
navigate through sheets just by pressing
on the sheet name
and when you get back to the bottom
right corner you have an option of
increasing and decreasing the cell size
or the sheet size now let's keep it
default with hundred percent
now these are the few fundamentals that
you need to keep in mind before getting
started with Microsoft Excel now that we
know the fundamentals of Microsoft Excel
let's get started with a practical
session which is about the employees
details in a company
now let's select this particular cell
let's type in employee details
yeah we have the cell now an employee
details table will have the information
related to employees so the information
will be about name
it will be about employee number
it will be the designation
and maybe salary
and maybe blood group as well
and let's take another one which is
phone number
yeah
so so far so good
and you can see that we have some
problem with this particular column the
designation and the name uh the name of
the designation is practically good but
it is not visible so when you uh when
you're not on that particular cell you
can see that the name is incomplete over
here so you can always fix that you can
just you know manually change the size
of the row or cell or you can also feel
free to you know double click on that
cell which will automatically you know
set the size of that particular cell and
same goes to the blood group just let's
try to double click on that and same
goes to phone number
great
so you can see that the employees
details are just confined to the first
two cells it's supposed to be somewhere
in the middle right so no problem we can
do that as well we can select all the
cells and we have an option of merging
them
you can just select this one which will
help you with merging and centering that
particular data to the center part
so that's how we do it
now let's get started by adding the
names of the employees
let's add the names Joe
John
uh Mary mark
Susan
and then
Jennifer
let's open mic
let's open them
chef
Jeffrey
yeah we have a couple of employees now
let's type in the employee numbers
foreign
yeah we have the employee numbers now
let's type in the designation okay let's
choose uh Joe to be the CEO of the
company
and John as the software developer
and Mary as tester
Mark and finance
Susan also in finance
and Jennifer in testing
and Mike in marketing
same goes for 10.
and again Jeffrey into software
development
and uh
Morgan into testing again
now let's click on C so that it gets you
know resized according to the length of
the text
now it's done so let's get into salary
uh ten thousand dollars
and fifteen thousand dollars
[Music]
and nineteen thousand dollars let's
increase the salary of a CEO so let's
keep it one lakh dollars
and finance again twenty thousand
so yeah the salaries are allocated again
the blood group
foreign
we have the blood groups now let's type
in the mobile numbers
foreign
[Music]
yeah now we have typed in some random
mobile numbers as well
so uh yeah this is how you can add in
some data into your table
and now let us imagine that you forgot
to add or remove a column so let's
imagine that we wanted to add a serial
number as well but somehow we forgot to
add it now you can always add a new row
or column for example here we wanted to
add a new column so we just have to
right click on a select the insert
option
you know we have a new row now
let's type in serial number
and let's type one
now can you see the small box option
over here if you just drag it you can
you know copy paste all those over here
and now let's right click
and
fill series now we have the employee
number starting from 1 to 10. that's how
you do it and apart from this you can
also uh you know change the font of the
entire row you can change the font to
say
aroni and you can always also change the
font
and same goes to the employee table we
can select it bold it and you can also
increase the size and again select a
color for the text maybe a different
color green would be better
and you can also select the entire cells
and align them to the center
looks more good
and you can select or double click the
row names so you'll have the proper
spacing between all the rows and columns
so we have double click on the column
right yeah so basically that's how you
make things happen now let's save this
so I'd like to go to the save option and
amp data
let me save this in my local location
and just save it's done
so that's how you work on your Excel
file with some basic data
and to learn more don't forget to get
subscribed to Simply learns YouTube
channel and don't forget to hit that
Bell icon to stay updated so you are the
first person to get an update on any
technology not just Excel
so slices in Excel are software filters
used along with Excel tables or Excel
pivot tables over a large amount of data
not just filtering out data but slices
also help you with an easy understanding
of the information being extracted and
displayed on the screen now Microsoft
Excel accesses are compatible with
Windows and Macintosh operating systems
now let us understand how to implement
slicers in Excel so for that we might
want to get back to the Practical mode
that is starting a Microsoft Excel
now we are on our Excel sheet and as you
can see on my screen there is some data
available on the Excel spreadsheet and
this table is not just any table this
table from Microsoft Excel has been
converted into an actual table as you
know by default Excel considers all the
data which has been inserted into the
spreadsheet as a database and to
implement this slices in Excel we might
want to create or convert the format of
database into a normal table for that
you can select all your data and just
press Ctrl T and that will allow you an
option called convert the data into
table
now since this table is already
converted as a table we can directly
start implementing or inserting slices
into the spreadsheet
now for that select all your data
then go into the insert option
and in the insert ribbon you can see the
filters group and and in the filters
group select the option called slicer
now you will be provided with multiple
options since we have the columns
employee ID employee name Zone
designation Department salary employees
date of birth and M plus date of Journey
so we can choose any of the options
available according to our columns and
create the slices now let me select the
first one that is Zone next designation
department and let's also select
employee name
now press OK and there you go we have
our slices
now let's try to rearrange these slices
all you can do is just select and drag
them up
and done now let us imagine that we want
to see or take a look at the employees
who are working in the East Zone then we
have all the information displayed on
the screen who are working in the
Eastern they are Jack Tony Banner Fred
Etc and their Department designation etc
etc all on one single screen so this
really helps you while you're presenting
your data in a presentation now for a
change let's try to select the
department now if your client wants to
select the data from only analytics
Department then you might want to select
on the analytics key on the department
slicer and the echo you have an employee
called lookups who works in the East
zoom and his department is analytics and
his resignation is contract
and the salary he is getting is 65
000.
now similarly
uh you can see that we have only
selected analytics and
a client also wants data from I.T
support now you can see that analytics
is gone
but what if we want both analytics and
ID support then you have an option
called selected multiple then you can
select analytics and ID support and if
you want HR you can also do that and in
the zone if you want West along with
East then you can do the same east and
west and you have all the employee
details and in the designation let's try
to Select Senior trainee okay select
multiple senior trainee and manager so
that's how you do it
so that's how it's done and that's how
you implement slicers in Excel to
simplify the filtering options using
slicers during a presentation
Excel Flash Fill is a feature of
Microsoft Excel where Excel can sense a
pattern in a cell and apply the same
logic to extract the similar resultant
pattern out of the remaining cells in a
table
might be a little confusing right so let
us simplify it so let us imagine that
you have a text in one of the cells in
the Excel sheet and you want it to trim
a part of that text for example let us
imagine that there is an assembly an
assembly where the car paths are
assembled together to finish a car so
each and every part has a code the
serial number the product code and the
assembly code Etc right and you wanted
to separate all those three if you
wanted to do that you might want to use
section function which might be a little
tedious to apply to all the cells but
what if if I say there is a simple key
format using which you can fill all the
columns in the Excel sheet within a
fraction of second sounds interesting
right so that's exactly The Flash Fill
function in Excel does
now before we get started let me tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple Technologies if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and don't forget to hit that
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply now without further Ado let's get
started with the Flash Fill in Excel for
that we might want to start the Excel to
get in the Practical mode
now we are on the Microsoft Excel and
remember the example we discussed so
this is a similar example now the first
column in the sheet is the product
detail so this product detail consists
of the product code that is one one two
next we have the product serial number
that is one zero zero two five six three
seven and lastly the assembly code that
is a s and X now we want to separate
this product detail into three columns
where we have the First Column to be
storing the product code second one to
be storing the product serial number and
the last one to be storing the assembly
code so now if you want to do that using
trim function you might want to apply
the trim function here and trim out the
left part and again for the product
serial number you might want to use
certain function again which might go
into a little complicated pattern So to
avoid the complications and and decrease
the time spent we might want to use the
Flash Fill in Excel now let us help
Excel about the pattern that we might
want to generate so the pattern is 1 1 2
and the next one is
three two two so now you can see that
the text was highlighted that was the
intimation from the Excel that it
understood the pattern now going into
the next cell and holding the Ctrl key
and pressing the E button will help us
to fill the remaining cells in the
column B
so that's how it is done and similarly
let's try out for the serial number
for that
the serial number is one zero zero two
five six three seven
now in the next cell we have one zero
zero three six five eight two
now we can go to the third cell and
press Ctrl e for Windows and if you're
using a Mac operating system then you
have to press command e and all these
serial numbers will be filled so this
will reduce the time in separating the
pattern and filling the columns
now let's try the last column that is a
s x which happens to the assembly code
next we have f g and V now the
shortcut method that is Ctrl e and there
you go
now you might be wondering will it work
only for numbers etc etc or the text
which is properly aligned or separated
using a hyphen no it can also be used
for some random text which is like this
so let us imagine that we have a text
which is of length like 20 or 30 and you
wanted to print only a part of it so
here I'm going to print the alphabets
from position fourth to position eight
so I've already tried the first one that
is taking out the alphabets from fourth
location to the eighth location or the
pattern of the text that is i f e r from
Jennifer Lopez and in the next cell we
have the numbers starting from the
location 4 to 8 so that is 7767 and
similarly we have the other cells
consisting of the names of few cars that
is Alpha Romeo Bugatti Veyron and next
we have Superman Returns text so now
let's press the shortcut key that is
Ctrl e and make sure that all the
remaining cells are filled so that's how
the Flash Fill works
so the Flash Fill in Excel will reduce
the time consumed to fill all the
columns by separating the text in your
main cell that is the column A which we
have here in this example and it also
reduces the complexity of using a trim
function in Excel so on my screen you
can see some data related to students
now let us try to duplicate some of the
rows here
so we have selected the rows 8 9 10 and
11. now we shall copy them and paste
them so now these are the duplicate
elements right now there might be
possibilities about the duplication of
class because all the students all the
10 students are in same class so they
might be a duplication but we are not
looking for such kind of duplications
right we are looking for the duplication
of the entire row for example we have
the details of mic over here in the
eighth row which has the roll number of
serial number S7 name as mic roll number
class blood group and subject scores
percentage round of percentage and total
marks so the entire eighth row has been
copied here and it is in the row number
12. we have the exact same details so
what if you have the exact same rows
duplicated so that's what we're gonna
deal with we're gonna eliminate the
duplicate rows all completely together
now to carry over this task we have to
select the data from toolbar so you have
various options file home insert Etc so
you need to select the data and inside
the data toolbar we have the ribbon and
inside ribbon you have got the duplicate
values or remote duplicates option in
the airplane so select all the data
select remove duplicates and now you can
see that we have all our column names
over here and make sure that you have
selected my data as headers and then
select ok
and now you can see that Excel has
automatically removed four duplicate
values
so four duplicate values are found and
removed 10 unique values remain
now another type of remove duplicates
can also be done so you can see that
here we have another data set which has
phone numbers or phone names that is
phone makers that are Samsung Huawei
Vivo Oppo Etc so there are some
duplicate values and this have copy
pasted it then so now you can also do
that so
just select all the data
and now go into home
and select conditional formatting and
here select highlight cell rules and
inside that you have duplicate values
selecting this option will help you
identify the duplicate values in your
data set but not to remove them so you
can select that and you can see the
duplicate values are highlighted over
here in the red color
now again you can get back to data and
select the option of remove duplicates
and select bulky and the duplicate
values will be automatically eliminated
so that's how you delete or eliminate
duplicate values in a data set and you
can also see that we have another
duplicate in this particular row and if
you wanted to select a particular row
and eliminate the duplicate signals to
do that now for that you need to go to
the same process remove duplicates and
here Microsoft Excel is asking you if
you had to expand the selection to the
entire data set or you want to continue
with the selected data set Etc or
selected column itself so for that you
need to select the continue with the
current selection and remove duplicates
and press OK and you can see one
duplicate value is found and it has been
removed and six unique values remain
so that's how you use the function of
removing duplicates in Excel now let's
get back into the Practical mode and
start our Microsoft Excel now we are on
the Microsoft Excel and this particular
spreadsheet is related to employee
details
yeah now the screen is visible a bit
better now let us imagine that this is
our confidential data and you want to
edit only two columns that is the
designation column and phone number
column now let us imagine that the
company has finished one annual year and
now there are some promotions happening
in the company and let us also imagine
that the phone numbers of the employees
provided by the company have undergone
some changes so now the minor edits that
you want to make are related to the
designation column and phone number
column now you can see that all the
columns that is the blood group new
salary salary hike current salary and
name of the employee serial number
employee number everything is editable
so in such kind of scenarios when you
pass on this data there might be a
possibility where your colleague or
subordinate might end up making some
mistakes right so you want to avoid that
so you can do that by locking the cells
now let us rename this sheet
now the sheet has been renamed
successfully so now you can lock the
cells by the following process
so in this process you have two major
steps first one is to log the cells and
the next one is to protect the cells by
a password now when you select all the
cells in this particular sheet you can
just click on this edge here and you
have all the cells selected and now
right click somewhere on the sheet and
you can see an option called format
cells
so in this particular option you have
some options provided which is number
alignment font and you want to go into
the protection part so you can see by
default Excel keeps all the cells locked
now we want the phone number and
designation to be unlocked okay so let's
cancel it for now and get back to the
sheet and select the columns D and I
and now let's right click and go into
format cells and in the protection
option make sure that you uncheck the
locked icon now select OK and now
okay so you cannot include the merge the
self find we have a cell here which is
merged okay let's remove that
okay now again select the entire column
right click get into format cells and
uncheck the log option select ok
now we have finished the first part that
is locking all the cells which you don't
want to get edit and unlocking the cells
where you want to make some edits now
the second stage is protecting the sheet
now right click on the sheet name and
you can see an option called protect
sheet click that and now here you can
see select love cells and also select
unblock cells so let us provide a
password here so let us use some simple
password so that we don't forget that so
I'll be selecting one two three and now
select ok
re-enter the password to proceed now let
us type 1 2 3 again now select OK and
now the sheet is protected
now we have successfully logged and
protected all the cells in Excel now let
us verify that the cells you wanted to
protect are really protected and locked
or not so we have unlocked phone number
and designation and everything else is
locked now let me try and edit the blood
group so when I double click or try to
edit this particular sheet then I'll be
receiving a warning from Excel it says
the cell or chart you are trying to
change is on a protected sheet to make a
change unprotect the sheet you might be
requested to enter a password
so it says that this particular cell is
locked and you cannot edit it now let us
try to edit the phone numbers which we
kept as unblocked
so you can see I can really edit the
unlocked cell here now let me try to
change this phone number let me enter
some random phone number
so you can see the cell is editable now
let us go through the designation column
and try to edit this particular column
now since I said that there's a
promotion happening in the company so
the deputy CEO is now the current CEO of
the company
and software developer happens to become
the cemia software developer
and the tester as well let us imagine
that he will become the senior
and so on
okay so this proves that this particular
sheet is editable not the entire sheet
but only the sense that we kept in the
analog mode
okay
foreign
goal say can excel so for this tutorial
we'll be considering the students
database now let's get back to the Excel
so now we are on the Excel sheet and you
can see that in this particular Excel
sheet we have some student details we
have the serial numbers names row
numbers class blood group and some
subjects like math science computer
statistics social GK and the final marks
obtained percentage and total marks
right so let us imagine that a company
has come for an interview
so all these students are going to
attend an interview and the minimum
percentage to attend the interview will
be like 75 percent so you can see that
we have 75 here and all the students
have got above 75 except for the one
student which is Mike right so for Mike
to attend the interview he needs 75
percentage or above
so uh he can make some modifications in
one of these subjects right so there is
always an exam after the exam called as
Improvement exam so if you can like this
course and extra marks in the subjects
which you have scored less so that you
can make up to the percentage what
you're expecting you can do that so here
in this particular sheet uh Mike has six
subjects right and in such subjects you
can see he has scored 76 91 45 71 94 and
62. so out of these he have scored less
and one subject compared to all the
subjects one subject is really low that
is computers so what if he can give an
improvement exam and increase his
percentage to 75 right so that can be
done so if we can do some Brute Force
methods like we can change the marks
like 55 and then check this particular
one so it's getting 74 right so using
the brute force method will be a little
bit lengthy so you can do this because
it is just a small table which has least
number of data and you just have one
single cell to modify so that can be
done in small tables but what if you had
some table with hundreds of rows or
thousands of rows that will be time
consuming right so for that we have some
inbuilt functionality in Excel that is
called goal seek in Excel
so for now let's eliminate the marks
here
so we have eliminated the marks and the
upgraded percentage is 65. now we need
the target as 75. okay so let's write it
as
Mike's Target right you need mic so mics
new Target as
[Music]
okay now to make sure that we need a
Mark here which can get mic to 75
percentage we will use the data
operation so here on the toolbar which
has file home insert Etc we have one
other option called as data so when you
click on data from toolbar you'll have
this ribbon and in this ribbon we have
various options so when you come into
forecast group we have an option called
what if analysis when you click on
what-if analysis you'll have a set of
options out of which we have goal seek
now for goal seek we need to select a
table cell that is this particular table
cell that is M9 so we need the value 75
here right so what is the cell that you
need to change here for that you need to
select this one and select this
particular cell here right and now you
can select ok now you can see that Excel
has automatically run all the
permutations and combinations and has
come up with a number so that the
overall percentage of mic will be 75
percent right so the expected marks that
Mike should be getting in his computers
Improvement exam should be equal to 56
or greater than 56 to get the final
Target as 75 so that he can attend the
company's interview so this is how we
use goal set or goal seek in Excel how
to add tick mark in Excel now on my
spreadsheet you can see some employee
data so they've been assigned a task and
they want to update the task status as
done and not done using symbolic
statements that is tick mark and into
marks now how to do that it is really
simple we'll discuss two different ways
the first way is to do it by conditional
formatting so click a cell on the task
status go to conditional formatting
click on the neural yes of course we can
use the icon settings but we want to
automate it so click on the new rule
right so here instead of two color scale
select icon sets now go to the settings
here we don't want the third symbol so
select no cell icon and here instead of
percentage number formula let's add just
a simple number and the second one as
well just a simple number now in the
icon settings select tick mark you have
various types of them you know the
circular Tech Market let's select the
generic tick mark without any outer
circles and into here generic X Mark and
now let's set the values when the value
is greater than 0 it will be green and
when the value is less than or equal to
0 it will be X and the reference value
is 0 and here also the reference value
is 0 everything is okay click on OK and
done
and here you cannot see the logos here
we need to add some formula here which
is equals to F click on Tab to select
the simple and if Cell address C2 is
equals to done
then the value should be 1 else the
value should be 0 close the bracket
enter
right now you can see this particular
logo here now drag the same formula it's
done now you can see we do have numbers
you can eliminate those numbers as well
just edit the rules
and here you can see show icon only
click OK and the numbers will be removed
also I did the second one and there you
go the numbers are gone and only the
symbols remain now what is the second
technique the second technique is
available in the developer options you
can activate it by you know going into
the options here go to file and here go
to options and here go to Advanced
customize weapon and in here on the
right hand side you will get developer
options click on the tick box and it
will be enabled now go into developer
options and click into insert menu click
on the form controls are active X
controls select the check box and now
just place it over here you know you can
edit this particular checkbox delete
everything drag it as checkbox as well
now you can drag the same cell across
all the functions and you will have the
check box as well now you can click on
it and say if it's done or not how to
add Excel document into PowerPoint
presentation now let us assume that you
are giving an important presentation and
you're also requested by a manager to
add the Excel document that you have
used to create that particular report
which would be something like this when
you click on it it will open a new Excel
document or Excel Window with all the
data in it right so how do we do that
let's look at the demo now let's have a
blank slide and let's get back to this
Source where our Excel file is located
that is in my documents so we are
currently in my documents and we have
the Excel file which we used for
creating that particular report now if
we copy and try to paste it on our Excel
document it would look something like
this
and clearly it's not visible and it's
not accessible right so instead of this
there is another way where you can
directly add the Excel document in the
form of logo which is a rather simple
idea all you have to do is just click on
the insert option in the toolbar then
navigate to the text group and here you
will find the option called object click
on the object and it will give you a new
window where you can identify which type
of document or object you want to add
either create or create from file so we
have the file in our local system so
we'll choose create from file browse and
from browse we will go into the
documents section where we have our
Excel file click on the Excel file and
click on ok now if you want the data or
Excel file to be displayed in the form
of an icon then click on the display as
icon section and here you can change the
icon so you can choose any one of the
given options let's choose this
particular one and click on OK another
okay and there you go the icon will be
now displayed on your Microsoft
PowerPoint PPT which is completely
clickable as the previous one
whenever you click on this the Excel
document will be opened so that's how
you add Excel document into Microsoft
PowerPoint how to modify or increase
cell size in Excel now most of you might
probably want to increase just the sales
error here just to increase the
visibility of the text so one of the
easiest way is just to press on the plus
icon on the bottom right corner of your
Excel spreadsheet so this will
automatically increase the text size and
you can see the text more clearly now
apart from that if it's just not that
what you want to do you can also modify
by hovering over to the line between two
columns and right click which will give
you the option of format cells or column
width so either of these options will
help you to maximize or minimize your
column width
similarly you can apply the same idea
for your rows as well so you can either
format the cells or modify the row
height of your cell and this is another
way and another simple way is to just
hold that line and drag it so it
improves your width of the column and
another way is to just hover onto that
line and hold it and drag it to
improvise or increase your width of the
cell and SEMA plus to your rope so this
is another way so apart from that there
is another way that is format cells from
this particular option in the home
button you can select this and here you
have the row height out of it row height
column width auto fit column width for
example let us imagine that you wanted
to you know just by mistake you uh you
increase the cell size and you want it
to restore it back to the original thing
right so you can just click on the
autofit height and click on the order
fit called width then you go it happens
in that way and now coming back to
another
simplest way let us imagine that you are
given a lot of data and you are told to
go to fit all the rows and columns now
we have already seen the format cell
option where I will auto fit all the
columns and width of the column and also
the height of the rows Etc right but
there is also a keyboard shortcut to do
this so all you have to do is select a
cell and press Ctrl a to select all the
cells in the spreadsheet and once all
the cells are selected all you have to
do is press and hold ALT key and then
release it then the combination of keys
that is h o i
so your column width has been now
adjusted now the same formula or the
same shortcut key with a small
modification press and hold and release
ALT key now h o and a to adjust the row
height so this is the way where you can
increase or decrease or modify or
autofit all the cells in Excel how to
group rows and columns in Excel now on
my spreadsheet you can see some data
which is the sales data of quarterly
basis and the four different zones that
is North West South East so you can you
know make things look better by hiding
these columns and if you hide these
columns it's critical for the end user
to identify which columns are exactly
hidden right to make things a little
easier for your end user you can select
the columns and then go to the data
option and in the data option click on
the group option so this will go group
these columns and you will have the
symbol of minimization which will help
you hide these columns automatically and
unhide these columns automatically now
let's also try to group ghij columns
and there you go now similarly let's
also try to group the rows of North
and rows of West
then you have the rows of South
and Rose of yeast
right now all these rows and columns
have been grouped now all you can do is
just click on the minimize button and
those will be minimized similarly the
rows right
and to unhide them all you can do is
click on the plus icon and they will be
unhidden
you can also try to ungroup the columns
and rows all you have to do is select
the columns and click on the ungroup
option similarly the rows as well
and that's how you can group and ungroup
rows and columns in Excel how to count
colored cells in Excel now here on my
spreadsheet you can see some data so
this particular data has some color
markings so we have used color codes to
Mark the designations of all the
employees with different colors so for
example blue for manager purple for
senior and so on right now our duty is
to count the total number of employees
present in a company based on the color
code this can be done using filters but
let's try with color tools now we don't
have a readily available function in
Excel to count cells based on their
colors but we can make use of macro now
to make use of macro you might want to
enable the developer options so by
default these will be disabled in Excel
to enable them right click on the
toolbar
and you can see this particular option
click on the customize ribbon option and
you will be provided with various set of
options
now on the right side you can see
developer options
so make sure the check box is clicked to
enable developer options and press on OK
to completely enable developer window
right now when you click on developer
options you can see various options here
visual Basics macro Etc now click on the
macro to create a macro now just give a
name to the macro function so I'll give
simply learn
and press on create to create that
particular macro function
so we have already created a macro that
is Count colored says which we will be
using in our current spreadsheet for
counting the colored cells now let us
erase the newly created function
now getting back to the original code so
how does this particular count colored
cells works so let us understand the
function first then we will try to make
use of it in this spreadsheet so the
function name is Count colored cells as
you can see and this particular function
will have two parameters current cell
and spreadsheet area so the current cell
will be the cell address where the color
you want to count is present and then
the spreadsheet area so what is the
range of cells where you want to locate
that particular color and count the
number of repetitions that is the
spreadsheet area and then comes the
variables used colored cell range color
code and color cell count so the colored
cell which particular cell is having
that particular color and what color
code is involved in that colored cell
and colored cell count so what is the
total count what is the total number of
colored cells you have in that
particular range that is colored cell
count now let us consider color code is
equals to current cell interior color
that is credential dot interior dot
color so this is the function which will
identify the interior color of a
selected cell let us imagine that
initially color code is equals to the
current cells color code okay now we
will have the for Loop and that for Loop
will include colored cell which is the
current cell in the spreadsheet area and
if the colored cell the currently
selected colored cell dot interior dot
color is equals to the color code that
we have selected then colored cell count
the variable which is used to count the
number of colored cells is equals to
plus one initially by default it will be
0 in case if this particular if
condition is true that is the current
cell color and the color code given is
equals to same then the value of colored
cell will increase by 1. and this
particular if Loop will run as many
number of times the condition is true so
let us imagine that the condition will
remain true for five times then we have
obtained five similarly colored cells in
the given range of cells in a
spreadsheet and once the condition fails
then the latest value present in colored
cell count variable will be displayed
which will be a final result so this is
how the macro function works now let's
close the macro window and get back to
our spreadsheet now let us try to make
use of the macro function that we just
created so that is equals to count
colored cells press tab to select the
macro function and the first one is the
current cell so this is the current cell
where the current color has been
provided comma this cell range so our
cell range will be from c 2 to c31
right so this is the range where we want
to count the similarly colored cells
that is sky blue colored cells close the
function and press enter now you can see
the function has identified six
repetitions of sky blue color in this
particular range of cells now you can
drag the same formula across all the
cells and it will be
providing the results of the same so six
senior colors that is pink or purple
color then two repetitions of this
particular color two repetitions of
trainy color five for dark blue and six
for green right so this is how the macro
function works and the key point to
remember here is this particular macro
will work only for manually colored
cells so there are situations where we
have used conditional formatting to
color a single cell let us imagine that
we have used conditional formatting to
recognize the employees with salary
above 30 000 as green color and if we
try to use that particular green color
to be counted by the color count cells
function now it will not happen it will
not consider that color as a feedback or
an input now in future we will also try
to design a macro which can recognize
the colors made by conditional
formatting as well but this particular
function will be exclusively used for
manually colored cells only how to add
date in Excel spreadsheet now there are
multiple ways to add date to Excel
spreadsheet for example equals to today
this is a shortcut method and you can
enter
then you will have today's date but
again
there is some problem with this kind of
approach so today's state is 4th of
September 2022 now if we open the same
spreadsheet after today let us tomorrow
or day after tomorrow then you will have
a concurrent date that is 5th of
September or 6th of September right the
date will always vary or get updated
according to time now you don't want to
change that or you don't want that to be
happening with M Plus data joining right
it should be stagnant it should not vary
right so there is another shortcut way
apart from using the date time functions
there is a keyboard shortcut where you
can add date to excel that is control
semicolon so this is the shortcut way to
add date to your Excel spreadsheet and
this particular date will not change
this will remain the same constant date
throughout the time now there is a
chance where you might also have to add
time to your spreadsheet that is data
joining and time of joining right so
there is another simple shortcut where
you can add time by just pressing three
keys that is holding Ctrl holding shift
and pressing semicolon then you'll have
the time
so this is how you can add date to your
Excel spreadsheet and add time to your
Excel spreadsheet and this date and time
will remain constant it will not vary
like the 3D function that we have used
here how to add Watermark to excel
now on my sheet you can see some data so
here we wanted to add some Watermark
logo to your Excel spreadsheet so that
it looks genuine and work by you right
so that's the overall idea of adding a
watermark now go to the insert window
and in the insert window go to the text
option click on that select header and
footer once you select header and photo
you can see something on your screen
like this so in this box which is
highlighted by a cursor is where you are
going to add the picture on my top in
the menu bar you can see header and
footer elements in this select the
picture element and it will navigate to
you to a different option window since
we are adding the image from our local
system select from file or if you are
adding from your Bing or any search
window you can also add that or OneDrive
as well but now let's go with from file
it will directly navigate you to the
pictures folder in your local system so
here is my simply launch logo click on
it and select insert now you can see the
images added in this format which is
Ampersand and picture and you might
wonder where is the picture it is
actually present to view it click on any
cell in the spreadsheet and there you go
you can see it now you might be
wondering the image is a little towards
top and abnormally placed right so no
worries you can always you know format
your picture just press enter and use
enter to move your picture towards the
center of your data spreadsheet and also
there is another option of format
picture altogether here you can adjust
the height and width of your image by
you know increasing and decreasing width
or increasing and decreasing height
using the arrow marks also works and
apart from this there is another option
of picture formatting where you can
choose your image to be washing out
black and white grayscale or anything so
currently I am going with automatic
which will automatically adjust the
brightness and you know everything for
your image it looks perfectly fine so
click on OK and there you go right so
now
this should be fine
right now everything is done and
everything is automatically saved if you
are having that auto save option on your
spreadsheet and let's go back to the
normal view from the header and footer
view click on The View and go to normal
you might be confused right where is
Hello going to vanished it I have to
save it no it's already saved everything
is fine even the image is there but you
cannot see it in normal view to see it
click on file click on print then you
can see the logo it will be present only
on the printed Pages not on the normal
view how to sort data in Excel so on my
spreadsheet you can see some employee
data and on the column F and the g you
can see employee date of birth and
employee native joining for example you
wanted to sort the employee data in the
form of earliest joining employee and
the latest joining employer right that
is who is the employee who joined first
to this company and who is the employer
who joined loss to this company so for
that you just need to select the column
of date so let's select both the columns
and go to home and check or verify if
the data type is date or not so
generally the data type will be set to
General by default by Excel so we need
to make sure that we have the proper
data type which is State now that we
have the proper data type select the
entire column and go to the data option
and here select the sort option add in
the sort option select the expand
selection click on sort and here sort by
employee date of joining and oldest to
news that's what we wanted the oldest
employee or the you can also set it to
the newest employer tools according to
your requirement but we'll go to oldest
to newest according to the case study
right now just click on OK and that
should be done so Emily was a manager is
the oldest employee who joined the
company and Chris who's a trainee and it
support is the latest employer who
joined the company now that's how you
sort date in Excel how to convert
numbers to words
now here on my sheet you can see we have
some numbers that is ten dollars or ten
point two zero dollars twenty two
dollars fifty three point one two
dollars twelve dollars and hundred and
ten dollars now the task is to convert
these numbers into word format that is
representing the numbers alphabetically
right this might be a little curious and
we also might end up searching for a
predefined method which is not readily
available in Excel but there is a way
where you can create a function using
Excel VBA or macros now again creating a
macro is completely complex now
identifying the trouble Microsoft has
already come up with a readily available
macro code on their official website
which will support the various versions
of Microsoft Excel starting from
Microsoft Excel 365 to all the way up to
the older Excel version that is 2010.
now you can scroll down and use this
particular macro function which
Microsoft has readily made us available
and use this to create our own macro and
Excel VBA now let's get back to Excel
and you can create a macro using the
developer option now developer options
will not be readily available in
Microsoft Excel to activate developer
option go to home and go to the options
menu in the last
and here go to customize ribbon and here
in the second drop down menu you can see
developer option by default it will not
be checked click on the check option to
activate developer options and press ok
now you have your developer options
ready click on developer options click
on Visual Basic and here to insert a new
macro click on the insert button click
on module and a new macro window is
readily available for you now Ctrl V to
paste your code and your function is
with the name number to text right now
close the macro
foreign
will be readily available
equals to and the function name was
number to text press tab to select the
function and select the cell where you
have the data close the function press
enter now drag the same formula across
all the cells and here you have the text
converted from numbers so here we have
10. 20 cents and you have ten dollars
twenty cents twenty two dollars and no
sense 53 dollars and twelve cents 12
dollars and no sense and 110 dollars
with no sense now that's how you can
convert numbers to words using the macro
which is predefined for excel in the
Microsoft website how to add rows and
Excel for that let's get back to the
Practical mode now we are on the Excel
spreadsheet
now here we have some sales data based
on a store now what we are going to do
is we are going to add some multiple
rows or a single Row in this particular
data so here you can see the region wise
category Wise statewise subcategory Wise
and there are sales and quantities right
now let us imagine that you must start
to add a sale data here right so let us
imagine that on the row seventh you are
supposed to add some detail for example
some technology related sale happen on
that day and you missed out to add it
right so how do you create a new row now
so for example if multiple sales
happened on the same day like three to
four and you missed out them so how do I
add three to four rows in between the
existing data right so don't worry about
it it's completely simple all you have
to do is select the row and right click
and press on the option insert now this
will insert one single row if you wanted
to add one single uh row or a tuple and
if you wanted to add multiple rows for
example you wanted to add three rows all
together then it's also simple all you
have to do is select three rows
and right click and press on insert and
then you have three rows so there you go
so that's how you add multiple rows in a
Excel spreadsheet or that's how you add
one single Row in an Excel spreadsheet
how to add two columns in Excel
so first let us assume that we are
trying to add two columns in Excel which
has textual kind of data this type of
data can be added using the concat
function which is a string concatenation
function in Excel so type in concat
press Tab Key to select the function the
first cell that is A2 and next the
second cell that is V2 separated by
comma press enter and there you go now
you can see we don't have a space so you
can modify the formula
add space
double quotes
space double quotes comma press enter
there you go now you can drag the same
formula across all the cells and you
have it now coming to the last column
where we literally have numbers right so
you can add two different numbers over
here either you can select the first
cell that is D2 plus E2 and press enter
and you get the number or you can use
the sum function
tap to select and
one
two press enter
or another simplest way is select all
the blank output cells so these are the
cells where you are expecting an output
of two cells that is column entire
column D and entire column e right now
after selecting the blank cells of f
column or the resultant column press the
shortcut key that is alt equals to
so this is the shortcut method to call
the sum function and assign the cell
values of individual columns that is d
and e and get the resultant cell in F
column right so remember the shortcut
key that is alt e AutoFill in Excel
now AutoFill in Excel is a feature where
you can add some series automatically
using Excel for example let us imagine
that you wanted to add index numbers
right so starting from 1 to 10. so
manually you will be typing in the
numbers and you'll be doing it right so
instead of this what if I said you there
was a simple way where Excel will fill
all the data for you right so just start
with one
Google and select these two cells and
you can see the slash logo over here
right so that's the indication that
Excel has understood your pattern and it
is ready to fill the remaining numbers
so as long as you drag this logo or that
ending part where you have a small
square box that will fill all the
numbers until where you are dragged it
so that's how autofill works and you
might be wondering will it work only for
numbers
no it will also work on some Logics as
well okay this was the first part let us
also look at some other tricks with
autofill now most of the time you might
be just adding one number and try to
drag that cell and the result is it will
copy the same number all the time right
so you can change it by clicking on this
menu
you can click on fill series and it will
change to series and this was one more
trick with numbers now getting back to
the next type so let us imagine now the
next type of series you want to add is
weeks in a day right so you will be
having Monday
Tuesday Wednesday right so you can also
do the series of weekdays using AutoFill
in Excel as well so drag that cell and
it will give you all the days or
weekdays in a week
now let's try January
and this will give you the months in a
year
in the shortcut way right since you've
just added the first three letters of
the month it will recognize the pattern
and it will do the same for you now let
us try the full names of months
right and now let's try to drag it it'll
fill all the full names of all the
months
now
let's try the dates so let us imagine
that this is the first day of the
current year
right it will now give you all the dates
of that current month or until the end
of the year as well
there you go now let us imagine that
your manager tells you to add the dates
of working days in the month of January
so how can you do that it's simple all
you need to do is select the cell go to
the fill option select series and here
select column wise since you want the
dates and columns and here in the type
select date date unit should be weekday
and the stock value should be the next
month right since your manager asked for
the weekdays of January so your stock
value will be the first of February
press OK and there you go so since the
first of January is Friday that's
selected over here and the rest to
Saturday and Sunday are eliminated
similarly we have all the dates here of
working days only so that's how you use
AutoFill in Access how to create a
barcode in Excel now for this let's get
on to the Practical mode by starting our
Microsoft Excel
now we're on the Practical mode that is
mfxn now you can see that we have the
First Column that is a column and the
first set of that is text and all the
other cells are numbers but as a whole
Excel considers the whole column as a
general data format so why have we
discussing about this so to create a
barcode in Excel you have to make sure
that all the elements in the column are
of Text data type so the first step is
to convert this General data type to
Text data type so you can do that by
going into the data type and selecting
text and now all the elements in your
first column A are type text
now the next step is to convert these
elements into barcode now for that let's
create a new column called barcode
now our new column that is barcode has
been created
now the next step would be is to check
for the barcode font so the barcode font
looks something like this but let me
remind you the barcode found in Excel is
not available by default
open source so let's go back to Google
so on the Google you want to search for
barcode font for Excel so the one that I
would recommend is three of nine barcode
font
now you can download this font by just
clicking on the download button over
here now I've already downloaded this
font on my local system let's now try to
install that
now the three of nine barcode folder
will come in the form of zip folder you
have to unzip that
and after unzipping you will get the
setup file which looks something like
this which is three of nine new select
that and you'll be having the installer
file over here you can install by
selecting the install button over here
so I have already installed it in my
local system so it is readily available
for me on my Microsoft Excel now we
might want to create the barcode for
this particular cell in A2 so let's
create that so to create a barcode we
need to write in a formula that is
equals to double quotes
star double quotes and Ampersand symbol
address of the cell that is A2 another
Ampersand symbol again double quotes
star symbol and double quotes
so you can either use this or instead of
star you can use brackets as well
so let's try brackets
now select enter
now this will generate another type of
code in your resultant cell now we will
change the font for this particular
resultant cell and we will get our
barcode now you can just drag all these
cells so that you can apply the formula
to all the codes and I got all the codes
over here
now select all the cells get into the
fonts and here select the barcode font
and there you go you have the barcode
for all the
numbers you have in your column A so
that's how you create barcode in Excel
page setup and Ms Excel
so to understand the page setup in Ms
Excel we will go through a demo
inventory in Excel where we'll be
considering some restaurant data
now without any delay let's get started
with the Practical demo now we are on
the extent sheet and this is the date I
was talking about the restaurant data
where we have the First Column that is
Rank and next we have the restaurant
name followed by that we have the sales
happening through that restaurant and
then we have the segment category that
is what kind of service does that
particular restaurant offers now this is
the list what we made and what if we
wanted to represent this data and form
of a printed paper right so I guess you
can see all the columns and rows here so
you can see that we have almost like 250
rows so there is no chance or there is
no way to print all those 250 rows in
one page of course it is practically
possible but when you try to read the
content it'll be so tough to read
Because all the rows will be club
together so closely so that you cannot
read it so uh you need to print them
Page by page so and you need to also
take care of the data is aligned
properly according to the page size
everything and even you need to take
care of the margins of your page right
so that's what pace data basically means
so we had a detailed overview of our
data and what actually we are trying to
make now let us see how page setup is
possible in Ms Excel so to go to the
page setup menu or go to the page setup
options we have three methods let's
start with the simplest method so the
simplest method is by just clicking on
file and go to print option
and you'll see all the page setup
options right over here
and you can also go to print menu by
pressing a shortcut method that is Ctrl
p
so you'll directly end up on the page
setup options now let's look at the
second method so the second method is
you can see the toolbar over here right
which has file home insert draw page
layout formulas data review View and
help so the second method we can use
page layout option from the toolbar and
you can see when you click on the page
option from the toolbar you have a new
ribbon over here so this ribbon is all
about page setup options so it will
offer you margins it will offer you
orientation size print area breaks
background print tiles etc etc right so
all these options are menus in this
ribbon belong to page setup now let us
look at the third method so the third
method is something similar you have
view option on the toolbar so just
select a view and you can see we have
few page setup options over here as well
the normal page break page layout custom
views and we have gridlines formula bar
heading zoom and zoom out select to zoom
free certain pins right so all these are
also the page setup options so we have
the three methods to enter the page
setup options now we are familiar
earlier with those now let's get started
with the Practical mode on page setup
for that let me use the simplest method
that is holding the control key and
pressing P which navigates me to the
print option
now we have various set of options here
we have no scaling normal margins letter
portrait orientation collated print
active sheets and Note 1 for Windows you
can see this option is the printers
option for example if you are connected
to a printer which is the hardware
printer then your Ms Excel will show the
printers name here so other than printer
you can also make some other
arrangements where you can just directly
print your complete data in the form of
PDF and then you can export your PDF to
your recipient that's also possible okay
now let's get started with the first
option that is print active pages okay
to understand this better we need to
create a new sheet not a problem so you
can see that we just have one sheet over
here
so let us kind of select all the items
and create a new sheet and try to paste
it over here
or let's try to paste it over here
okay now let's try to extend these
yeah this should be fine now let's
rename this sheet
sheet
or let's rename it as
restaurant
sheet 2.
for our reference now let us get back to
the print sheet option so I'll use the
shortest method that is holding the Ctrl
key and press P now you can see that
here we have six pages in total from the
active sheets so the current active
sheet is the top 250 sheet so this
particular sheet is the current active
sheet so if we print the entire data in
this particular sheet then we will end
up printing six pages now let us select
the other option where you have to print
the entire workbook right so now you can
see that there's the change in the
number that is 12 pages so what is a
workbook so basically workbook is the
collection of entire sheets and your
Excel home page so in this particular
Excel homepage you have the first sheet
that is top 250 and the second sheet
that is the restaurant sheet 2 right so
the combination of these two sheets make
up a workbook
so when you select the entire workbook
option you'll have 12 pages so that's
how we use this setting where you select
the active sheets the entire workbook
and there is another option where you
can only print a selected item so if you
want to do this then let's get back here
now what if your customer or what if
your client wanted the top 10
restaurants only so you can select the
top 10 restaurants
foreign
doing this
now you have the top 10 restaurants
let's go to print
so you can see Excel has automatically
selected the selection only print the
selected content only so you can see we
have only the top 10 restaurants or top
11 restaurants that we have selected in
our sheet and it is ready to get printed
so this is how we use the first option
now let's get back
let's not select that and let's make the
pages normal now get back to the print
option again now you can see the next
option that is collated
right so in collated you have different
different options that is one two three
one two three and one two three and the
next one which is uncolluted one one one
two two two three three three so why are
these numbers present here and what does
collected mean anyway so this is a
question right now the answer for this
question will be a little similar to
your examination Hall okay let us
imagine that you are in examination Hall
and you are the invisilator and you have
10 students in your room
so you wanted to provide question papers
to all the 10 students okay so you have
your question paper distributed into
three sheets that is you have marked
questions and your questions are fit
into three papers right in this scenario
we have 250 rows and all the data is
split into six sheets that is sheet 1 or
page 1 page two page 3 page four right
now if you wanted to print 10 copies
then the arrangement of papers will be
page 1 page 2 page three page 4 page
five page six in continuous order right
that is collated if you wanted 10 copies
of different different ways where you
wanted to print the first sheet first
then you wanted to print the second
sheet second and the third sheet third
that is you'll have 10 copies of first
page 10 copies of second page 10 copies
of third page and so on that particular
approach is called uncolated approach
and if you are printing the pages in
continuous order for 10 times then that
particular approach is called as
correlated approach so this is what we
had to learn about collated and
uncolluted now let's get back to the
third option
now let's just again print now we have
our data over here
there is something wrong
select all the elements Ctrl P yeah now
we have our data pack now we have the
third option that is the portrait
orientation okay so when we click that
we have two options that is portrait and
landscape so you might be having a good
idea like when you try to click a
picture in your phone we have two modes
as well that is portrait mode and the
landscape mode so when you click on the
portrait mode this is how your data will
be looking now to understand the
difference let's click the landscape
mode so when you click the landscape
mode this is how your data
representation will change you'll have a
wider page to print so this is why we
use the page orientation for now let's
keep the page orientation as portrait
orientation
and we have now the fourth option so
what is the fourth option we have
various sets of options in here that is
letter and A4 size there are also some
more page options over here where you
can select the page types you want to
print
so basically you'll be having few more
options that is A4 A5 A3 Etc but here we
just have two that is A4 and letter so
basically you'll get those options and
followed by that next we have margins so
here you can see we don't have any
margins for our data okay so now we can
add some margins by setting up this one
as an option like last custom setting or
you can also choose normal wide narrow
right so your page will be changed
according to your margin size
right so this is how you can change the
margins now let's keep it as default
let's set the
normal one
now we have the next option that is
scaling option
so here you can see we are trying to fit
the page so when you're trying to print
these sheets using no scaling then the
actual size of the page will be printed
now we can also modify that you can fit
and print these sizes so you can
remember the first option that I said of
printing all the 250 rows in one single
sheet this is how you can fit it so fit
the sheet on one page where you can see
all the 250 rows are fit into one page
but the data is not readable so but we
don't want this type of an approach
right so let's keep it as the default
one which is no scaling so these are the
variety of options in print
now if you wanted to print the all the
six pages into the PDF format and mail
it to your client you can also do that I
think I have explained it in the first
place so you can see we can do it by
just selecting this option where you can
print all the six pages and into PDF
format and then you can mail them to
your client
and you can also select the number of
copies you want you can increase the
copies to 2 3 and any number of copies
you want for now I'll keep it as one
copy
[Music]
now let's print this
now let us select the
location
rename it and publish
now let's get back to documents and see
if the page is printed or not
here you go here we have the restaurant
data in the form of PDF
so we have our entire six pages of data
in the PDF format
now we are back on the home page now we
have some limited functions in the print
functions over here
we have tried to export the data so you
can also export the data or try to print
it from the print option over here you
can just select that as well
delete the modified
PDF
yes the pages are printed now
there you go we have the restaurant 2
PDF data
so that's how you can print all your
data you can either choose
the export option or you can either
choose print option now when you see
into the print option we have limited
number of page setup options over here
now let's check out what we missed so we
are in the page layout here so we had
gone through the margins we had set all
the margins and then we have also gone
through the portrait and landscape now
you can see this size when Weaver in the
print menu option we had only A4 and
letter but here you can see there are a
wide variety of options that is other
than later we have tabloid legal
statement executive A3 right we have A5
and many more other options and if you
want some more paper options you can go
to more and you can always select few
more options that's how you do it and
yeah we didn't had the break option so
remember when we had been through the
print option we did not have the break
option there
let's select this to normal A4 so you
cannot see the break option over here
right so here we have the brick option
so what does break option does right you
can actually break the page remember we
spoke about the top 10 things or the top
10 rows you can always do that so you
can just keep the top 10 restaurants in
your first page and then break the
remaining and to set page breaks you can
select the cell now I need the top 10 so
I'll select this particular cell which
is in the 11th position
and now I'll try to implement the page
trick insert a page break and now you
can see on my sheet there is a thin line
which is separating the two pages that's
how you can see the indication of app
page break implemented onto your page
now how do you see it you can see it by
selecting Ctrl P where you can see the
first top 10 restaurants being printed
on your sheet so there you go we have
the first top 10 restaurants printed on
our sheets so that's how you use the
page break
now let's try to eliminate all the paste
tricks so you can select next and reset
all paste tricks so the page break has
been eliminated
now you can always choose a background
for your data as well you just if you
want you can add a picture to your
background I think that's not
available for now
okay you can work offline as well
let us select this one
so you can see that we have added a
background to our data
we can select all the text files and
then you can change the color so that
the text becomes a little visible yeah
that's how you do it now if you don't
want the image to be added on your file
you can also remove that delete piece
background and there you go all the
images are gone
now the next important part that is the
print titles
now why do we need print titles for that
let's try to print this
so now you can see the first page in the
first page we have the title rank
restaurant sales segment category but if
you go to the second page you don't have
that title right you don't have the
title rank name of the restaurant sales
and their service category so if we want
that then we need to add Titans
now for that let's select the print
titles option
now let's select the rows to repeat on
top
now for that we need the first row
select the first row and this particular
row will be repeating into all the pages
now let's try to print it
so yeah now you can see the titles are
being added to all the sheets you can
see the page 2 page 3 page 4 page 5 and
page six so you can see the titles added
to all the sheets
so that's our USD print titles option
let's look at one more interesting
feature of Excel and that's your
conditional formatting now as you see on
the screen conditional formatting has
different rules which can be applied on
your data and that allows you to
basically differentiate or easily
identify data values which are
based on certain criterias or rules so
when you talk about conditional
formatting you have different options
such as you can highlight cell rules you
can get top and bottom values you can
apply different rules apply different
color scales and you you can easily
manage these rules so conditional
formatting is very useful for people who
would want to work on huge amount of
data and easily perform some data
analysis
it's easy to use as it is shown here and
with your conditional formatting
you can format cells based on a preset
condition you can perform conditional
formatting to identify cells you can
highlight a few significant cells and
you can easily perform conditional
formatting as shown on the left side
now how do we work with conditional
formatting let's have a quick look so
say for example we have our Excel sheet
and if you see here I am highlighting
the sales person who have generated
Revenue greater than 10 000.
so we can be looking at the values where
the revenue generated by a particular
sales person is greater than 10 000 it
has a particular
color and how do we get here so for
example let's select this data
and what I could do is
I could go into conditional formatting
now I could basically highlight cell
rules and we could just say greater than
that's an easier way I could also go
ahead and create a new rule but then I
can use one of this option I can say
greater than and let's give some value
might be we would be interested in
looking at any value greater than 12 000
so let's choose 12.
thousand
and here it says what color would you
want to select so for example I would
say something like
yellow filled with dark yellow text
and let's say okay so right now what I'm
doing is I have all the values where the
revenue generated was greater than 10
000 but then I have also selected all
the sales people who have made or who
have generated Revenue greater than 12
000. so I can just do a Ctrl Z to see
the previous result now here I had the
values which were greater than 10 000
and the one which we did just now
basically
highlighted the values which are greater
than 12 000. so this is one simple
example now we can look at some other
examples say for example you want to
format cells using three color scale so
if you look at the values here I have a
three color scale mainly in green yellow
and red and how do you do this so for
example I can go in here and I can go to
conditional formatting so I would want
to go for color scales and here you can
create different rules so we can set up
a two color scale so we can say format
only values that are above and below
average I can format only cells that
contain something I can get the top and
bottom value so these are different ways
in which I can have a three color based
scale now what I will do is I will
select this and let me show you the rule
which I have so for example I can go
into manage rules and if you see here
there are certain rules which have been
specified now what does that mean so you
would want to specify a three grade
scale so for example if I would want to
look at my first rule it tells me that I
am choosing three color scale I can
choose lowest value percentile and
highest value and that basically will
select the cells based on their values
so what we could have done is I can
basically
use one of these values I can delete
these rules which I have created so for
example I have all these rules but you
should always carefully remember that
the rules will be applied in the order
shown so for example if I just delete
these rules
and then say apply and say okay my data
is back now it does not have any
highlighting now I can go in here I can
say condition sorry conditional
formatting I could go for color scale so
I could basically go into
new rule so I would want
the
cells to be using three color scale so
let's
choose three color scale now when you
say three color scale it says what will
be the color of lowest value
and we could choose might be any one of
this let's choose red I can say midpoint
is percentile 50 and then the highest
value is green and if that looks good
let's say okay and now if you see the
lowest values have been highlighted as
red you have mid values and then you
have the positive value so this is a
three color scale and that easily helps
me in identifying the data based on the
cell values
now in conditional formatting what you
can also do is you can basically color
the cells based on their value so what
we are seeing here is if the revenue
generated is greater than average then
that shows in green and if the revenue
generated is lesser than average that's
shows in Orange now how do we do that so
we can basically again manage some rules
so I can basically create a new rule now
here I can select one of the options
which says format only values that are
above or below average and that's the
option I would want to select now I can
select this and it says format values
that are above average so in our case we
had it in green so for example I'll say
above average and then here I can go for
a particular color
so you can go for a particular size so
let's go and look into
the formatting so for example let's
choose yellow
say okay now I'm saying wherever the
cell values are above average it would
be yellow instead of green
and let's go in here let's go and look
into manage rules so this is basically
the rule which we are applying now we
can also add a new rule
and I need to select the values so for
example I will say
here so we had gone for above now we'll
go for below we'll go for format we will
choose red we'll say okay we'll say
now these are basically
the rules which we have created and here
it says applies to your data so right
now it has not been applied so for
example if I select this and then I
could basically choose my area just hit
on enter and similarly you can go in
here and then select your area hit on
enter and say apply say okay and now if
you see I have really chosen bright
colors but then I have said wherever my
revenue generated is above average it
should be in yellow and
below average should be in Red so we
wanted above
average to be in green and below average
to be in Orange so
that's what we have here right so you
can always
color code your cell values based on
some rules which you are setting up now
similarly you can also find the top 10
and bottom 10 values and that's pretty
easy so you can just select this and
then you can go into conditional
formatting you can go for top and bottom
values top 10 items bottom 10 items or
you can go in for more rules so you can
say format only top or bottom ranked
values so you have top 10 now you can
choose the color and for example I'll go
for blue
and
I'll say okay so now if you see my top
10 values are blue now similarly I can
add one more rule so I can say new rule
and I can say let's go for top or bottom
let's go for bottom let's go for format
let's say orange
say okay say okay and that's it so now
you have your values which are top or
bottom 10 values so you are using
conditional formatting where you are
basically highlighting your cell values
based on different colors and here easy
conditional formatting based on
different rules helps us to do that now
similarly you can also have the values
which is basically
showing you how the values are
increasing so what we can do is we can
select our columns either you could
apply this to all the columns now here I
have applied this only to Jan and April
now I could apply this for June so let's
say June so you can go for gradient fill
you can go for solid fill you can
obviously just select the color and that
takes care of the things you can say for
example select this and now this is
selected what I would want to might be
format this so I can go in here I can go
into manage rules now that will tell me
what rule has been applied
in the order so I can just do a edit
Rule and that basically says this is a
solid fill which is color you have no
border this is basically color as black
now I can go for something like gradient
fill
and I can say okay and now if I say
apply and okay so this basically is Like
Your First Column so you can use
conditional formatting for various use
cases and you can highlight the values
so anyone who would look at the value
would automatically notice which are the
higher values which are lower values
might be here the revenue is getting
generated or was getting generated but
did not grow Beyond a particular value
and so on now similarly you can also go
in for different options say for example
here we would want to
see if the revenue was dropping
or if the revenue was
if the revenue decreased or say for
example if the revenue was going up for
this particular sales person so here we
are looking at Carol so in Jan the
revenue Generation by sales was very
high then in Feb it was falling down
in March it was kind of stable then in
April it went way below so we can
obviously work on this wherein we can
grade our cell values so what we can do
is we can go in for
highlighting the cell values now you can
go for color scales you can go for Icon
sets and this is where you can choose
your different shapes
so you could choose one of these shapes
so for example
I would be interested in looking at the
indicators like directional I could go
using this three arrows I can go in for
this color I can choose directional and
then my values are
automatically using directional now what
we can also do is we can then go into
manage rules and that basically tells me
what rules have been applied so for
example the latest one is the icon set
which I have chosen it shows the
selected columns I can obviously do a
edit Rule and then I can choose so I'm
saying the format style is icon sets I'm
not using a data bar I'm not using color
scale now here I have chosen the style
of icons
and then here you can basically give
some values so you have icon which is
green when the value is greater than or
equal to 67 percentage
when I say hyphen or minus it is less
than 67. it's way below 33 percentage
then you give this value so you can
obviously edit and easily highlight your
cell values based on this icon set so I
can apply this and that's how I use
conditional formatting so conditional
formatting can be very useful if you
would want to use icon set if you want
to use your data bars if you would want
to highlight particular values if you
would want to color code based on some
calculation if you would want to
use a three color or a two color scale
or if you would want to just find out
values based on some simple calculation
so conditional formatting is used
extensively by data analysts or people
who are working in business intelligence
teams or people who would want to use
Excel to easily identify the data
easily identify the cells which contain
particular value or finding out less
significant or more significant cells to
then pull out values and carry out your
computations calculations or analysis so
let's continue learning on using Excel
for various things now we have learned
on conditional formatting and seen how
that can be very helpful let's learn one
more feature of Excel and that's
basically your data validation now this
can be very useful when you would want
to work on validating the data which is
being fed in the cells so you could
limit it to basically a number between a
particular value you could also add some
messages to it if you would want or you
could even
Circle invalid data or clear validation
circles so data validation really helps
us in validating the data which is being
fed in to particular fields
now it's a feature in Excel which is
mainly used to control what a user can
fill in a Cell you can decide what type
of values must be entered you can also
restrict user to enter only valid data
and if any invalid data is entered an
error message will be displayed now
that's where you can use your data
validations so let's see how that can be
done so for data validation let's see
some exercises here so for example you
have a name column and you would want to
restrict that the name should accept
only 15 characters now how do you do
that so you can basically select the
cells or you can just select a
particular cell and then we can later
drag the property to other fields now
here once the cell is selected so for
example let's try this out and let's see
if that works so for example example I
will say Peter Johnson
okay and that is basically five and nine
and 12 characters so let's say
Junior
and if I do this it says input length is
greater than 15 do you want to continue
if I say yes right so basically
it is allowing me to add the value here
but then it has basically violated the
rule now this is giving a message to the
user that the username should be entered
less than 15 characters now how do we do
that so for this we can basically select
the column and then we can search for
data Tab and get into Data validation so
this is where you can create or select
different kind of rules so for example I
can go into Data validation I can go
into settings and I can say the text
length and that should be less than 15
now this is the maximum I'm giving and
it says apply these changes to all other
cells within the same settings so I can
do this or I can just drag and drop so I
can basically
apply this formula and now you can in
fact randomly check in any particular
cell is the rule applied so it says text
length less than 15. so we can basically
Control Data validation in this
particular column and that will allow
only 15 characters it will pop up a
message if the user really wants to go
beyond the particular limit now you also
have similarly date of birth so the
Restriction is date of birth should be
between 10 Jan 1990 to 30 December 1998
so this is what we want to restrict how
do we do that so we can select the field
we can click on data validation and if
you see here I have selected date and
then date is between and then obviously
you can give a range that is 10 Jan date
1990 12 30 1998 so that's the start and
the end filter which has been applied
and once this is done you can also check
your input messages which says
when cell is selected show this input
message enter a valid date
so if you see here on the left there is
a pop-up which is coming up which says
enter a valid date now I can also say
when user enters invalid data show this
error alert so I can say stop I can say
invalid entered
and this is how I have set a rule so for
example if I just do something like this
and that says invalidate entered I can
do a retry it will take me back here but
unless and until I did not give the
right format the date will not be
accepted and again the same thing
applies to all the cells
similarly email so we are saying the
email should have at the rate present in
the value provided now for this we can
use a formula and we can select well I
would want to apply this rule to all
these rows starting from C2 to c14 so
let's get into Data validation let's
look in settings and here we are
choosing custom now within custom I am
choosing what is the formula so I'm
saying is number
and then I'm saying find
at the rate for
the rows C2 to c14 so the only thing we
are concerned about here is the value
should have an email
icon
you can input a particular message you
can say what has to be done for error
alert so for example we can basically go
in here and we can say
invalid email
that's the title I'm giving and we can
say email should contain
at the rate
so if I do this and if I say ok now you
can test it so you can say A B C D and
that says email should contain at the
rate and basically that will not allow
me to add the values so now you have the
field called salary it says salary
should be greater than 50 000 now we can
limit the values by choosing a whole
number so for example for salary I can
go into Data validation I can go into
settings so here I can say something
like decimal or I can go for whole
number so both of the things are fine it
depends on what kind of values get into
this particular field so if I say whole
number and if I say it has to be greater
than 50 000 so I'm saying the minimum is
50 000 or I could have given a decimal
and then I can say greater than less
than equal or anything or even between
so I can select greater than and then I
can just say okay
now for rank the rule is rank should be
between 100 and 200 so again we can use
a whole number so ranks will generally
not be decimal so this would be whole
number salary is can be a whole number
or it could be decimals so we have
chosen decimal here and in rank if you
click on data validation I have chosen
whole number
I have set data between 100 and 200
input message nothing error alert
nothing but that depends I can give this
so this is how you can just do a simple
data validation and control the values
which land in the cell okay so now let's
also understand how we can
restrict the values in a particular cell
which might be based on a list of items
now for example here if you see I have
two columns so one column basically has
the values of city names and then you
have places within that particular City
so if I would want to implement a data
validation based on this so for example
if you see here City and that basically
shows me only the four values which can
be entered and if I go to place then it
tells me for Maharashtra I can only
enter Pune Mumbai nashik now how do I do
this so say for example you take an
empty field and you want to restrict the
values of city names so I could select
data validation I could basically select
list and then it tells me you need to
enter the list values that is the source
so you click here and then I can just
select these fields now if I do this and
if I say OK it has implemented a data
validation but if you look into this it
will show me the same thing but then it
shows me some empty cells which did not
have any value so this is fine but it
would be better if we do it in a
different way so I can select this and I
have already given my city names here so
I can just do a data validation and here
in the source let me get rid of this now
I can just have my cursor here I can
select these values and then if I say ok
so now if you see my city names have
been restricted to these values and
that's how you can Implement your data
validation so I have this data
validation here but I will get rid of
this one by just doing a control Z now
I'll come here and say for example I
would want to implement the same data
validation now the easiest way would be
in doing this for all my four cities now
if you see here I have data validation I
could choose Bangalore and if you come
and check here there is no data
validation but we have implemented data
validation here now how is that done so
I could select this or for example I can
go in here I can select data validation
I can select list and then here in the
source I will say for Bangalore the
value should be these and then if I
basically say okay
now if we see these are the values which
are fed into Bangalore so we could do
this or like what we have done here so
if you can check the data validation
rule I have used list and then I have
said indirect F2 so basically I'm giving
in a formula which relates to the value
which is in for the city Maharashtra so
we could do this or in a simpler way we
could do this and then just drag and
drop here so we could check for
Maharashtra what are the values let's
choose a different city so for example
Kolkata and here I will choose now since
we did a drag and drop it has basically
taken the values of Bangalore so that's
not right so we select this we go into
Data validation and here I can either
feed in the values that is such as
Bangalore I could basically say
something like this Kolkata and I could
say okay so now if you see it shows me
the places in Kolkata now here we have
let's choose a different city so for
example let's go for Delhi and here I
can go to data validation and I can just
say Delhi so this is an easier way of
doing it or if you remember the formula
then what you can do is you can just
give in
indirect and then basically
give the value of the cell for which you
would want to keep in the values so this
is how you can do list validation so you
can provide a list of values and then
you can restrict the values in a Cell
which should be belonging to a
particular list so this is how you do a
simple data validation by restricting
the data in the form of a list Mis
reports in Excel
so first let's understand what exactly
is Mis report in Excel
so Mis stands for management information
system Mis reports provide data on
different categories for accurate
decision making so Mis in Excel is a
procedure to create interactive report
using Microsoft Excel so Mis reports
help management to access the
performance of organization and allow
faster decision making so if you know to
create the Mis reports using various
business intelligence tools such as
Excel then you might find a very good
job opportunity in a well established
company now let us try to learn how to
create Mis report using Excel in a
practical mode so let's get back to the
Microsoft Excel IF getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so here you can see that I've got some
sales data of various car manufacturing
companies and I've also got some slices
so using these slicers I can get the
real-time information from the dashboard
so I'll select an ear from the first
slicer and I'll go into the second
slicer and I'll select a company now
I'll select BMW and SUV type so we have
the data of all the SUV types cars
manufactured by BMW car manufacturing
company in the year 2018. now let's
start and create something similar to
this one
so how did I create this mis report
let's go through this in a step-by-step
way
so on my screen you can see that we have
created a completely new Excel workbook
and we have some sample data with five
rows and 20 columns
so this particular data is based on the
manufacturer and the car manufacturing
company and the type of the car
manufactured and number of cars
manufactured in that particular year and
also the price of that particular car
Now to create a minus reports we need to
play around favor tables so we also have
tutorials on pivot tables and you can go
through that in our simply learn YouTube
channel and also we will try to link
those in the description box below
now let's select the entire data and go
into the insert ribbon and there you can
see the first option that is pivot table
so after selecting the pivot table
option it will show this particular
dialog box where it will ask you for the
range of cells you need to select and
the next one is to
create the pivot table in the same sheet
or a new sheet so we'll take a new sheet
here now select OK and there you go you
have the pivot table here so first you
have an empty pivot table and on the
right side you can see we have pivot
table Fields now you can either drag
these options into the rows and columns
or you can also click it so now let's
drag and drop these first we will select
here
and card
followed by that we will take type
quantity and price to columns
so there you go we have our pivot table
now
let's select all the data in the pivot
table
and again let's get back to the insert
option
and here you can see an option called
pivot chart select that and you will
have various favorite chart options here
now you can select any one which you can
prefer or which you like or whichever
you think can represent your data in a
best way possible so now let's go with
column chart first
let's select OK and we have our column
chart over here
now this happens to be our first chart
now let's create a few more chats so to
create few more charts we'll go back to
the same original data select again
insert and there's a table
now again a new worksheet
so here we have another empty pivot
table in the similar way let's drag the
same data into rows and columns
there you go and again we will select
all the data and create a pivot chart
go to insert option
favorite chat and now let's try to
select pie chart
select ok
and we have our pie chart over here
now let's try to create one more
same procedure select table select pivot
table then create new worksheet for the
new pivot table and now drag and drop
the data
now let's go to insert again
let's select all the data go to insert
option and pivot chat now let's try to
select the bar chart
select OK and there we have our bar
chart now
remember the first chart we created that
is in sheet 2 this one so we will try to
move all the charts to this particular
table or this particular worksheet
so let's get back to the sheet number
three right click and you can see an
option called pivot chart analyze so
from here you can move the chart select
the option of moving the chart and don't
select the first one select the object
in option and select the sheet number to
which you want to move this chat for now
we want to move this chart to sheet
number two select that press ok now we
have the chart moved to the sheet number
two
and in the same way let's go to the
sheet number four and let's move this
particular chart to sheet number two
there you go the chart got moved to
sheet number two
now you can insert the slices
so we have selected the third sheet or
third chart and inside the pivot chart
analyze option we have an option of
inserting the slicer now we will insert
the slices for year
car and
type
now select OK and you will have all the
three slices onto your sheet
now let's rearrange them
so I'm just organizing them in a
neat way
there you go
and you can also customize your designs
for all the charts
so that they look a little more better
now if you see
if I make some changes only one chart
will be interacting for this
right so if I select Ferrari and year
2020 and option as thoughts you can see
only one chart is interacting to these
particular slices why because all these
slices are connected to just one chart
here so you need to make sure that all
the slices are connected to all the
three charts what we created so let's
erase all the filters and select one
slicer at a time right click and you
will see an option of report connections
select that and you see that the
connections are only connected to the
pivot table 3. so select the remaining
pivot tables as well select OK and in
the same way select the second slicer
select the record connection option
connect pivot table 1 and 2 and select
OK and in the same way the third one
so now all the slices are connected to
all the pivot charts now if you make
some changes here they will respond
automatically in the same way
now let's select this code company the
year 2019 and hatchback option and you
have all the cars which were made in the
year 2019 from Ford Company in the
segment of hatchback
so this was the sample data set that we
worked on now you can also work on some
complex data sets such as this Superstar
data set
now one thing you need to make sure that
when you're working with Excel Mis they
need to make sure that all the macros
are disabled on your data set and you
convert the entire data into the regular
table format of excel right now Excel is
considering this particular data as a
database so for that you need to select
all the data press Ctrl T and then
convert the entire data in the form of
tabular data and also don't forget to
click this icon which reads my table has
headers so the first row is the headers
now let's select OK and your entire data
will be converted into tabular form now
let's reset this to the normal
type which has the clear color not all
the fancy colors now the entire data is
converted from the dbms to the tablet
form and now he can start implementing
the Mis reporting pivot tables so that's
how you work on Mis report in Excel
let's look at an example of one more
useful function in Excel and that is
vlookup now vlookup is used to see if a
value exists in a range of values and we
can create a range of values which is
nothing but a block of cells which has a
name and can be referenced so mainly to
use vlookup we need to create a named
range and that can be referenced
anywhere in the workbook or the other
option is you can always drag and select
the range of data in which you would
want to search something now there is
also other functions such as Edge lookup
which pretty much does the same thing
however it does it horizontally that is
left to right instead of vertically
there are other functions like lookup
and X lookup and so on so when we talk
about vlookup let's see how we do that
so for example this is the range of or
this is the data which has been given to
you and here is the question find the
employee name with employee ID 107. now
assume that you might have huge amount
of data and you may want to search
something so how do we do it now here I
have created some column and then some
basic formatting I have given it as an
employee ID I've given employee name now
what I can do is I can create a range of
data now how do I do that or a named
range so what you can do is you can
select the data and then you can do it
right click now here you have something
like get data from table range so you
can do that you can define a name so you
can click on this and here you can give
a name to the range what you would want
to call it so for example let's say our
search now that's the named range I'm
creating and just say Okay so the scope
is workbook and I have created a named
range which you can see here so it shows
for search our search so you have
created a named range now how do we do a
vlookup here so for that we can use a
formula so for example I would want to
search for employee name where employee
ID is whatever you would want to search
for so employee ID we can give here one
zero seven now that's what we would want
to search the employee name for an
employee name is what we are interested
now what we can do is we can use the
function option here I can do a insert
function and that shows me different
function which I have here now vlookup
is showing up because I have recently
searched for it or you can basically
just type in here look and you can do a
go so that shows you all the lookup
options what you have like look up Edge
lookup match vlookup and so on so we
would be interested in vlookup so let's
select that and click on ok now that
basically opens up this function
arguments and it shows what does this
function do so it says looks for a value
in the leftmost column of a table and
then returns a value in the same Row
from a column you specify by default the
table must be sorted in an ascending
order now you can basically say this is
what you would want to search for what
is the lookup value if you place your
cursor here it says what is the table
array that is nothing but the range
which we can use our named range here we
have the the column index number which
basically tells me what is the column
number in the range which we want so
what is the value we want from which
column and then basically you have range
lookup which basically is the fourth
option and range lookup is nothing but
it can have two values so true or false
so true basically means closest match
and then false should be an exact match
so let's do that so for lookup value we
would want to give a particular value
which is nothing but
we would be interested in say employee
name so I can basically
search for a value based on the lookup
value now how do we do it so we are
saying we would want to search for
employee ID which is one zero seven so
what I can do is I can select this
cell here which tells that this is the
value
or employee ID for which I would want to
search the employee name I could
actually select the cell here which is H
so that whatever value you feed in here
you can search for that value so maybe
we can select this one which is H6 and
whatever value we key in here we will be
searching for employee name for that
employee ID now table array is we would
want to give a range so what we can do
is we can give our range so for example
we had selected something like our
search
and if you see here that already cell X
or shows me employee ID employee name
email address so it gives me the range
now column index number so which
column are we interested in that means
what is the value we are searching for
so we are searching for employee name
which is the second column so I can just
say 2 and that basically is the column
number and then you have to give a range
lookup which is a logical value so
either you give an exact match or you
can basically give a closest match so we
can say for example do a 0 which
basically means false or you can say 1
which is true so let's go for zero now
that's our formula so it says vlookup
you will search for the value as per at
6 in the range and then you are looking
for employee name which is column number
two and then true or false so let's
click on okay and that basically gives
me the value which is parallel
bunch
so here I'm searching for employee name
and you can basically drag this for
other columns and you can do that so if
it finds employee
ID here now say for example if we had an
employee ID somebody enters an employee
ID which is not in the range for example
let's try 121 and then you see this is
basically an error right because it does
not have any employee ID with 121 now
how do I take care of this so there is a
Formula which is called if error and
that can be used to take care of this so
if the value is not found then it will
show whatever I would want to
show here so what I can do is I can
still select this and what I can do is I
can search in function
say for example this is the function we
are looking at but what we can do is
we can test it here so for example if I
look in function and if I search for
error and say oh go so there are lots of
functions here and this is the function
we are interested in if error so if I
say okay now this takes the value and
what is the value if error so for Value
what I can do is basically I can select
the value from here which is nothing but
our vlookup formula and value if error
so for example I will basically say for
example not found so we can try this and
we can say okay now here it says not
found so whenever it is n a it is not
found now
if we look at the formula here it says
if error it takes the value of H7 which
is nothing but our vlookup and then it
is
showing us the value which we have
entered so for example if I would say 1
0 7 like earlier and then hit on enter
so it says panel of cruise and it shows
us the value
right and if we enter something else
then basically
here it shows n a and it shows not found
but what we want to do is we want to
merge these two so what I can do is I
can get rid of
or I can basically take this one
now what I would want is I want this
formula to be here so what I can do is I
can say if error and then basically
given your vlookup option or function
here and then say for example not found
here not found now that basically will
take care of any kind of error if the
value is not found so when we say 121 it
basically says not found but if I say
107 which is found then it shows me the
value so we are using vlookup but when
then we are also using IF error which
will take care of our error message or
basically the not applicable pound not
applicable replaced with whatever value
we key in similarly we can do the same
thing here so we have the find the job
title so we are interested in finding
out the job title once the employee name
is given now employee name can basically
have a value from the cell or whatever
value you would want to key in
how do we do it so we basically start
with our vlookup so that's the function
we are interested in
so you can just do a double click now
you are interested in finding out the
value whichever is given here so that's
the lookup value and then you are
interested in finding out the job title
from the range so I will still give our
range which basically
also shows for example let's do a
double click here and that basically
selects the range and now I am
interested in finding out the job title
so that's column number four
and then I can just give 0 which is for
false so now we have given our vlookup
but that shows not applicable because we
have not given any employee name so we
can key in the value here which says
Fred Stone and now if we are basically
giving the value so Fred Stone now we
will have to search if there is any job
title which is Fred Stone so here is the
value so that should be showing up let's
check what has gone wrong so we are
giving our range we are interested in
finding out the value but what the
mistake what we did here was that when
we want to search for a value say for
example let's take this vlookup and
let's replace this value of H to L with
the value here so Fred Stone and then
basically we will give our range we will
say which is the column we are
interested in and then give true or
false so we can also basically take care
of this error message so for example
let's take this complete formula from
here and just
just copy this formula
and now we can put in here the formula
but then this is where we were searching
for H6 which was employee ID now that's
not what we are interested in we are
interested in finding out the value so
let's take this one and replace this
with the value given here
and then I give my range I say which is
the column I'm interested in so I'm
interested in looking for job title and
then let's search so it basically tells
me not found so let's check this
now the error which we were facing was
because when we talk about your vlookup
let's look at the formula again and here
say for example I go for function and
then I select vlookup and say for
example I say okay now just look at the
description here looks for a value in
the left most column of a table now
earlier the range which we had selected
had the leftmost column as employee ID
and that's why it was giving an error so
how do we fix that so for example let's
basically
remove this function from here now what
we want to do is we would want to search
for the stock broker now if you see here
I have given a range which is b 1 to D21
so we would want the value for what we
would want to search say employee name
that should be the leftmost column so
so that's how
we have our function so let's do that so
say for example the name is given here
so we want a range so either we can
create a range like earlier by selecting
say for example this data now am I
interested in salary no I am interested
in job title right so I can basically
just select these three columns and then
I can define a name so I can say our
search to and let's give a named range
and that's only because we would want to
easily reference or use that named
search or name range now here we would
want to use vlookup but we would also do
an if error
now within that we can say we lookup and
then you need to
select what is the value what your
function takes so basically this is my
function we will say if the value is not
found then we will give this so you can
create an external structure and then
within your vlookup we will say the
leftmost column which we are interested
in so that's your employee name
so in employee name we have the value so
either I can directly select the value
here in the column b or I will give the
value whichever is fed in here the
employee name then I need to give a
range so let's select our range so
that's your our search too and then you
need to select the column number
so we are interested in finding out the
job title so that's the third column so
let's say three and then just give it 0
and then hit on enter so it says not
found because you have not given any
employee name now let's
try to find the job title of Fred Stone
so I can just select or I can say equal
and then I can just given a value and
that basically shows me the job title so
this is how you use vlookup we have also
used if error which basically takes care
of error message if the value is not
found so for example we can test this
here we have Fred Stone
so for example if I just empty this and
I point it to something which does not
exist so that shows me not found or if
you just select this and then key in a
value it shows you this might be we can
just type in so if I say Fred then
basically it says not found because we
are looking for exact match now if we
had changed this to the closest match
something like this then it would have
tried to find something but then we
don't have anything which is just with
this so there are different ways of
doing it so what we can do is we can
always go for the exact match
and that's basically the value
and here we can basically key in any
value for example I would be interested
in finding out
this one and let's give this so you can
search in this way so you can also have
statements which can be searching one
related to other now here the question
was to find the job title of Fred Stone
so let's type in Fred Stone and that
basically shows me the job title which
we are interested in so let's search for
job title let's go for exact match and
then search so it is stock broker so if
getting your learning started it's half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now that we have looked at vlookup it
would be interesting
horizontal lookup
purple works in the on the same lines
but here instead of vertically searching
through the columns the range is more of
horizontally defined so we search in
rows rather than in columns so for
example this is the data which has been
given to you and you have various
columns so you have employee ID you have
your employee name you have employee
email address
you basically have the job title of
different employees and then basically
you have the salary so this is the data
which has been given to you and you are
asked to search or you are interested in
finding out say the salary based on
employee name or job title based on
employee ID so what we need to do is we
need to define the range here now range
can depend on what you are searching for
so for example when I'm searching
employee name and salary so I am
interested in these four rows when I am
saying employee ID and job title then
might be this is the range and I don't
need salary so I can create a named
range if we are interested in so that we
can easily search for it or we can
straight away give the the first cell
value which is basically A1 here and
then the last value here which is G and
then you can give 5. so you can do that
or you can create a named range
whichever way you would want to do it so
for example we would want to create a
named range for our first question which
is find the salary of Eden Cornell using
H lookup so we are interested in this so
let's select
these four rows all the way for your
columns now like we did earlier we can
just Define a name might be we can call
it our search 3 and we can just give
okay so that's the named range which we
have created
now what we would want is we want to
search for the salary based on employee
name so here we can insert our function
so let's look up and let's search for
look and just click on go so here you
have hlookup and basically that's the
function I'm interested in say Okay so
this says what is the lookup value which
you are interested in so we are
interested in finding out the value
based on the employee name so for
example let's select this cell that
gives us more dynamism and you can add
in any name and you can search for the
salary
or you can basically give the employee
name exactly from the employee name
value here which is D 2. so we can give
Aden kernel from here so let's select
this now table array so we need to give
our range so let's say our search three
then you need to give the row index
number now this is different than
vlookup in vlookup you have column index
number and here you have row index
number so what are you interested in
searching for so we are interested in
searching for salary now in our range
that is basically the fourth row
remember we created a range from
employee name to salary so let's give
the row index number which is 4 and the
range lookup will say 0 which is
basically exact match and that completes
our formula so click on OK and that
basically gives me the salary for Eden
Cornell
now that's basically because we have fed
in the value here
and that is basically giving me this so
I can again do if error if I would be
interested in to basically take care of
error message if the value is not found
for that you can look into the previous
example which is vlookup now similarly
we are interested in finding out the job
title for employee ID
105 how do we do that so we need to use
Edge lookup well we could have done with
vlookup but here the data is more
arranged in the form of rows so how do
we do that so we can again use Edge
lookup but and we can give a range or
named range or let's for this time let's
basically key in our range manually so
we can do that so let's go for H lookup
now what do we want to search for so we
will say this is the value then we need
to give a range now as I said if you
would want to give a change manually so
for example I'll say a and then I'll say
a 1.
colon and then I'm interested in G and
then the row will be 4 so salary row is
not what we are we are not interested in
so let's say G and then we can give 4 so
that basically gives me the range right
instead of having a named range so we
can do that and then we need to give the
row index number so we are interested in
finding out the job title which is
basically in our range the fourth row
and then give 0 for true or false so if
you see here it tells if it is 1 it is
approximate match false is an exact
match and we can close this bracket that
completes our formula it takes the value
which is given in employee ID and then
it will try to search for the job title
so that basically shows wherever the
employee ID is one zero five the job
title is fabricated again you can use if
error
wherein your if error can then be
working on hlookup and can take care of
error so that if an employee ID is keyed
in for which there is no matching value
then it will not show you a not
applicable error in instead of that it
will replace with the word whatever you
have specified so in this way you can
easily use Edge lookup to search from
the range of data which is horizontally
arranged and in the previous example we
were seeing how you use vlookup when the
data is arranged vertically
so we have looked at vlookup and Edge
lookup and what we have seen is vlookup
has a limitation in one way that we need
to basically give a range where the
leftmost column is the one which is used
now instead of that we might be
interested in searching in specific
columns and not all the columns well
that can also affect the time taken to
search for the data
wherein we can select particular columns
or particular ranges rather than
selecting all the data which has to be
searched for so for example we have this
question find the salary of Hank
Saunders now that's the employee name
which we have here and we would want to
find out the salary so what are the
columns we are interested in so one is
your employee name and one is your
salary and these are the only two
columns which we are interested in so
instead of using vlookup now like I've
shown earlier you can create a named
range for these two columns and you can
use that or we can manually give the
range here so let's go for lookup
function here and lookup function will
basically help us in searching what we
are interested in so we are interested
in finding out the employee name
and we are interested in finding out the
salary based on the employee name so how
do we do that so here in lookup I can
first give the value which is here
employee name now whatever
employee name is keyed in here we will
be searching for salary of that employee
now lookup function needs a lookup value
so we are searching
based on employee name then it says
lookup Vector so we will basically then
say what is going to be our lookup
Vector so here we need to give a range
so what are we interested in we are
interested in finding out the salary
based on employee name so first goes our
range
based on which we need to search so
that's your employee name so let's for
example select this one so that's our
range B1 to B21 so that will basically
have the employee name in which we will
be searching for and then we are
interested in searching out the the
result Vector that is basically the
column from which we want the value
that's our salary column so let's select
this and that completes our lookup
function so now if you hit on enter it
shows that for this employee where the
name is hunk Saunders the salary is 5400
now you can test it by basically giving
some other name so for example if I
replace this with say Fred Stone
and that basically shows me the value
for Fred Stone we can replace it to the
question which we have that is Hank
Saunders and that shows me the salary so
that's a simple example of Lookup which
allows you to search by selecting a
range of columns rather than having the
leftmost column which has to be
referenced similarly we have one more
question find the employee ID of this
particular email ID so we need to again
use our lookup function so we'll say
look up now what are we interested in we
will search based on this email address
so I will select this then I need to
give that based on email address we are
searching the employee ID so email
addresses in this column so let's select
this range and then we are interested in
employee ID so then goes our result
Vector so select this column and that
basically completes your formula so
close this bracket and hit on enter so
that means basically shows me the
employee ID for an employee with this
email address so this is how you use
lookup now as I've explained earlier you
can be using the if error and you can
basically see how
your index match can be used now here is
an example of if error so basically this
shows how if error helps so say for
example as I showed in your sheet1 so
check for employee James Bond if the
value is not present display not found
and what are we doing we are basically
nesting our vlookup
inside if error with a not found option
which basically says if the value given
in the cell H is not found then
basically
it will
display not found so here you also
notice that the range which has been
given has been selected that is B1 to
c21 now we could have used a named range
which basically helps us in searching
for multiple functions we are searching
for 2 that is the column number 2 here
that is employee name so check for
employee James Bond if the value is not
present or no so we are basically just
searching for employee name here and
then give your 0 or 1. so that's
basically usage of your if error which I
have shown earlier and the same thing
can be applied for your Edge lookup also
now suppose you have been given some
additional questions for example you
know instead of using your vlookup or
hlookup or lookup examples what we have
seen say for example you are asked to
find the salary of Peter Daniels now we
already know how to find that using
vlookup right so for example we want to
find out the salary for this employee
name which is Peter Daniels I can use a
vlookup however sometimes we may also
want to use a index match an index match
is also one useful function to do that
so we can basically search based on that
so we have to define the range of data
we have to then say what do we want to
match so that's basically an employee
name and then we are interested in
finding out
say for example based on the range of
employees you would want to find out
the value of salary so we are then
giving a range and doing it how do we do
that so for example here I can use a
function which is called index and if
you see here it says returns a value or
reference of the cell
at the intersection of a particular row
and column in a given range so this is
where index function can be useful now
we can start with this function it says
it needs an array that's nothing but a
range so we can basically select all our
data so I can say A1 all the way to E21
so that basically is my range now I
would want to find the salary of this
employee name which is Peter Daniels so
I can use internally here
basically you need to give a row number
so what we can do is we can do a match
so we can use an internal function match
now we need to basically give it
correctly so we need to say match now
how does this match function work so we
need to basically match for a value so
for example we will select whatever
employee name is given here so that's
Peter Daniels now that's basically what
we would want to match now where do we
want to match this so we want to match
in the column B which has employee
names so we can give a range which is B1
to B 21 so that's basically within the
employee names we are looking for a
match which is given here that's in H6
and we want to do a match so we want to
do a exact match so let's do a comma 0
and then we are interested in finding
out the salary
based on this match and salary is in our
fifth column so let's basically give the
column number here and then just close
this bracket
so that basically completes your
function and just hit on enter so that
shows me the salary of Peter Daniels
right so this is an easy way when you
can use the index function remember
first you give the range
and then you need to give your matching
conditions So when you say match I would
take the value whatever is given in this
cell I will search in the range of
values which is employee names I will
find an exact match and what I'm
interested in is finding the salary for
Peter Daniels now similarly say for
example you have been given a question
find the employee ID with salary 10 000
so you want to find out the employee ID
wherever the salary is ten thousand so
we are obviously looking for an exact
match now how do we do that so we can
start with our index function and within
index function we need to give a range
so for example I am interested in
finding out say for example our range
which is a 1
two e 21 so that's what I'm interested
in or you are actually interested in
searching based on
save your salary so you are interested
in searching the employee ID so maybe if
I just do a 821 let's see what happens
here now then I can just do a match
so match will be now done based on the
value which is here H 13 so I will do a
match for this one now I need to give a
range
so let's basically give a range which
will be we are interested in
searching employee ID based on the
salary column so that's your e column so
I will say E1 to E21 that's what I'm
interested in searching
finding a match for this salary we want
an exact match so first let's close this
one now
that's fine I mean we are interested in
finding out the employee ID based on the
match which is within this range
and then what we would want to do is we
would want to basically find the
employee ID employee ID is in my column
A so what I can do is I can additionally
give a match here and then I can say I'm
interested in the finding out the value
for employee ID
and that basically needs a range so the
range here will be just the
the column headings so we will give A1
all the way to E1 so that's the range in
which we would want to search and we
would want to find a match for employee
ID we want an exact match so let's close
this one and that basically closes my
match and we need to close our index
function so now that shows me employee
ID where the salary is 10 000. so this
is how you can do your index matches
where you can give a range then you can
say what you need to match
within which particular column whether
it is an exact match or approximate
match and then the column from where you
are interested in finding out the value
so same thing we did here we basically
gave a complete range and if you closely
see we were only interested in finding
out the employee ID so here I give a
range A1 to a21 which is basically this
particular column so that's where we are
interested in finding out match
basically will give your lookup value so
that's h13 then we gave a range which is
salary that's what we are interested in
and then we said when we are doing a
match we are only interested in finding
out the employee ID
which is in a range of column names and
then doing an exact match so this is how
you can use index match instead of
lookup which can also give you uh some
exceptions and searching for specific
columns or specific rows now if error we
have already discussed where you Nest
your vlookup or hlookup inside it
so this is how you can use your lookup
functions Edge lookup vlookup lookup or
index match to search for data some
function like this which shows up
xln.xlookup and then you're trying to
search for something so don't be
surprised with that so xln is basically
a prefix added to functions that don't
exist in the version of excel you are
using you have Excel 2013 and say your
friend has a newer version of excel say
Office 365 or Excel 2016 and basically
he uses a new cool function and sends
the file to you so that's where you will
have this excellent prefix as I am
showing up here so for example what is
the job title of Xavier power is what
you would want to search and here the
function which shows up Excel and X
lookup and then you are searching so
this is is basically something which is
the function now if I just select what
it has selected here and if I hit on
enter it shows that this does not work
in my Excel here and that's because of
the version but what I can do is I can
fix this by removing this
details here and that basically shows
lookup we are searching for job title
based on employee name which is in this
field H6 and then we need to give a
range so we need to give a range of
names employee name and then basically
the job title range which is basically
the job title so now if I just hit on
enter it gives me the value so it's as
simple as that similarly here what is
the employee ID of the person with this
email we have already looked at the
lookup function so if it shows your xln
X lookup all you need to do is remove
this and then keep the lookup function
searching for the value based on the
range of values and then searching for a
value within a range of values so just
hit on enter and that gives you the
value and same thing goes for this job
title so what is the job title and
salary of employee name so we have this
function now what I can do is
here I am interested in finding out the
value for this particular function how
do I fix this I can basically select
this and then just do a lookup based on
the values and it basically says you
can't change part of an array so we can
fix this now what we need to do is we
need to basically search based on this
particular value so we will basically
say I want to do a lookup now lookup
should be based on employee name
whatever name is given here then you
need to find the job title and salary so
for job title I want to find based on
employee name so I will give a range
and then basically I will say I'm
interested in finding out the job title
so I will give a different range
and then basically close this so that
basically shows now this is basically
because of the function which we have
here so basically to fix this what we
will have to do is we will have to
delete all the columns here which were
selected such as employee name job title
and salary because that was giving you
an error you cannot delete a part of an
array now what we want to do is we want
to find the job title and salary based
on the employee name so we can do that
using lookup as we have done earlier so
we will use a lookup function now what
we are interested in finding out is the
job title based on employee name so we
can select this cell which does not have
any value then we need to basically say
from which range or based on what you
want to search so we want to search
based on employee name
and we want to find out the job title so
we can basically give a range of values
and then we will be interested in
finding out the job title so let's
select the job title range and that
basically completes our lookup so let's
close this and hit on enter now it says
obviously error because this does not
have any value we will fix that by
giving in a value here same thing we can
do for salary so for example I can just
drag and drop it here and in this one
instead of
basically having a range which is your
we will be interested in finding out the
salary so
let's see what is the range we give so
the range should be employee name
so we will basically select employee
name as the range
and then we are interested in finding
out the salary so we will select this
particular range and what we are
interested in finding out is basically
employee name
or we are interested in finding out
based on employee name so let's select
this particular column and then hit on
enter so both of these are any values
now just feed in an employee name so we
will say for example Eduardo and that
basically gives me the job title and
salary so that's how you can fix your
Excel FN error so same thing goes here
so it shows you xln is what you would
want to search might be if you don't
find something you would want to
pushing name not found so first is we
will have to fix this part so we will
have to remove this because that's not
supported in my Excel and then I have
lookup I'm searching based on h24 which
is basically employee ID you are giving
a range which is A2 to 821 because we
would want to find name not found
for a particular employee ID so I am
giving a range which is A2 to a21 I am
trying to search for the name which is
from B2 to B21 and then I am giving name
not found so say for example we can do
this lookup but then with lookup you
don't have this direct option what we
can do is we can use if error
if error and then basically try to
search so that gives your lookup value
and then you will have to close this one
and then again if it gives you some
error like this we can obviously go for
vlookup and fix this so here we are
searching for a particular range and
then let's search for this value
and basically to fix this what I did was
I just use a vlookup so we know that
employee ID 121 does not exist so I'm
just using IF error I'm doing a vlookup
where I'm searching for the value given
in h 19 and then I am saying that I
would want to search from a range which
is basically B1 to c21 that is in
employee name and say email address for
example and we would want to basically
search for name not found so we can
instead of giving B21 or B1 to c21 we
can restrict it to just B1 to B21 we are
searching in column 2 we are searching
for exact value and if it does not fine
then it says name not found and that's
how we do it so we can always replace
and fix this Excel FN errors if
you are using uh some spreadsheet which
was or Excel which was sent by
um someone else who is using a different
version so in this way we can use your
different lookup functions
take care of your errors use index match
vlookup is one of the most widely used
functions in Microsoft Excel to perform
analysis of data calculation and data
manipulation
so in this video you will learn vlookup
in detail let's straight jump into
learning what is Excel vlookup
vlookup stands for vertical lookup
vlookup lets you search for specific
information in your spreadsheet it
allows you to search for a particular
value in a column and returns another
value from a different column but of the
same row
vlookup takes advantage of vertically
aligned tables to quickly find data
associated with the value the user
enters now let's look at the syntax to
write a vlookup function so vlookup
takes four parameters or arguments you
can see it here there are four arguments
in the Wilco function
so the first argument is called the
lookup value the lookup value represents
the value that you are searching for
next is the table array the table array
represents two or more Columns of
information the third argument is called
the column index number now this
represents the column number in the
table from which the value must be
returned the First Column is 1 the
second column is 2 and so on and then we
have the fourth parameter which is
called the range lookup now this
parameter is optional now range lookup
is used to find an exact match
so if you want to find an exact match
you need to enter false or 0 meanwhile
if you want an approximate match you
need to enter true or one if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now let me give you a brief overview on
what's going to be in our demo
so for our demonstration
we'll use a sales data set you can see
the data set on the left
using this data set we'll understand how
vlookup performs an exact and
approximate match we'll see how vlookup
is case insensitive
then we'll perform a wildcard character
search
will understand how to handle errors
when a match is not found and finally
you will look at two-way lookups
now here is a small example of how
vlooker works
so we want to find the units sold by
Morgan using the data set on the left
so here you can see I have the data set
it has
some rows and columns so these are the
columns which are order date region
there's a representative column item
units this unit cost and total and from
this table I want to find the units that
were sold by Morgan if you look at the
table at the bottom you can see the
representative name Morgan and Morgan
has sold 30 units now I want to find
this value using the vlookup function so
here on the right you can see I have my
lookup value which is Morgan and this is
my vlookup formula and using this
formula I am getting the result as 30.
now let's go to our Excel workbook and
perform all the demos one by one so this
is my Excel workbook that we are going
to use for our demo
and here is the data set we'll be using
now this is the same data set that you
saw a while ago
so this data set has seven columns you
have the order date the region
representative's name item this units
unit cost and total which is basically
the total or the amount of sales that
was generated
now we are going to use a chunk of this
data set and perform our vlookup
analysis
so let's see our first example and the
problem we have at hand
let me go to the exact match tab
all right
so here
I'm going to use this chunk of data
which is actually taken from the
original data set so we have taken the
first
11 rows from the data set you can see
from Row 2
till root 12 is going to be a data set
that we'll use
so we have a question here
we want to find the items sold by
Thompson
so here
Thompson is my lookup value which means
looking at Thompson I want to find the
item that is sold
so if you consider our table here you
can see we have the representatives name
Thompson right here and from the table
you can see Thompson sold pencil
and I want to get this value which is
pencil using my vlookup function so
let's go ahead and write our vlooker
function
I'll consider this as my lookup value
and here under item I'm going to write
my vlooker formula
to write the vlooker formula I'll write
first equal to
and
I'll write vlookup now if I hit tab it
will auto complete all right now let's
give the parameters so first is going to
be the lookup value which is nothing but
Thomson so I'll just select this cell
which is j17
comma now it's asking to give the table
array so the table array is the table
from which you want to retrieve a value
one thing to keep in mind is that the
value you are looking for should be the
first column of a table and you can
select the table array till the end of
the data set or till the column which
has the value you want to find
so here I'll select my table array
starting from the representatives column
till the end of the item column which is
going to be my table array then I'll
select the column index number so the
column index number is based on the
table array you have selected in this
case my column index number is going to
be 2 because we have selected just two
columns and the value which I am going
to find is in the second column so I'll
give 2
comma now the range lookup I am going to
give is false because I want to find an
exact match so either you can hit tab
or you can write 0 which means false
if I close the bracket and hit enter
it will return me the item that Thompson
had sold which is pencil you can verify
from the table that Thompson had sold
pencil all right
now let's try to change the table array
and see what result are we getting so
this time I'll slightly change the table
array so again we are trying to find the
item that Thompson had sold so I'll
write my formula equal to vlookup I'll
hit tab to autocomplete I'll give my
lookup value as Thompson
comma this time I am choosing my table
array starting from the representatives
column till
the end of the data set which is
till p12
again my column index number is going to
be 2 because if you consider this table
array the item column is the second
column in the selected table array so I
am going to write it as 2 comma
the range lookup I want to give as false
because I want to find the exact match
if I close this and hit enter you can
see it has written me the same result
that we saw earlier
now suppose let's say this time I want
to start my table array from the region
column which is this column
so I want to select my table array
starting from the region column now this
is going to show me an error because
your table array should always start
from the lookup value column so if you
consider Thompson as the lookup value
my table array should always start from
the representatives column so let's just
try this example
so I'll write vlookup my lookup value
I'm going to give it as Thompson comma
the table array as I mentioned earlier I
am going to choose from the region
column and let's say I'll select till
the item column give another comma and
this time a column index number is going
to be 3 because since the table array
has three columns and my item column is
the last column so I'm going to give my
column index number as 3 comma I want to
get the exact match so I'll give 0 if I
close the bracket and hit enter you can
see it has given me
an error
okay now let me just show you another
method to use vlookup in Excel so here
on the top you can see there's a
formulas Tab and under formulas tab
under function Library you see we have
an option to select lookup and reference
if I click on this
and if I scroll down below you can see
there's an option
called vlookup let's choose this
all right now here you can give
your lookup value your table array
column index number and the range lookup
under this function arguments dialog box
so here I want to select my lookup value
as
Thompson my table array is going to be
from the representatives column till
let's say the end of the data set
my column index number is going to be 2
I'll write 2
and range lookup I'll write as false
because I want the exact match
if I hit OK you can see it has given us
the exact same result so this is one of
the other ways to use vlookup in Excel
now let's move to the next sheet which
is regarding approximate match okay so
sometimes you might have cases where you
don't have the lookup value present in
the table in those cases you can tell
vlookup to return an approximate match
now one thing to keep in mind is that
your lookup value columns should always
be sorted in ascending order while
trying to get an approximate match so
here we are going to use this table and
my lookup value column which is going to
be the representatives column is already
sorted in ascending order
and let's see the question we have here
so I want to find the items sold and the
unit cost format so my lookup value is
going to be matte now if you see this
table I don't have the representative's
name matte anywhere in the table now
using an approximate match I want to
find the item and the unit cost so let's
do it
so here under item I'll write my vlooker
formula
so I'll type vlookup I'll hit tab to
complete it
and this time meluco value is going to
be matte so I'll select the cell comma
my table array I'll select
from the representatives column till
the end of item column because I want to
find the item value format
I'll give a comma
my column index number as per the table
array is going to be 2
comma my range lookup this time I am
going to give a screw or one so I'll
write 1. close the bracket hit enter
all right it has written me binder was
the item sold by Matt
now let's try to figure out why vlookup
returned binder as the item
now let's see you were asked to insert
the name matte to the representative
column in alphabetical order so where
would you place it ideally you should
Place between qvel and Morgan
since this column is already sorted mat
should appear before Morgan and after
cubelle so in an approximate match
vlookup will consider the previous
highest value
in this case the previous highest value
before Matt is qvel
and hence vlookup returned the
corresponding item purchased by kevl
which is binder now similarly
if you wanted to find the unit cost
format
again vlookup will return the unit cost
of cubel which is 125. let's just try it
out so I'll write vlookup
my lookup value is matte comma my table
array for this time is going to be from
Representatives column
till the unit cost column I'll consider
I'll give a comma now the column index
number as per the table array is going
to be 4 I'll give another comma and this
time I'll double click true because I
want an approximate match we close the
bracket hit enter you can see it has
returned me 125 which is actually
kibble's unit cost okay we have another
question and this time I want to find
the units sold by Rob now Rob is going
to be my lookup value
if you see the representatives column we
don't have Rob now let's see what
vlookup is going to return as the item
for Rob so I'll write vlookup I'll give
my lookup value as Rob comma my table
array
is going to start from the
representatives column I'll select till
here I'll give a comma my column index
number is 2
we give another comma
I'll double click on true
if I close the bracket hit enter you can
see vlookup has written me pen now let's
understand why vlookup returned pen for
Rob now if you are asked to insert the
representatives name Rob
into this column so ideally Rob would
appear somewhere between Morgan and
Sorvino because
since this is sorted in ascending order
Rob is actually greater than Morgan and
is less than Sorvino so as you know
we look up in an approximate match
Returns the previous highest value which
is Morgan here and the corresponding
item for Morgan is pen and hence we look
up returned pen from Rob all right
now moving to the next sheet
which is another property of vlookup
which tells vlookup always looks to the
right this means that your lookup value
must always be on the left
and the value you are going to find out
should always be to the right of the
table now consider this scenario where
your lookup value is on the left in this
case it is the representatives value and
I have taken cervino for an example
and we want to find the order date for
Sorvino now if you consider this table
your lookup value which is sure we know
is actually this column the
representatives column and we are going
to find out the order date so your
representative's name is on the right of
the table and the value we are going to
find out is on the left of the table
now as per the property vlookup only
looks to the right
so if I use the vlookup function for
this example here I'll write vlookup
I'll give my lookup value as sorbino
comma
my table array I'll consider from the
order date because I want the order date
till
the representatives column I'll give a
comma and this time
my column index number is actually the
first column if I consider my table
array as the first three columns
selected
and my range lookup is going to be false
if I close the bracket hit enter it
returns me an error the reason is
vlookup always looks to the right and
this time the value we were trying to
find out was to the left of the table
now
if you consider
the opposite case suppose you have the
order date and you want to find the
representative's name you can do that
easily because you look up value which
is the order date is on the left and
your representatives column is on the
right so let's just try this I'll write
vlookup my lookup value is going to be
sorvino's order date so I'll select it
from the table
I'll give a comma my table array will
start from the G column let's say I'll
select the entire table
comma and my column index number will be
3 if you consider these as my table
array
comma my range lookup is zero if I close
this hit enter you can see we have got
Sorvino corresponding to the order date
all right now let's move to the next tab
now this tab says vlookup returns only
the first match so we have a question at
hand the question is
find the units sold by Jardine
if you see this table
we have the representatives name Jardin
twice you see here and if you look down
we have jar in here as well but the
items sold by Jardin at the first
instance is pencil and at the second
instance it's desk
now as per the property vlookup always
returns the first match now ideally when
we write the vlookup function and look
for the units sold by Jardine you will
see vlookup will return
36 instead of 3. let's just try it out
I'll write the vlookup function
my lookup value is Jardine
comma my table array
I'll select from the representatives
column till the end of
units column
we'll give a comma my column index
number based on the table array is three
I'll give another comma Now I want the
exact match so I'll select 0
close the bracket and hit enter
as you can see it returns me the first
match of Jardine which is 36 so vlookup
did not consider the second match
now similarly
if you consider this table
we have Jones repeated Thrice so you
have Jones here
we have Jones here for the second time
and also we have Jones for the third
time
and let's say
you want to find the unit cost for Jones
so if I write the vlookup function
I'll consider my
lookup value as Jones comma my table
array
I'll select from the representatives
column till the end of unit cost column
I'll give a comma based on the table
array my unit cost column is at the
fourth index so I'll write 4 comma the
range lookup is 0.
if I click on this
and hit enter you can see it here
vlookup has returned the first instance
of Jones and it did not consider the
second and the third instance so our
unit cost
for Jones is 1.99 because vlookup only
Returns the first match
okay moving ahead to the next example we
have here is vlookup is case insensitive
if you consider this table
I've added another
Row in green
so if you see here I have a
representative name called Gill which is
in proper case or
popularly known as sentence case here I
have added Gill's name in
capital letters or all in uppercase so I
want to find the total revenue generated
by Gill the total revenue is basically
the total column
let's do it all right vlookup
my lookup value is Dil which is actually
in upper case
I'll consider my table array from the
representatives column till the end of
total column or the sales column
based on the selection my column index
number is 5.
comma the range lookup is false so I'll
just double click on false
if we close the bracket hit enter
you can see it here
our vlookup function has returned the
total as
539.73 which is actually
the value for this row so clearly
vlookup did not consider Gill which was
present at the bottom of the table in
upper case
so this shows that vlookup is clearly
case insensitive
all right
now moving to the next example the
vlookup function supports wild cards
which makes it possible to perform a
partial match on a lookup value for
instance you can use vlookup to retrieve
values from a table after typing only
part of a lookup value to use wildcards
with vlookup you must specify the exact
match by giving false or 0 for the last
argument that is range lookup now we
have a question here
I want to know how much sales did the
representative whose name starts with Ki
make now here sales represents the total
column actually
so I want to find out the person whose
name starts with Ki
so if you consider the representative
column I have one representative whose
name starts with Ki that is kival so
using Ki as my lookup value I want to
find the total so let me show you how to
use Wild Card characters and find
the value using vlookup
so write my function vlookup
okay now in lookup value I'll give Ki
after that I am going to write Ampersand
followed by
double inverted commas
then I'm going to write a star
and close the inverted comma this means
the value starts with k i Ampersand
actually represents concatenation and
star represents anything followed by Ki
so this is going to be my lookup value
in total
I'll give a comma
next I'll select my table array starting
from the representatives column till the
end of total column because I want to
find the sales
I'll give another comma
my column index number based on the
table array we have selected is 5.
comma the range lookup is 0 because I
want to find an exact match
let's close the bracket hit enter you
can see it here
vlookup has returned me 999.5 which is
actually Cable's total
now there's another way to do it
instead of selecting the cell in which
we have the lookup value I can directly
write it in the vlookup function
so I'll write the vlookup function
something like this so my lookup value
I'll pass Ki within double inverted
commas because k i is a character value
So within double inverted commas I'm
writing Ki followed by Ampersand which
is for concatenation
followed by
a star
within double inverted commas so this is
going to be my look of values
this in total means anything that
appears after Ki will be considered as
the lookup value
again the table array I'll select as
these rows and columns
comma my column index number would be 5
comma the range lookup is zero if I
close the bracket hit enter you see we
have the same value so this is another
method or another way of using
vlookups
okay now moving ahead let's explore
another feature of vlookup so if the
vlookup function cannot find a match it
returns a hash an a error now if you
want you can use the if any function to
replace the hash any error with a
friendly message so suppose
you want to find the region in which an
order was placed on 10th of May 2018.
now if the order date is not found I
want to return a message that is invalid
date
so
if you look at the order date
column we don't have any value for 10th
of May 2015. you can see these values we
don't have any value corresponding to
this date
so
if my vlookup function cannot find this
lookup value I'll return invalid date so
let me show you
how to write this
I'll type my vlookup function
I'll give my order date as 10th of May
2015.
as my lookup value and then
I'll consider my table array starting
from the order date column till the end
of
region column
I'll give another comma my column index
number would be 2 this time based on the
table array we have selected comma
I want an exact match
so I'll give 0 close the bracket and hit
enter
there you go it has returned me a error
now I want to convert this error to a
friendly message saying invalid date so
let me show you how to do it I'll do it
here so to return a valid message
I'll use the if any function
and within if any function I'll give my
vlookup function
so let me type if any
I'll hit tab
now for the value parameter I'll use my
vlookup function so my lookup value is
going to be the order date
comma my table array I'll select from
the order date column till the end of
region column comma my column index
number is going to be 2
comma my range lookup is 0
I'll close the bracket give another
comma Now if this expression results in
an error I want to display a message
that is invalid date so I'll put invalid
date within double quotes
since it is
a text message
I close the bracket hit enter you can
see
the result which is invalid date
now moving on to the final section of
the demo
we have two-way lookup
now in the vlookup function the column
index parameter is normally hard-coded
as a static number however you can also
create a dynamic column index by using
the match function to locate the right
column
and this technique allows you to create
a dynamic two-way lookup matching on
both rows and columns
now let me first show you how a match
function works so suppose
I want to find the index where unit cost
column is present so here I'll use the
match function
I'll give my lookup value as the unit
cost column name
comma suppose I'll choose my lookup
array starting from Representatives
column till the unit cost column comma
I'll give my match type as 0 for exact
match
if I close the bracket hit enter it
returns me 4 because
my array was selected from the
representatives column till the unit
cost column and in this array unit cost
is at the fourth index
all right now using this idea let's
solve the following problem I want to
find the cost of each item sold by
Morgan
so let's
write our vlookup formula
write B lookup
my lookup value is J5 which has the
representative's name as Morgan comma
well table array I'll select from
C2
till
F12
I'll give a comma and this time I know
that my column index number is at
4 but I'll be using the match function
to find the same
so I'll write match
my lookup value is
unit cost comma
my lookup array is from C1 till F1
comma my match type is 0
I close this bracket give another comma
and I'll give my range lookup as 0
close the bracket hit enter you can see
for Morgan the unit cost is 19.99 you
can verify from the table for Morgan the
unit cost is 19.99
all right now
we have another question here
I want to find how much sales did
Andrews make in the central region so
here I have
two lookup values one is Central one is
Andrews now looking at these two values
I want to find the total
to solve such problems
let me first create
another table
I'll place the table somewhere here
okay so let me just paste the table here
all right now I'll create another column
where I'll merge the values of region
and representatives so here let me
create another column okay I'll just
name this column as
region
rep
all right now this column
I'll use the concatenation operator
so I'll Select East
use Ampersand and then select Jones I'll
hit enter
now the same thing I'll just duplicate
it
for the other rows as well so I have my
new column created Now using this table
I can easily solve the problem
now to find the total I'll write my
vlookup formula
so my lookup value
will be a combination of j11
ampersand
k11
comma well table array will start from
the region rep which has the values of
region and rep combined
till
the last column
and from this table array my column
index number is 5
and my range lookup is zero if I close
the bracket hit enter you can see
for central region which is this one
and for Andrews representative the total
is 149.25
all right now we are done with our demo
let's have a quick glance at what all we
did in this demo
okay so first of all we saw our data set
which was a sales data set that we used
then we started with our first example
to see how vlooker performs an exact
match we also saw how using the formulas
Tab and lookup and reference you can
write vlookup in
another way so you can use the function
arguments to give your vlookup
parameters next we saw how vlooker
performs an approximate match so we had
matte and raw which were not present in
the representatives column
after that
we saw an important property of vlookup
that is vlookup only looks to the right
followed by
vlookup only Returns the first match
following which we saw that vlookup is
case insensitive so here we had added a
new row where Gill was present in upper
case but still we look up
found the total revenue for Gill which
was in sentence case or properties next
we saw how we can use wildcard
characters to use vlookups
and here we saw how to use an if and a
function along with vlookup and finally
we saw how to use two-way lookups we
have to implement Excel purchase
template so on my screen you can see an
example Excel budget template theme
so on my screen you can see a column
where you have the debit amount so in
the I column we have all the amount what
we are spending for a month and on the
right column will be the balance amount
or the running balance of that for
example you can see that there is a row
number five where the debit amount is
8000 for our genes Levi's and it is done
through UPI payment now if I change this
value of 8000 to 4000 something
and then you can see that the running
balance will automatically change you
can see that currently the running
balance is 73 000 and if I change this
value from 8 000 to 4000 then all the
running balances will change let's do
that so for that let's press enter
there you go you can see that the number
has been changed successfully and all
the values from the running violence are
also changed until the last date which
is the March 30th
now how is this working and not just
that you can see that we have also
included what is the total debit amount
in January and what is the running
balance that is the total available
balance after one lakh has been debated
into the account in the month of
February as February income now the
current available violence is 1 lakh 13
200 and the total expense in February is
1 lakh 4500 right how am I doing on this
looks so much interesting right now
let's do this practically
so for that I have already created a new
sheet and I have included all the data
that we have used previously the income
of that particular month and all the
expenses of that particular month
now without further Ado let's begin to
implement the Excel budget template now
our first step happens to be converting
all the data into a natural table so you
know that in Excel all the data values
are stored in the form of a database by
default so it happens to be our duty to
convert the database stack table into
the pure table type table so for that
select quality data and press Ctrl T and
then we have an option to convert this
data into a table and remember to check
this particular checkbox and tell your
Excel that your table has headers so we
do have headers here so now press OK and
your table will be converted into a
natural table
now let's type in the formulas
so now let's select the cell J2
and type in the formula
so what are we doing here is we are
trying to add the sum of J2 plus H3
so which is this particular cell and
removing I3 that is this particular
debit amount so this formula is used for
checking the running balance let's press
enter and there you go
so it means that you received one lakh
rupees in the month of January and out
of that one lakh you spend 15 000 rupees
for something maybe your educational
load or something and then the remaining
running balance out of 1 lakh Rupees is
85 000 rupees now let's copy the same
formula to all these cells
and there you go now the running balance
has been calculated for all the cells
here now remember the monthly income
available balance and debit for January
and final bonds now let's try to
calculate that for all the three months
so here we have three months that is
January February and March now let's do
a simple calculation to find out the
available balance of that month and the
total debit made by that person in that
particular month
the formula is really simple all you
have to do is use a sum function and
calculate the sum of all these values
and done right
there you go so the total expense of the
month January is 93 800 rupees now let's
calculate the total doubt of February
month same formula that is
calculating the sum of all the expenses
made in the month of February
day
now let's also calculate the sum of all
the expenses in the month of March
done so we have the final values of all
the total expenses made in those
particular months now let's calculate
the final balance
now I think I forgot one important thing
so before we calculate the final balance
we need to find out the available values
that is the available balance after 1
lakh Rupees is created into our account
and along with the savings that you have
from your previous month right for that
we have a simple formula
now which all we are doing is just
adding the uh income cell with the
balance cell that's all
so there you go now after crediting one
lakh rupees and adding up the uh balance
of that particular month that is we have
13 200 remaining from the month of
January and the month of February we
have income of one lakh so the total
amount is 11 300 and
I don't know it is 1 lakh 13 200 yeah
now we have the final balance that is
the difference between the available
balance and the debit made in that
particular month so in the month of
February we had a total balance of one
lakh 13 200 and the total debit of one
lakh four thousand five hundred so the
final remaining balance is eight
thousand seven hundred
similarly the same formula has been
applied for the month of March and the
final balance we have is 37 300. so
that's how you implement budget template
in Excel all simple formulas and you
have all the numbers at your filling
tips user form and Excel
so what exactly is a user form so user
form is a graphical user interface that
helps you have a live interaction with
your worksheet which enables you to
enter or eliminate data from your Excel
worksheet through the graphical user
interface now let's get into the
Practical mode and start the Excel
workbook now we have launched our
Microsoft Excel so let us create a blank
workbook for now
now we have the blank workbook or
worksheet now before we get started with
the user forms in Excel the fundamental
step is to enable the developer menu on
the toolbar here you can find the
developer menu so basically it will not
be enabled as default to enable that you
need to get into file menu and inside
the file menu you can see the last menu
that is the options menu select that and
you will have a dialog box on your
screen and inside that you need to go
into the customized ribbon option
and inside the customize ribbon option
you have the main tabs scroll through
the main tabs and here you can find an
option called developer by default it
will not be enabled it will look
something like this but to enable that
you need to select the check option in
this and click on that and select ok now
the developer option will be enabled on
your tool menu so now you have your
developer option on your toolbar so to
get started with user forms in Excel
click on the developer option and here
you can see Visual Basic so click on
that Visual Basic and now you have your
new window opened right on your screen
so this is the visual basics for
applications
so here is where you create your user
forms
Now to create a user form just select on
insert menu and you have the option
called user form
now a new user form will be created for
you
and that is user form one
so this is the user form which you can
design and enable to interact with your
worksheet and help you insert data or
eliminate data for now let's try to
create a simple user form for employees
now here you can see the controls option
where you can find the various options
to provide an object into your user
phone so it might be a label it might be
a text box it might be a multi-page it
might be a command button it might be a
frame or a toggle switch many more for
now let's make it simple let's create a
label
so this is our first label we have just
dragged and dropped it and let us name
it as
so let us select it and rename it as
employee ID
now let's insert another label
drag and drop
as simple as it looks
select that
and rename it as employee
name
now another one you can also copy that
and paste it
and this should be our employee phone
number
now we have our three labels on the
screen
let's try to insert the text box
now this is our first text box
for employee ID
now let's copy and paste it
so another text box for employee name
copy and paste again and the last text
box for
employee form now let us try to insert
the button
so the First Command button let us
rename it as insert
now it is relocated to a little bit left
now let us try to insert another button
the second button would be
refresh sheet
uh the refresh button will play the role
of clearing the text boxes in case if
there is some data already entered if
you want to clear that you can just
press on refresh and it will be clear
now we have our user form so let us try
to rename our user form so here you can
see that we have the properties Tab and
inside the properties tab you can always
rename it and to rename it let us go
into caption and rename it as employee
is done
so our basic user form is ready now
let's get back to Excel sheet so
remember that we have created three
labels employee ID employee name and
employee phone we need to create the
exact same columns here
okay so employee
ID
let us expand the column a little bit
now
employee
name let us also increase the width
and finally we have employee funk
there you go
yeah we have our three columns
let us select all the three columns
and
align to Middle
you can also format your cells
let us select the green color
and text as White
and it is hold
yeah
pretty good
there you go so we have created our
sheet and it's ready now
now the last part remaining is we need
to code this particular user form
so coding in the sense we have two
buttons over here right so those buttons
should be performing some kind of
operation so for insert button the
operation should be inserting the data
which we have entered into these text
boxes so to program it just double click
on the insert button
here
eliminate everything
and paste this code so basically what we
did is we had this particular code
segment so this is the starting part of
the code segment and this is the ending
part of the code segment so we are
writing our code in between these two
lines
so what did we write here
so end of the row is sheets of sheet
name so this is the sheet name right
here we have a sheet name as sheet1 so
that is the sheet name where we want to
perform the operations and range from a
to rows count and XLR row that is we are
counting the number of rows here that
particular statement will count the rows
till the end of the sheet automatically
and after that it will shift to Xbox
value that is once the row number is
counted that is from 1 to n it will
start entering data from the first
available row
that is a column
a column then once the a column is
finished it will enter into B column and
subsequently into C
and once
the text boxes are entered the data that
is let's come back to here so once we
have entered all the text that is the
employee ID name and phone after
selecting the insert button
automatically these three text boxes
should go blank again you cannot have
the same data again in your
text box
so that is why we have included text box
value 1 null text box value to null text
box value 3 null so that was for command
operation insert now we should program
the command operation for refresh double
click on that
and you have the
code option over here so this particular
code will be automatically loaded from
The Click button one now for click
button 2 you need to add some more data
that is refreshing so whenever you press
the refresh button the text should go
blank so that will use the same code
from the previous click button or the
command button paste it over here and
they should perform the clearing
operation and it's done now close this
so select the employee data user form
and here you can see the Run option so
select that run option and the sheet has
the user form here now let us enter the
employee ID as one two three four five
and employee name as j o h n
okay caps lock is on
John employ phone as some 1800 231
and select the insert option and the
data got inserted now let us try to
insert another data one two three four
six
employee name click
and employ phone number one eight double
zero three four five Yeah by now you
might have guessed I am a fan of John
Wick yes
and yeah there you go we have entered
the second data over here now let me
show you another trick where you can
place all this user form as a macro and
replace this by just one single button
so whenever you press that button this
data form or user form will pop up and
you can directly start entering data so
for that let's get back to the Visual
Basic
and stop this particular execution and
you got your user phone back
now you need to insert a model get into
insert option and select the module or
model the its module not model
so inside this module you need to write
the command for macro
so here it is
so what we are basically doing is data
dot show or we can use an underscore and
get back to user form and rename this
uh cool
so what we are doing is entering the
subject as enter employee details this
will be the macro name and when this
macro is called the employee data user
form should be shown and once attached
shown the code should be ended let us
end subject now we have designed our
module
now let's get back to the sheet
and here go to the developer option go
to the insert menu and select button
and draw the button somewhere
and now you can select the enter
employee details macro and press OK and
now you have a button here
now you can edit this
edit it as press to enter
enter employee details
there you go
done so now whenever you press this
particular button the user form will
activate
okay
and you need to play this
okay the error was related to the
employee data sheet name we had to
rename the employee data from user form
to employ data initially it was just
user form we have renamed that to employ
data and now the code is fine so let's
get back to the sheet now if you press
this button the user form will
automatically start now let us try to
enter the data again one two three four
five seven this time and
some name
let's enter as
Jennifer
her phone number would be 1800-345
098 some random number and select insert
and the data has been inserted here so
this is how you work on user forms in
Excel why exactly do we need to do time
series analysis typically we would like
to predict something in the future and
it could be stock prices it could be the
sales or anything that needs to be
predicted into the future that is when
we use time series analysis so it is as
the name suggests it is forecasting and
typically when we say predict it need
not be into the future in machine
learning and data analysis when we talk
about predicting we are not necessarily
talking about the future but in Time
series analysis we typically predict the
future so we have some past data and we
want to predict the future that is when
we perform time series analysis so what
are some of the examples it would the
daily stock price the shares as we talk
about or it could be the interest rates
weekly interest rates or sales figures
of a company so these are some of the
examples where we use time series data
we have historical data which is
dependent on time and then based on that
we create a model to predict the future
so what exactly is time series so time
series data has time as one of the
components as the name suggests so in
this example let's say this is the stock
price data and one of the components so
there are two columns here column B is
price and column A is basically the time
information in this case the time is a
day so that primarily the closing price
of a particular stock has been recorded
on a daily basis so this is the time
series data and the time interval is
obviously a date time series or time
intervals can be daily weekly hourly or
even sometimes there is something like a
sensor data it could be every few
milliseconds or microseconds as well so
the size of the time intervals can vary
but they are fixed so if I am saying
that it is daily data then the interval
is fixed as daily if I'm saying this
data is an hourly data then it is the
data is captured every year and so on so
the time intervals are fixed the
interval itself you can decide based on
what kind of data we are capturing so
this is a graphical representation the
previous one here we saw the table
representation and this is how to plot
the data so on the y-axis is let's say
the price or the stock price and x axis
is the time so against time if you plot
it this is a Time series graph would
look so as the name suggests what is
time series data time series data is
basically a sequence of data that is
recorded over a specific intervals of
time and based on the past values so if
we want to do an analysis of Time series
First Data we try to forecast a future
and again as the name suggests it is
time series data which means that it is
time dependent so time is one of the
components of this data time series data
consists of primarily four components
one is the trend then we have the C
seasonality then cyclicity and then last
but not least irregularity or the random
component sometimes is also referred to
as a random component so let's see what
each of these components are so what is
strength trend is overall change or the
pattern of the data which means that the
data may be let me just uh pull up the
pen and show you so let's say you have a
data set somewhat like this a Time
series data set somewhat like this all
right
so what is the overall trend there is an
overall trend which is upward Trend as
we call it here right so it is not like
it is continuously increasing there are
times when it is dipping then there are
times when it is increasing then it is
decreasing and so on but overall over a
period of time from the time we start
recording to the time we end there is a
trend right there is an upward Trend in
this case so the trend need not always
be upwards there could be a downward
Trend as well so for example here there
is a downward Trend right so this is
basically what is a trend overall
whether the data is increasing or
decreasing all right then we have the
next component which is seasonality what
is seasonality seasonality as the name
suggests once again changes over a
period of time and periodic changes
right so there is a certain pattern
um let's take the sales of program
clothes for example so if if we plot it
along the months so let's say January
February March April May June July and
then let's say it goes up to December
okay so this is our December D I will
just mark it as D and then you again
have Jan Feb March and then you get
another December okay and just for
Simplicity let's mark these as December
says the end of the year and then one
more December okay so what will happen
when if you're talking about warm
clothes what happens the sales of warm
clothes will increase probably around
December when it is cold and then they
will come down and then again around
December again they will increase and
then the sales will come down and then
there will be again an increase and then
they will come down and then again an
increase and then they will come now
let's say this is the sales pattern so
you see here there is a trend as well
there is an upward Trend right the sales
are increasing over let's say these are
multiple years this is for year one this
is so here two this is for year 3 and so
on so for multiple years overall the
trend there is an upward Trend the sales
are increasing but it is not a
continuous increase right so there is a
certain pattern so what is happening
what is the pattern every December the
sales are increasing or they are peaking
for that particular year right then
there is a new year again when December
approaches the sales are increasing
again when December approaches the sales
are increasing and so on and so forth so
this is known as seasonality so there is
a certain fluctuation which is which is
periodic in nature so this is known as
seasonality then cyclicity what is
cyclicity now cyclicity is somehow
similar to seasonality but here the
duration between two cycles is much
longer so seasonality typically is
referred to as an annual kind of a
sequence like for example we saw here so
it is pretty much like every year in the
month of December the sales are
increasing however cyclicity what
happens is first of all the duration is
pretty much not fixed and the duration
or the Gap length of time between two
cycles can be much longer so the
recession is an example so we had let's
say recession in 2001 or 2002 perhaps
and then we had one in 2008 and then we
had probably in 2000 2012 and so on and
so forth so it is not like every year
this happens probably so there is
usually when we say recession there is a
slum and then it recovers and then there
is a slump and then it recovers and
probably there is another bigger slab
and so on right so you see here this is
similar to seasonality but first of all
this length is much more than a year
right that is number one and it is not
fixed as well it is not like every four
years or every six years that duration
is not fixed so the duration cap query
at the same time the gap between two
cycles is much longer compared to
seasonality all right so then what is
irregularity irregularity is like the
random component of the time series data
so there is like you have part which is
the trend which tells whether the
overall it is increasing or decreasing
then you have cyclicity and seasonality
which is like kind of a specific pattern
right uh then there is a cyclicity which
is again a pattern but at much longer
intervals plus there is a random
component so which is not really which
cannot be accounted for very easily
right so there will be a random
component which can be really random as
the name suggests right so that is the
irregularity component so these are the
various components of Time series data
yes there are conditions where we cannot
use time series analysis right so is it
can we do time series analysis with any
kind of data no not so what are the
situations where we are we cannot do
time series analysis so there will be
some data which is collected over a
period of time but it's really not
changing so it will not really not make
sense to perform any time series
analysis over it right for example like
this one so if we take X as the time and
Y as the value of whatever the output we
are talking about and if the Y value is
constant there is really no analysis
that you can do leave alone time series
analysis right so that is one another
possibility is yes there is a change but
it is changing as per a very fixed
function like a sine wave or a COS wave
again time series analysis will not make
sense in this kind of a situation
because there is a definite pattern here
there is a definite function that the
data is following so it will not make
sense to do a Time series analysis now
before performing any time series
analysis uh the data has to be
stationary and typically time series
data is not stationary so in which case
you need to make the data stationary
before we apply any models like arima
model or any of these right so what
exactly is stationary data and what is
meant by stationary data let us take a
look first of all what is non-stationary
data time series data if you recall from
one of my earlier slides we said that
type series data has the following four
components the trend seasonality
cyclicity and random random component or
irregularity right so if these
components are present in Time series
data it is non-stationary which means
that typically these components will be
present therefore most of the time A
Time series data that is collected raw
data is non-stationary data so it has to
be changed to stationary Data before we
apply any of these algorithms all right
so a non-stationary Time series data
would look like this which means like
for example here there is an upward
Trend the seasonality component is there
and also the random component and so on
so if the data is not stationary then
the time series forecasting will be
affected so you cannot really perform a
Time series for casting on a
non-stationary data so how do we
differentiate between a stationary and a
non-stationary Time series data
typically or technically one is of
course you can do it visually in
non-stationary data the the data will be
more flatish the seasonality will of
course be there but the trend will not
be there so the data May if we plot that
it may appear somewhat like this right
it's a horizontal line along the
horizontal line you will see compared to
the original data which was there was an
upward Trend so it was changing somewhat
like this right so this is not
stationary data and this is our
stationary data would look visually what
does this mean technically this means
that stationarity of the data depends on
a few things but the mean the variance
and the covariance so these are the
three components on which the
stationarity of the data depends so
let's take a look at what each of these
are for stationary data the mean should
not be a function of time which means
that the means pretty much remain
constant over a period of time right so
there is there shouldn't be any change
so this is how the stationary data
outlet and this is a non-stationary data
I've shown in the previous slide as well
so here the mean is increasing that
means there is an upward Trend okay so
that is one part of it and then the
variance of the series should not be
also a function of time so the variance
also should be pretty much common or
should be constant rather so this is a
if we visually we take a look this is
our time series stationary this data
would look when the variance is not
changing here the variance is changing
therefore this is non-stationary and we
cannot apply type series for casting on
this kind of data similarly the
covariance which is basically of the ith
term and the I plus MTH term should not
be a function of time as well so
covariance is nothing but not only the
variance at the ith term but the
relation between the variance of the ith
term and the I plus M meth or the I plus
NF term so as again once again visually
this is how it would look if the
covariance is also changing with respect
to time so these are the three all three
components should be pretty much
constant that is when you have
stationary data and in order to perform
time series analysis the data should be
stationary okay so let's take a look at
the concept of moving average or the
method of moving average and let's see
how it works we'll do simple
calculations so let's say this is our
sample data we have the data for three
months a January February March the
sales in hundreds of in thousands rather
not hundreds thousands of dollars is
given here and now we want to find the
moving average so how do we find the
moving average we call it as moving
average three so moving average three is
nothing but you take three of the values
of the readings add them up and divide
by three basically the way we take a
mean or average of the three values so
that is as simple as that so that's the
average first of all so what is moving
average moving averages if you now have
a series of data you keep taking the
three values the next three values and
then you take the average of that and
then the next three values and so on and
so forth so that is how you take the
moving average so let's take a little
more detailed example of car sales so
this is how we have the car sales data
for the entire year let's say so rather
for four years so year one we have for
each quarter what a one two three four
and then year two quarter one two three
four and so on and so forth so this is
how we have sales data of a particular
car let's say or a showroom and we want
to forecast for year five so we have the
data for four years we now want to focus
for the fifth year let's see how it
works first of all if we plot the data
as it is taking the raw data this is how
it would look and what do you think it
is is it stationary no right because
there is a trend upward Trend so this is
not a stationary data so we we
later we will see how to make it
stationary but to start with just an
example we will not worry about it for
now we will just go ahead and manually
do the forecasting using what is known
as moving average method okay so we are
not applying any algorithm or anything
like that in the next video we will see
how to apply an algorithm how to make it
stationary and so on all right so
here we see that all the three or four
components that we talked about are
there there is a trend there is a
seasonality and then of course there is
some random component as well cyclicity
may not be it is possible that cyclicity
is not applicable in all the situations
for sales especially there may not be or
unless you're taking a sales for maybe
20 30 years cyclicity may not come into
play so we will just consider uh
primarily the trend seasonality and
irregularity right so Random it is also
known as random irregularity right so we
were calling the random or irregularity
components so these are the three main
components typically in this case we
will talk about so this is the trend
component and we will see how to do
these calculations so let's take a look
re-draw the table including the time
code we will add another column which is
the time code and this is the column and
we just number it like one two three
four up to 16. the rest of the data
Remains the Same okay so we will do the
calculations now now let us do the
moving average calculations
um or ma4 as we call it for each year so
we take all the four quarters and we
take an average of that so if we add up
these four values and divide by 4 you
get the moving average of 3.4 so we
start by putting the value here so that
will be for the third quarter let's say
one two three the third quarter then we
will go on to the next one so we take
the next four values as you see here and
take the average of that which is the
moving average for the next quarter and
so on and so forth now if we just do the
moving average it is not centered so
what we do is we basically add one more
column and we calculate the centered
moving average as shown here so here
what we do is we take the average of two
values and then just adding these values
here so for example the first value for
the third quarter is actually the
average of the third and the fourth
quarter so we have 3.5 now it gets
centered so similarly the next value
would be 3.6 plus 3.9 divided by 2 so
which is 3.7 and so on and so forth okay
so that is the centered moving average
this is done primarily to smoothen the
data so that there are not too many
rough edges so that is what we do here
so if we visualize this data now this is
how it looks right so if we take the
centered moving average as you can see
there is a gradual increase if this was
not the case if we had not centered it
the changes will have been much sharper
so that is the basically the smoothening
that we are talking about now let's go
and do the forecast for the fifth year
so in order to do the forecast what we
will do is we will take the centered
moving average as our Baseline and then
start doing a few more calculations that
are required in order to come up with
the prediction so what we are going to
do is we are going to use this
multiplicity or multiplicative model in
this case and this is how it it looks so
we take the product of seasonality and
the trend and the irregularity
components and we just multiply that and
in order to get that this product of
these two We have basically the actual
value divided by CMA YT value divided by
CMA will give you the predicted value of
YT is equal to the product of all three
components therefore s t into i t is
equal to y t by CMA so this is like this
is equal to y t right so therefore if we
want s t into y t the product of
seasonality and irregularity it is equal
to YT by CMA so that is how we will work
it out I also have an Excel sheet of the
actual data so let me just pull that up
all right so this is how the data looks
in Excel as you can see here year one
quarter one two three four here two
quarter one two three four and so on and
this is the sales data and then this is
the moving average as I mentioned this
is how we calculate and this is the
centered moving average so this is the
primary component that we will start
working with and then we will calculate
since we want the product of s c into i
t that is equal to y t by CMA so if you
see this values are nothing but the YT
value divided by CMA so in this case it
is 4 by 3.5 which is 1.14 similarly 4.5
by 3.7 1.22 and so on and so forth so we
take we have the product St into it and
then the next step is to calculate the
average of respective quarters so that
is what we are doing here average of
respective quarters and then we need to
calculate the D seasonalized values so
in order to get decisionalized value we
need to divide y t by St that was
calculated so for example here it is 2.8
by 0.9 so we got the decisionalized
value here and then we get the trend and
then we get the predicted values so in
order to get the predicted value which
is basically we predict the values for
known values as well like for example
here one quarter one we know the value
but now that we have our model we
predict ourselves and see how close it
is so we predicted as 2.89 whereas the
actual value is 2.8 then we have 2.59
the actual value is 2.1 and so on just
to see how our model work works and then
continue that into the fifth year
because for fifth year we don't have a
reference value okay and if we plot this
we will come to know how well our
calculations are how well our manual
model in this case we did not really use
a model but we did on our own manually
so it will tell us the trend so for
example the predicted value is this gray
color here and you can see that it is
actually pretty much following the
actual value which is the blue color
right and the gray color is the
predicted value so the ACT wherever we
know the values up to year four we can
see that our predicted values are
following or pretty much very close to
the actual values and then from here
onwards when the year 5 starts the blue
color line is not there because we don't
have the actual values only the
predicted value so we can see that since
it was following the trend pretty much
for the last four years we can safely
assume that it has understood the
pattern and it is predicting correctly
for the next one year the next four
quarters right so that is what we are
doing here so these four quarters we did
not have actual data but we have the
predicted values so let's go back and
see how this is working in this using
the slides so this is we already saw
this part and uh I think it was easier
to see in the Excel sheet so we
calculated the St i t the product of St
and ID using the formula like here y by
YT by CMA if you got that and then we
got ST which is basically YT so this is
the average of the first quarters for
all the four years and similarly this is
the average of the second quarter for
all the four years and so on so these
values are repeating these are they are
calculated only once they get repeated
as you can see here and then we get the
decisionalized data and that is
basically YT by SD so we calculated St
here and we have YT so YT by St will
give you the DC analyze data and we have
got rid of the seasonal and The
Irregular components so far now what we
are left with is the trend and before we
start the time series forecasting time
series analysis as I mentioned earlier
we need to completely get rid of the
non-stationary components so we are
still left with the trend component so
now let us also remove the trend
component in order to do that we have to
find the or we have to calculate the
intercept and slope of the data because
that is required to calculate the trend
and how are we going to do that we will
actually use
um what is known as regression tool or
Analytics tool that is available in
Excel so you remember we have our data
in Excel so let me take you to the Excel
and here we need to calculate the
intercept and the slope in order to do
that we have to use the regression
mechanism and in order to use the
regression mechanism we have to use the
Analytics tool that comes with Excel so
how do you activate this two so this is
how you would need to activate the tool
from Excel you need to go to options and
in options there will be add-ins and in
add-ins you will have
analysis tool back and you select this
and you just say go it will open up a
box like this you say analysis tool pack
and you say Okay And now when you come
back in to the regular view of excel in
the data tab you will see data analysis
activated so you need to go to file
options and add-ins and then analysis
tool pack typically since I've already
added it it is coming at the top but it
would come under inactive application
add-ins so when you're doing it for the
first time so don't use VBA you just say
analysis tool pack there are two options
one with VBA like this one and one
without VBA so just use the one without
VBA and then instead of just saying okay
just take care that you click on this go
and not just okay so you say go then it
will give you these options only then
you select just the analysis tool pack
and then you say okay all right so and
then when you come back to the main view
you click on data okay so this is your
normal home view perhaps so you need to
come to data and here is where you will
see data analysis available to you and
then if you click on that there are a
bunch of possibilities what kind of data
analysis you want to do if there are
options are given right now we just want
to do regression because we want to find
slope and The Intercept so select
regression and you say okay
and you will get these options for input
y range and input X range input y range
is the value YT so you just select this
and you can select up to here and press
enter and input X range you can for now
you start with the baseline or you can
also start with the D season value so
you can just click on these and say okay
I have already calculated it so these
are the intercept and the coefficients
that we are getting for these values and
we will actually use that to calculate
our Trend here right so which is in the
J column so our trend is equal to
intercept plus slope into the time code
so The Intercept is out here as we can
see in our slide as well so if you see
here this is our intercept and the lower
value is the slope we have calculated
here and it's shown in the slides as
well so intercept so the formula is
shown here so our trend is equal to
intercept plus slope into time code time
code is nothing but this one t column a
one two three four okay so that's how
you calculate the trend and that's how
you use the data analysis tool from
Excel using these two we calculate the
predicted values and using this formula
which is basically trend is equal to
intercept plus slope into time code and
then we can go and plot it see how it is
looking and therefore so we see here
that the predicted values are pretty
close to the actual values and therefore
we can safely assume that our
calculations which are like our manual
model is working and hence if we go
ahead and predict for the fifth year so
till four years we know the actual value
as well so we can compare our model is
performing and for the fifth year we
don't have reference values so we can
use our equations to calculate the
values or predict the values for the
fifth year and we can go ahead and
safely calculate those values and when
we plot for the fifth year as well the
predicted values we see that they are
pretty much they capture the pattern and
we can save here assume that the
predictions are fairly accurate as we
can also see from the graph in the Excel
sheet that we have already seen okay so
let's go and plot it so this is how the
plot looks this is the CMA or the
centered moving average the green color
and then the blue color is the actual
data red color is the predicted value
predicted by our handcrafted model okay
so remember we did not use any regular
forecasting model or any tool we have
done this manually and the actual tool
will be used in the next video this is
just to give you an idea about how
behind the scenes or under the hood how
forecasting Works a Time series analysis
how it is performed okay so it looks
like it has captured the trend properly
so up to here is the known difference we
have referenced and from here onwards is
purely predicted and as I mentioned
earlier we can safely assume that the
values are accurate and predicted
properly for the fifth year so let's go
ahead and implement moment a Time series
forecast in r first of all we will be
using the arima model to do the forecast
of this time series data so let us try
to understand what is arima model so
arima is actually an acronym it stands
for auto regressive integrated moving
average so that is what is arima model
and it is specified by three parameters
which is p d and q p stands for auto
regressive so let me just mark this so
there are three components here Auto
regressive integrated moving average
okay so these three parameters
correspond to those three components so
the P stands for auto regressive D for
integrated and Q for moving average so
let us see what exactly this is so these
three factors are p is the number of
Auto regressive terms or ar we will see
that in a little bit and D is how many
levels of differences that we need to do
or differentiation we need to do and Q
is the number of lagged forecast error
so we'll see what exactly each of these
are so AR is the number of Auto
regressive terms and which is basically
denoted by the p and then we have t
which is for the number of times it has
to be differentiated and then we have q
which is for the moving average so what
exactly AR terms so in terms of the
regression model autoregressive
components are refer to the prior values
of the current value what we mean by
that is here when we talk about time
series data focus on the fact that there
is regression so what exactly happens in
regression we try to do something like
if it is simple linear regression we do
have some equation like Y is equal to MX
plus C where there are actually there
are two variables one is the dependent
variable and then there is an
independent variable let me just
complete this equation as well MX plus C
right so this is a normal regression
curve or a simple regression curve now
here we are talking about Auto
regression or or Auto regressive so Auto
regressive as the name suggests is
regression of itself so which means that
here you have only one variable which is
your maybe the cost of the flights or
whatever it is right and the other
variable is basically time dependent and
therefore the value at any given time
and that we will denote as Y T for
example so there is no X here there is
only one variable and which is y and we
say y t which is basically the predicted
value at a time interval T for example
is dependent on the previous value so
for example there may be A1 and then y t
minus 1 and then there will be like plus
A2 and right plus A2 and Y T minus 2 and
all right and then plus A3 into y t
minus 3 all right so basically here what
we are saying is there's only one
variable here but there is a regression
component so we are doing a regression
on itself so that's how the term Auto
regression comes into plane so only
thing is that it is dependent on the
previous time values so there is a lag
let's say this is the first lag second
leg third lag and so on so the current
value which is y t is dependent on the
previous time lag values so that is what
is auto regression component so this is
what is shown here for example in this
case instead of Y we are calling it as X
so that's the same and this is
represented by some equation of that
sort depending on how many lags we take
so that is the AR component and the term
p is basically determines how many lags
we are considering so that's the B form
now what is d d is the degree of
differencing so here differencing is
like to for the non-seasonal differences
right so for example if you take the
values like this which are given for
five or six and so on and so forth if
you take the differencing of one after
another like for example 5 minus 4 or 4
minus 5 the next value with the previous
value so 4 minus 5 so this is known as
the first order differencing so the
result is minus one similarly 6 minus 4
is 2 7 minus 6 is 1. so this is first
order differencing and here we call it
as D is equal to 1 okay and same way we
can have second order third order and so
on then the last one is q q is the
actually why we call it moving average
but in reality it is actually the error
of the model so we also sometimes
represent as e t all right so now arima
model works on the assumption that the
data is stationary which means that the
trend and seasonality of the data has
been removed that is correct okay so
this we have discussed in the first part
how what exactly is stationary data and
how do we remove the non-stationary part
of it now in order to test whether the
data is stationary or not there are two
important components that are considered
one is the autocorrelation function and
there is the partial order correlation
function so this is referred to as ACF
and pacf all right so what is sort of
correlation and what is the definition
or correlation is basically the
similarity between values of a same
variable across observations as the name
suggests now how do we actually find the
article relation function the value
right so this is basically done by
plotting and autocorrelation function
also tells you how correlated points are
with each other based on how many time
steps they are separated by and so on
that is basically the timeline that we
were talking about and it is also used
to determine how past and future data
points are related and the value of the
autocorrelation function can vary from
-1 to 1. so if we plot this is how it
would look autocorrelation function
would look somewhat like this and there
is actually a readily available function
in R so we will see that and you can use
that to plot your nautical relation
function okay so that is ACF and we will
see that in our R studio in a little bit
and similarly you have partial order
correlation function so partial
autocorrelation function is the degree
of association between two variables
while adjusting the effect of one or
more additional variables so this again
can be measured and it can also be
plotted at its value once again can go
from -1 to 1 and it gives the partial
correlation of Time series with its own
lagged values so lag again we have
discussed in the previous couple of
slides this is a psef plot would look in
our studio we will see that as well and
once we get into the r studio and with
that let's get into our studio and take
a look at our use case before we go into
the code let's just quickly understand
what exactly is the objective of this
use case so we are going to predict some
values of four plus some values and we
have the data of the airline ticket
sales of the previous years and now we
will try to find the predict or forecast
the values for the future years all
right so we will basically identify the
time series components like Trend
seasonality and random Behavior we will
actually visualize this in our studio
and then we will actually forecast the
values based on the password sorry
history data historical data so these
are the steps that we follow we will see
in our studio in a little bit just
quickly let's go through what are the
steps reload the data and it is the time
series data and we try to find out what
class it belongs to the data is actually
air passengers data that is already
comes pre-loaded with rstudio so we will
be using that and we can take a look at
the data and then what is the starting
point what is the end point so these are
all functions that are readily available
we'll be using and then what is the
frequency which basically frequency is
12 which is like yearly data right so
every month data has been collected so
for each year it is 12 and then we can
check for many missing values if there
are any and then we can take a look at
summary of the data this is what we do
in exploratory data analysis and then we
can plot the data visualize the data how
it is looking and we will see how the
data has some Trends seasonality and so
on and so forth all right then we can
take a look at the cycle of the data
using the cycle function version and we
can see that it is every month that's
the cycle end of every 12 months the new
cycle begins so each month of the year
is uh the data is available then we can
do box plots to see for each month how
the data is varying over the various 10
or 12 years that we will be looking at
this data and from exploratory data
analysis we can identify that there is a
trend there is a seasonality component
and how the seasonality component varies
also we can see from the box plots and
we can decompose the data we can use the
decompose function rather to see the
various components like the seasonality
trend and the irregularity part okay so
we will see all of this in our studio
this is how they will look this is the
Once you decompose and this is how you
will actually you can visualize the data
this is the actual data and this is the
trend as you can see it's going upwards
this is the seasonal component and this
is your random or irregularity right so
we call it irregularity or we can also
call it random as you can see here yes
so the data us have a constant variance
and mean which means that it is
stationary before we start any analysis
time series analysis and without so
basically if it is stationary only then
it is easy to model the data perform
time series analysis so we can then go
ahead and fit the model as we discussed
earlier we'll be using a Remo model
there are some techniques to find out
what should be the parameter so we will
see that when we go into rstudio so the
auto arima function basically tells us
what should be the parameters right so
these parameters are the p d and q that
we talked about that's what is being
shown here so if we use Auto arima it
will basically take all possible values
of this PDQ these parameters and it will
find out what is the best value and then
it will recommend so that is the
advantage of using Auto arima all right
so like in this case it will tell us
what if we use this parameter Trace we
set the parameter Trace is equal to true
then it will basically tell us what is
the value of this AIC which has to be
minimum so the lower the value the
better so for each of these combinations
of p d and q it will give us the values
here and then it will recommend to us
which is the best model okay because
each other has the lowest value of this
AIC it will recommend that as your best
PDQ values so once we have that we can
see that we will basically we can
potentially get a model or the equation
model is nothing with the equation and
based on the parameters that we get and
we can do some Diagnostics we can do
some plotting to see how whether there
is a plot for the residuals so which
shows the stationarity and then we can
also take a look at the ACF and psef we
can plot the ACF and pacf and then we
can do some forecasting for the future
year so in this case we have up to 1960
and then we can see how we can forecast
for the next 10 years which is 1970 up
to 1970. and once we have done this can
we validate this model yes definitely we
can validate this model and uh to
validate the findings we use uh jump box
test and this is how you just call box
DOT test and then you pass these
parameters and you will get the values
that will be returned which will tell us
whether this how accurate this model is
how accurate the connections are so the
values of P are quite insignificant in
this case we will see that and that also
indicates that our model is free of
autocorrelation and that will basically
be it so let's go back and into our our
studio and go through these steps in
real time so we have to import this
Library forecast package is not
installed you have to go here and
install the forecast package okay so
that the easy way to install rather than
so click on this install I will not do
it now because I've already installed so
the first step that's only one time then
after that you just have to load it into
memory and then keep going so we will
load this data called air passengers so
by calling this data method and if you
see the the data passengers is loaded
here and if we check for the class it is
a Time series data TS data so we can
check for the dates you can also view
the data in a little bit and the start
date is 1949 and January
and our end date is 1960 December and
the frequency is 12 which is like
collected monthly so that is the
frequency which is uh 12 here and then
we check if there are any missing values
there are no missing values and then we
take a look at the summary of the data
this is all exploratory data analysis
and then if you just display the data
this is how it looks
and then we need to decompose this data
so we will kind of store this in an
object yes data and then use that to
decompose and store the new values so
let me just clear this for now and if we
decompose basically as we have seen in
the slides decomposing is breaking it
into the transitionality and irregular
or random components then you can go
ahead and plot it so when you plot it
you can see here let me Zoom this this
is our original plot or observed value
as it is known as then we have
decomposed the three parts which is
basically the trend as you can see there
is a upward Trend then the seasonal
component so this is some regularly
occurring pattern and then there is a
random value which is basically you
cannot really give any equation or
function or anything like that so that's
what this plotting has done and then you
can actually plot them individually as
well so these are the individual plots
for the trend for the seasonal component
and the random component all right so
now let's take a look at the original
data and see how the trend is in a way
so if we do this linear regression line
it will show that it is going upwards
and we can also take a look at the cycle
that are there which is nothing but we
have a frequency of 12 right so the
Cycles will display that it is January
February to December and then back to
January February and so on and so forth
and if we do box plots for the monthly
data you will see that for each of the
months right and over the 10 years that
the data that we have we will see that
there is a certain pattern right this is
also in a way to find the seasonality
component so while January February
sales are relatively low around July
August the sales pick up so especially
in July I think the sales are the
highest and this seems to be happening
pretty much every year right so this is
every year in July AI there seems to be
a peak in the sales and then it goes
down and slightly higher in December and
so on so that is Again part of our
exploratory data analysis and once again
let's just plot the data now as I said
in order to fit into an arima model we
need the values of PD and Q now one way
of doing it is there are multiple ways
actually of doing it the earlier method
of doing it was you draw the
autocorrelation function plot and then
partial order correlation function plot
and then observe that and where does
this change and then identify what
should be the values of PE and Q and so
on now R really has a very beautiful
method which we can use to avoid all
that manual process that we used to do
earlier so what R will do is there is a
method called Auto arima and if we just
call this Auto arima method and it will
basically go and test the arima model
for all possible values of this
parameters PDQ and then it will suggest
to you what should be the best model and
it will return that best model with the
right values of PD and Q so u v as data
scientists don't have to do any manual
you know trial and error kind of stuff
okay so we got the model now and this is
the model it has PDQ values are two one
one PDQ and this is the seasonal part of
it so we can ignore it for now and so if
we want to actually understand how this
has returned these values to one one as
the best one there is another
functionality or feature where we can
use this Trace function or Trace
parameter so if you pass to Auto arima
the trace parameter what it will do is
it will show you how it is doing this
calculation what is the value of the AIC
basically AIC this is what you know
defines the accuracy of the model the
lower the pattern okay so for each
combination of PDQ it will show us the
value of AIC so let's run it before
instead of me talking so much let's run
this if we run Auto arima with Trace you
see here there is a red mark here that
means it is performing it's executing
this and here we see the display right
so it starts with certain values of PDQ
and then it finds that value is too high
so it starts with a gain with some 0 1 1
0 and so on and so forth and ultimately
it tells us okay this is our best model
you see here it says this is our best
model two one one let's go back and see
did we get the same one yes we got the
same one when we ran without Trace as
well right now Y is 2 1 1 let us see
where is two one one here is our two one
one and if you compare the values you
see that 1 0 1 7 is pretty much the
lowest value and therefore it is saying
this is our best model all other values
are higher so that's how you kind of get
your model and now that you have your
model what you have to do you need to
predict the values right so before that
let us just do some test of these values
so for that you install T-Series again
if you are doing it for the first time
you would rather use this package and
install and say T-Series and install it
and then you just use this Library
function to load it into your memory all
right so now that we got our model using
Auto arima let us go ahead and forecast
and also test the model and also plot
the ACF and psef remember we talked
about this but we did not really use it
we don't have to use that but at least
we will visualize it and for some of the
stuff we may need this T-Series or
Library so if you are doing this for the
first time you may have to install it
and my recommendation is don't use it in
the code you go here and install
T-Series and I will not do it now again
because I have already installed it but
this is a preferred method and once you
install it you just load it using this
library's function and then you can plot
your residuals and this is how the
residuals look and you can plot your ACF
and psef okay so this is how your tacf
looks and this is how your ACF looks for
now there is really nothing else we need
to do with ACF and pacf is just to
visualize how that how it looks but as I
mentioned earlier we were actually using
these visualizations or these graphs to
identify the values of p d and q and how
that was done it's uh out of scope of
this video so we will leave it at that
and then we will forecast for the next
10 years how do we focus that so we call
forecast and we pass the model and we
pass what is the level of accuracy that
you need which is 95 percent and for how
many periods right so basically we want
for 10 years which is like 10 into 12
time periods so that's what we are doing
here and now we can plot the forecast
value so you see this is the original
value up to I think 62 or whatever and
then it goes up to 72. this blue color
is the predicted value let's go and zoom
it up so that we can see it better so
from here onwards you're forecasting and
you can see that it looks like our model
has kind of learned the pattern and this
pattern looks very similar to what we
see in the actual data now how do we
test our model so we can do what is
known as box test and we pass our model
here residuals basically with different
lags and from those values here the P
values here we find that they are
reasonably in low P values which means
our model is fairly accurate now
Microsoft Excel has a lot of interesting
features and one of the exciting
features in Excel is to send automated
emails by writing sample VBA Scripts we
will look at how you can automate an
Outlook application and send several
emails with attachments from Excel
Market people in CC and BCC
so let's open the Excel spreadsheet okay
so I'll click on this blank workbook
all right
now before we jump into the Hands-On
part of this tutorial let me tell you
the purpose of using Excel to send
emails
there could be multiple reasons for
which you might want to send an email
using Excel
suppose you have a team that updates
spreadsheets or documents or let's say
reports monthly and you want to get an
alert message when those updates are
complete
now this is a simple case where you can
use VBA to send automated emails
another example could be let's say you
have a list of customer names in a
column in Excel
suppose in Excel you have a list of
customers like this
and you have the file path
of a related file for each of the
customers in another column let's say in
column d
so your task is to send one email to
each customer and attach the correct
file
so this is another example of using VBA
to trigger automated emails
so now let's start with our
demonstration
you can send emails directly from Excel
with a few clicks without having to
write any codes now let me show you how
to do that
so here in my Excel workbook if you look
at the top left corner
there's a drop down here which says
customize quick access toolbar if I
click on this drop down you see there
are a list of options you have
automatically save new open and here you
can see something called as email you
have other things as well like Quick
Print
spelling check undo redo and others but
we are interested with email so if I
click on this email it will add this
email
to our quick access toolbar which is
here on the top let me click on email
there you go you see here we have the
email icon now if I click on this email
icon
you have the interface where you can
send
emails directly from Excel without
having to type any VBA script or code so
here you can specify your two address
you can see I have a list of address
names available here
and you can also Mark people in CC which
means carbon copy now
you can also write a subject you see
here I have a subject written test email
using Excel and I have my current
workbook attached now here on the top
you can see you have a lot of other
options like file you have the message
where we are currently in then you have
the option to insert you can attach some
other file you can add your signature
you can draw something you can use these
options to change the theme colors fonts
and given
effects you can also
change the format of the text
here you have review as well as help
so this is a very easy way to send email
from Excel
now
we will see how to send email in Excel
using BBA so let me close this
okay so I am on my Excel workbook
you need to write a few sample scripts
to send email using VBA so let's
understand the steps to send emails
through Outlook from Ms Excel using BBA
now another thing that I've
forgot to tell you
if you want to use this feature of
directly sending emails to people
without having to type any code you need
to create
an Outlook account so I've already
created my Outlook account but if you
don't have an Outlook account first you
need to create an Outlook account all
right
now let's see how you can write VBA
scripts and send automated emails for
that we need to first go to the
developer tab here on the top now in the
developer tab we need to select the
Visual Basic
option or you can just
type alt f11 let me click on this Visual
Basic
and this will open the VB code editor
now to access Outlook with VBA you need
to activate the Microsoft Outlook object
Library so for this you need to go to
tools here on the top you have tools
I'll click on this and then
with tools you need to go to references
all right
now under references you need to select
the Microsoft Office 16.0
you can see here I have already selected
the Microsoft Office 16.0 object Library
you also have to select the Ole
Automation and then you should also have
Microsoft Office 16.0 object Library
and this Visual Basic for applications
is already selected by default you don't
have to worry about that but the other
three you need to assure that these are
selected and then click on OK
okay
The Next Step
we need to navigate to the insert tab so
I have my insert tab here and click on
module so I have created a new module
here you can see here it says module one
and this is where we will type our VBA
script to send emails
Now to create a sub procedure in VBA
I'll just
write
sub
I'll say send
email underscore
let's say demo
I'll give parenthesis and click enter
automatically it has given my answer
where my script will end or the sub
procedure will end
okay
now for those of you who are not very
acquainted with how
quotes are written or your program in
VBA we already have a video on vbn
Macros so I would recommend you to
please check that video
cool
now next
so we had given reference to Outlook now
we can access the properties of Outlook
in VBA let's now declare an object
variable called
outlook.application to refer to the
Outlook object
so what I'm going to do here is
I'll give a comment first which says to
refer to
Outlook application
now it is recommended to use comments in
your script or code
this makes your code very readable
so I'll start with dim
and then
I'll give my variable as
let's say email app
as
r
object variable which is
Outlook dot application
okay
I'll come to the next line
now to send an email we need to declare
another variable that will use Microsoft
outlooks property to refer to a new
email
so in the next line I'll give another
comment which says
to
refer to new
Outlook email
here I'll write dim
I'll create my
new variable which says new email
item
as
I'll say
Outlook dot mail item
all right so this line of code
will use Microsoft outlooks property to
refer to a new email
all right
now moving to the
next line
this time
if you want to attach the current
workbook in your mail
you must first declare a variable source
as a string so I'll write dim
SRC which stands for Source then I'll
say as
string
now the reason
source is a string is because we will
provide the file path where the
file is located and
the name of the file is often a string
okay
next
now
we are going to create an instance of a
new object separately
so for that I'll give my comment to
Launch
Outlook application
okay I just did a smelling mistake here
I'll change this to launch okay
so to create an instance of a new object
separately
we'll use the set keyword and then
followed by
this variable name
just close this which is email app so
I'll write email app equal to I'll say
new
outlook.application
okay
now moving ahead
in the next step
we will create an instance for a new
email that will open the new email using
the set keyword
so for this we'll use the
application.create item method that will
create and return a new Microsoft
Outlook item
so I'll give another comment
which will C to Launch
new
Outlook email
okay
I'll go to the next line again I'm going
to use my set keyword
and now I'll write new
email item which we had passed
on the top you see here while we were
referring to the new
Outlook email I'll just click on cancel
here
it should be Outlook okay
so coming back to this line we'll see
new
email item
equal to
I'll say
email app Dot then we'll use the
create item method
and inside this we are going to pass the
date type which is of
ol mail item
close this
moving ahead okay so here on the top
there should be a space between new
outlook I have made a spelling mistake
okay
now we'll use the two property and
assign the email address to whom we want
to send the email
so I'll write new
email
item
dot I'll use the to property
give equal to and within double quotes
you need to pass in the
email ID to whom you want to send the
email so here I'm going to use my
official email ID
now one thing to
note here is once the video goes live we
are going to blur the email IDs that I'm
using in this video
okay
so in two I have passed in my email ID
next
if you like to CC anyone in the email
you can use the CC property as well so
I'll write new
email
item
dot CC
I'll give an equal to sign and again
within double quotes
I'll pass in the email ID of the person
okay
now moving ahead similarly you can also
use the BCC property if you want to Mark
someone in BCC you can pass in their
email IDs as well
so I'll write new email
item Dot
this time I'll use the BCC property and
within double quotes I'll pass in the
email address
okay
then the next step
you can give the subject of the email so
for that we will use the dot subject
property
so I'll pass in my
variable name which is new email item
this is also called as an object
so I'll write new email item Dot I'll
use the subject property equal to so
let's give a subject to our email let's
say test email
demo you can give
whichever subject line you want
now you can write the body of the email
by using the HTML body type so let me
show you how to do that I'll pass in my
object which is new email
item Dot
I'll use the
HTML
body type
given equal to and here
we are going to write whatever we want
to put in the body of the email
I'll use
a new
object which is called VB new line
now this BB new line is to insert a new
line
in the body of the email so let's start
with the body of the email let's see
I'll write
within double quotes I'll say hi
given Ampersand and write
VB
new line
I'll give another Ampersand and again
give another new line by writing VB new
line
and I'll give
Ampersand again
and then
I'll write let's say this
is a
test
email
from
Excel
all right
I'll give
my double quotes
give an ampersand again
and then
I'll given underscore and come to the
next line
and here
I'll again see
VB
new line
given ampersand
I'll give another new line
so I'll write VB
new line
to the number sent
and an underscore
and then
I'll close my mail by writing let's say
regards
give a comma
then I'll again give ambersand VB
new line
given ampersand
and underscore and go to the next line
and I'll
keep my signature
let's see
Jimmy
okay
so
what we did was we created our body of
the email by writing new email item Dot
and we use the HTML body type and my
body has high
with two new lines and in the third line
we have the
body which sees this is a test email
from Excel and then I have my closing
statement
which is the signature that is regards
Jimmy
now after the male body
you can assign this workbook dot full
name to Source variable so this is going
to attach the workbook that we are
working on to your email so I'll write
SRC which we created here on the top
I'll give an equal to and say
this
workbook dot I'll use full name
if I hit tab it will auto complete
now here this workbook refers to the
current workbook and Dot full name
refers to the full name of the worksheet
now you can send the attachment using
the attachments property
so the way to do is
I'll write
new
email item Dot
I'll use the
attachments property
and I'll write add SRC
now if you want to send any other
attachment you have to pass in the files
location on your computer along with the
extension of the file now
if I go to
my folder I have a folder in my D drive
which says email in Excel files so there
are two files here one is an image this
is a JPEG image and this is a text file
which has employees data
you can see here I have opened it on a
notepad and it has some insert into
students values so basically we are
inserting some values to a student's
table it has some information regarding
that so suppose you want to
attach these two files in your email you
can do that so let's see how to do it
so coming to the
next few lines I'll write
email
item
Dot
I'll say
attachments Dot
add
and here
I'll pass in
my file location
within double quotes
so
I'm going to copy this location
and I'll paste it here
and I'll give another
backslash
and
followed by the backslash we are going
to
give the file name along with the
extension of the file
if you see here my file name is employee
data so I'll write
employee space data Dot txt
and I'll close this
copy this
and I'll paste it here
and the next file we are going to attach
is
my logo let me just rename this I'll
just write
logo
okay
and you can check the data type by going
to the properties you see here it is of
type jpg
and we'll use the same extension for
this I'm going to delete this and make
it as logo Dot
gpg
okay
now if you want to display the email to
edit the email body manually or ensure
everything looks correct you can use the
dot display method
so what I'm going to do is
I'll write
new
email
item
dot I'll use the display property and
I'll say
displays true
then finally
you want to
send the email to the mentioned email
addresses
you need to use the dot send method
so even dot displays a method and not a
property
okay so I'll write now
new
email
item
Dot send
okay
so we have our code ready here let me go
to the top and tell you what we did so
first I created my
sub procedure which is send email
underscore demo then we created our
variables email app which is
to refer to Outlook application then we
had new email item which was to refer to
new Outlook email then we passed in our
source string then to launch our Outlook
application we used
new outlook dot application
now to
launch
new Outlook email we use the email app
dot create item method
and then we saw how to use the dot to
property CC BCC we root our subject then
we passed in our email body and then we
saw how to attach the current workbook
using the attachments property or the
method
then we passed in r
two files which was employed data and
the logo file by giving the
file location and using the
attachments.add method finally we are
displaying and sending the email
before I run it this should be new email
item
again this should also be new email item
okay
now you can see here I have saved it as
email underscore demo dot Excel SM which
means this workbook is now macros
enabled
all right
so now it's time for us to go ahead and
run our script so here on the top you
can see we have the Run option
let's go ahead and run it
it says there is some compilation error
let's debug it
okay so in the references we actually
missed adding one of the other
references
let's do it now so I am actually looking
for
Microsoft
Outlook 16.0 let's search and add it
I'll show you which one
okay so this object Library which says
Microsoft Outlook 16.0 object Library we
missed adding initially so let's add
this as well
all right so now let's go ahead and run
our script
you see here on the top you can see the
subject test email demo and we have the
message box
you see here we have attached
three files the one is the email
underscore demo.xlsm which is the
current workbook we are working on then
we have the employee data file and we
have the logo PNG file as well and these
are my email IDs that I had put in my
script and Below you can see the body of
the mail if you want you can edit it
here you can bring these to the next
line
all right now if you just click on send
the email will be triggered now this
happened because
in the script we have used the dot
display method now the display method
ensure that you can edit your email body
and make sure everything looks correct
before sending the email I'll go ahead
and close this
I'll say no
and what I'm going to do here is
I'm going to comment this line which
says new email item dot display true so
every time we run this VBA script our
display
box that we just saw won't appear it
will directly trigger the mail by
sending it now let's run it again
okay now we are going to check our
mailbox now
okay so this is how our
email looks like on the top you have the
subject of the email which is test email
demo and then below you can see the body
of the mail which says hi this is a test
email from Excel regards Jimmy and at
the bottom you can see we have the three
attachments the first is the simply loan
logo then we have the employee data
which is present in a doc file and third
we have the Excel file that we are
working on all right
now first up what exactly is mail merge
mail merge in Excel is a simple yet
spectacular method to write similar
emails to hundreds and thousands of
recipients without a hassle or even a
single error let us imagine that you are
supposed to write an interview call
letter to multiple recipients
so what if you had like five recipes you
could do five different emails and you
could send them but what if you had 50
or even 500
right that would seem a little
Troublesome and you might even feel that
you might want a whole team to do that
right but what if I say that you can do
the same with one single mail within a
matter of minutes you send all the
emails to all the 50 or 500 recipients
sounds interesting right so now in this
particular tutorial we are going to do
the scene now without further Ado let's
directly get on to the Practical mode
and start our Excel and try to do some
mail merge in Excel
now we are on practical mode and we have
started our Microsoft Excel so regarding
the example we discussed earlier that is
sending an interview call letter to
multiple people that's what exactly this
Excel sheet does so here we have about
25 members or 25 candidates with their
first name last name and email and their
address written over now where is our
call letter now this happens to be our
call letter so the call letter is been
sent from an imaginary company that is
smart Solutions private limited India
and followed by that we are having one
recipient here who happens to be Mia and
the subject and everything all the text
related to the interview call
now we are trying to send this one
single interview call letter to all the
25 people now the only change that is
going to happen is the recipient's name
and address is going to change and the
addressing for example here you can see
dear Mia so instead of dear Mia we're
going to greet the recipient with their
particular name so that's what we're
going to try to do now so to do that you
have to go into the toolbar and select
mailings option
in the mailings option you can see the
start mail merge select recipients edit
recipient and all other options so here
you might want to select the second
group and inside the second group you
have an option called select recipients
click on that and now it will show you
some options the first one is type A new
list so if you are having Sim list then
you can type in or if you already have
an existing list like what we did
creating an Excel sheet and storing all
the email and address and all the
recipients complete details you can use
that as well
so here we're going to use the existing
list so click on that
now it will show you a new dialog box
using which you have to navigate to the
existing list so our existing list is
named as mail merge so click on that and
select open
now press ok
now the next part is to address all the
details
so here
you can see that
to address and after that you can see
the addressing of the recipient now we
have to encode this mail in such a way
that to all the recipients automatically
Excel will replace the addresses names
and the greetings right now let's try
that
now let's try to encode the address part
so highlight the address part and in the
same mail links option you can find the
address block and write and insert
Fields ribbon
so let's select that and now you can see
the address of everyone
right
so this is the preview of the
recipient's address now you can see that
the recipient's full name and state is
only available here not this street and
house number Etc now you can fix that by
selecting the match Fields option and
here you can include the address so
which might be the Hauser department and
the second one would be Street and
postal code you can match it with PIN
code
and that's all yeah remaining we have
everything else let's look at the
preview and this is how it looks like
perfect
now let's select ok
that's fine
and similarly we will also try to match
the
just a moment yeah similarly we'll try
to encode the recipient's name now for
that let's go into the greetings line
here you can see you can select the
option Dear Sir or dear Mom or to
whomever mates may concern and here you
have another option two or just dear so
we'll go with deer and this is how the
preview looks like
and if you're happy with that it's okay
and if you want to parallely check for
other things I mean other recipients you
can also do that for example the next
recipient is Santosh shastri and
followed by him we have prabhakar Reddy
Rajesh saho right you can also check
everything and here you can also see the
address changing on the mail
so we can check for jagadish Chari his
address and his name
right so it looks like it's working
perfectly now select OK and that's done
now we are in the final stage and in the
mailings option you can see the last two
options in that is the preview results
and finish so before merging and
finishing the mail merge we shouldn't go
through a quick preview to check if
everything is fine or not so here you
can see we have the address block this
is how the encoding looks like and if
you
replace the encoding with the actual
address in me this is how the actual
address and name looked like and you can
check all the letters you can just click
on the Arrow key here and you can check
all the recipients address and their
names
right so if you can find any errors you
can replace them and if not if
everything is fine then you can just
quickly press on the finish and merge
option when you finish merge option or
finish and merge option you get three
different
options that is edit individual
documents print documents and send all
these to the recipients now if you had
any queries or if you had any doubts
about or if you find any errors on the
emails then you can go to that
particular individual document and edit
it with the first option and in the
second option you can print all the
documents like if you want to send a
hard copy then you can print it
so you can see here all and select OK
and then you can you know kind of save
it as a PDF or you can send the location
of your printer and then just press ok
right you can just save them in the form
of PDF
or you can directly send the emails
right now I'm not connected to any
printer so I'm not going to print any
documents now let us try the last one
this should be interesting
now when you select the mail option
then it automatically selects the email
column from your Excel sheet remember we
had an email column from Excel sheet
right this particular column word
automatically selects that column from
Excel and you can just select OK and all
the mails will be sent to all these
imaginary mailing addresses
so that's how it's done now let's learn
about pivot charts and tables which is
one more very useful feature of Excel
and which allows you to work with your
data or perform data analysis now pivot
table is a summary of your data
it is used in cases where there are
numerous rows and columns in your data
set and it allows you to group your data
in several ways so that you can derive
meaningful information from it now the
visual representation of a pivot table
is termed as a pivot chart now how do we
do that so let's see an example now here
is some data here you see we have some
row labels which basically gives me some
category of items here it also tells me
the sum of sales and basically it gives
me per item what is the total sum of
sales which were made now how do I get
this here so for example if I would want
to delete this and I would be interested
in getting the
total sales under each category of items
now we know that we have
different data here and it's huge for
example on the row end if I just do a
control and right arrow it tells me
what's my right last column and if I
just do a control and down arrow it
tells me there are
9994 rows now I can use this and what I
can do is I can basically work on
insert and go to pivot table now this
basically tells you need to choose the
range now since I have chosen my first
row and First Column it basically has
selected the data and that's fine now do
you want the result in a new worksheet
I'll say existing worksheet and I can
choose a location now that basically
needs me to select a field might be we
can just select this field and that
should be good enough so for example if
I close this or if I say ok so
this is basically an indication that my
pivot table will be created now what are
the fields we are interested in so as
per the problem we need to find out what
the total sales for each category so
let's go in here and let's select the
field category now as soon as you do
that it shows that the rows
which are being selected are for this
column category and now we are
interested in getting the sales so we
would want the sales per category so
let's select this so you see some of
sales is selected now close this and
that's it that's that's your data so it
shows you row labels it tells you what
are the different categories
and it also gives you some of sales
which is per category now this is
one easy example where we have solved
the problem where we have tried to find
what were the total sales under each
category of items so for example let's
have another data set so again you can
just check how many rows we have and it
is basically the same
and if I look in columns it basically
shows me profit is the last column
and here we would want to find out which
category
so for example let me get rid this with
subcategory of items sold the maximum
under each category so we have some
categories here which says furniture and
it shows some sub categories and then it
shows me office supplies and then some
sub categories and same thing with
technology now we know how we got this
data but this is different than what we
were seeing here so here we were just
getting the categories what what we did
not have any breakdown of sub categories
within this particular category and here
you see there is a breakdown and then
basically you can also apply a filter
which basically says what is the data
you want and if you are interested in
finding out a particular value now how
do we do this so for example let me get
rid of this now we know how we can find
out the category of items but we would
want to find out which sub category of
items so all the maximum under each
category so here we are not looking at
sales but we are looking at the quantity
okay so what we can do is we can go to
the first row and First Column click on
insert click on pivot table data is
already selected let's choose existing
worksheet let's choose a location in our
worksheet where we would want to have
this so maybe I can select this
particular field and then just close
this so it says this is the existing
worksheet say okay and now you need to
select your columns so for example
if I would want the data for categories
so I can select this now I know that
within category these are the options
which we have and then there is a
subcategory so let's select that and if
you see here now we have the data which
will be filtered So based on your
category and subcategory and then we
will choose quantity so it automatically
understands that this is something on
which summation can be done so let's
select this and close on this now if you
see here we have got our items where we
can see
the subcategories within a particular
category now I can basically close this
and that just shows me high level
categories here so here I can again
select a particular
row and column I can go for
either a new pivot table so we could
basically select this the row is already
selected existing worksheet is what I
want so now I will select
this particular place
say okay now we do the same thing like
what we did earlier so we will select
category subcategory and quantity so the
data is already coming just select this
and now you already have all your data
but this is not what we want we want to
basically apply a filter to this now how
do we do that so we can go for
slicer so I can go for insert slicer and
then it tells what are the subcategories
which you are interested in so for
example if I go for something like
subcategory and say Okay so this tells
me what are the categories you are
interested in so for example we know
that furniture has Furnishings with the
highest value so I can select say
furnishings and then I was interested in
office supplies So within office supply
I can basically
search for
here
binder so I can just do a control and
select binder
and then I can also know for technology
I can select phones so I'll say control
and select phones and now if you see the
filter has been applied and we have
these sub categories which are selected
so we have our data here now we don't
need really this so I can just delete
this and I have my data which shows me
Furniture being the main category and
that has only Furnishings office supply
having binders and Technology having
phones and that basically is a filter
applied on the result of your pivot so
this is how we are seeing which
subcategory of items were sold
maximum for each category
so this is how you can easily use pivot
tables and you can do some analysis
let's look at some more examples
now
let's see if you have to answer this
question which says which were the top
three states for each region that made
the highest average profit now how do we
calculate that so for example this is
the data we have and as I've instructed
earlier you can select the first row and
First Column you can click on insert go
into pivot table and that basically
selects all your data we will choose the
result should be in this existing
worksheet so select this click here and
then basically let's select
this cell and I will say okay so now my
pivot table will be here so we are
interested in finding out top three
states within each region which have
made the highest
profit or which have made the highest
average profit so for that first we will
select region so when we select region
it shows
here region and within region you will
then select state So within every region
you have multiple States so that's what
we are selecting and then we are
interested in looking at the profit so
let's select profit and that
automatically shows up here so we can
now say close this so basically we have
all the data but we are looking at the
sum of profit but that's not what we
want we are looking for
top three states
from each region that made the highest
average profit now how do we change that
so here we have sum of profit so I can
do a right click and basically I can say
summarize values by average so now I'm
getting the average here and that
basically tells per region I have the
average profit but first is let's sort
this data so let's go into sort more
options and here I have average of
profit or for example as I said you can
select region say okay and now it is
basically having the
regions and then you have your state
value so again we can do a sorting here
and I can say
let's go for more sort options I'll say
descending the state values should be
based on average profit so let's say
okay and now if you see
in particular region we have the data
which has been
sorted wherein you have the highest
average profit on the top now what we
can also do is we can basically
then go for filtering we can say top 10
but I am not interested in top 10 so I
could reduce this to top three
and this is the items average of profit
say okay and now you see per region you
have the data which is
showing me top three states what are the
average and then you are also looking at
the subtotal so which basically says
average profit for your West now if you
would want to arrange this
your west and south and east and Central
in a particular alphabetical order if
you would want to sort it you can always
do a sorting and you can choose sort Z
to A if that's what you would want to do
or you can go for sorting more sort
options and you want to
sort the region which is as of now
based on descending z2a let's make it
ascending say okay and now you see the
data has been filtered so it says per
region now you can always select this
and you can say what is this so this is
basically your average of profit now we
are looking at
each region and the states the top three
states as we wanted within the region
and what is the average now we have one
more question what is the percentage
contribution of each sub-category of
products under each category to the
total sales so we know there are
different products there are different
categories and all the categories
contribute to the total sales so we
would want to find out what is the
percentage contribution of each
subcategory
of products under each category so we
not only want the category percentage
but we would also want what is the
contribution of each subcategory
to
each category to the total sales how do
we do that so for that we need to again
just place
our cursor here or select the first row
in First Column click on your insert
click on your pivot table and now the
data is already selected existing
worksheet place your cursor here and
then let's select this cell say okay
now your pivot table fields are here so
we are interested in category
so let's select category and then within
a category we will have subcategories
and we are interested in the sales data
wherein it is already going to give us
the sum of sales but we would want this
in the form of percentage rather than
just the sump now we can click here
value field settings and it says if you
would want to summarize this it says
show value as and what are the values
you would want so you can straight away
go ahead here and say percentage of
grand total so we could do that because
we know
we will get a sum of sales and grand
total now I could basically say
percentage of grand total say okay and
then just close this
so once you have closed this you see
already the data is in
percentage so now we have our data with
subcategories but we also want the data
to be sorted might be in a descending
order which tells which subcategory is
contributing more than others we can
select how many subcategories we are
interested in so we can basically select
one of the subcategory cells right click
now you have option filter and you have
sorting so we can say more sort options
now here I will say descending and you
want the descending to be sum of sales
which is already showing as percentage
click on OK and now you see for each
category
it shows the percentage contribution
towards the sales it shows the sub
categories contribution
to a particular category and also to
total sales so technically speaking if
you look at all these values which are
subcategories and if you would total
them that would be your total grand
total so this is how we can solve a
simple problem like this what is the
percentage contribution of each
subcategory of products under each
category to the total sales
the next question is which customer made
the lowest profit in the home office
segment in each state now here we know
that we are looking for home office
segment we are looking for customer
which made the lowest profit we are also
looking for the state as the main
criteria so in each state we would look
for home office segment and within that
we would look for customer which has
made the lowest profit that means
the lowest value
of the profit so how do we do this so
let's say let's get into selecting our
row and column we will go into insert
I'll say pivot table I'll say existing
worksheet and let me get my result here
so let's say okay now that gives me the
PO table so the first thing is we are
looking at per state
and
I would be interested in
home office segment or I could first
start with segment now here we have
segment and in segment I can basically
select home office so I can just uncheck
and select home office only
and now I can select
state so that will be my
subcategory within segment and then
within State we would want to find out
the customer so let's get the customer
name
and we are interested in finding out the
lowest profit so let's select profit and
here we have sum of profits so the
fields are selected close this and now
you have your data
which basically shows me the names of
customers which made the profit but it's
it's not sorted so we can sort this and
we have state entries also so that's
fine so what I can do is here I can
basically say sorting go to more sort
options I can say I want to do it
descending or I want to do an ascending
and ascending based on sum of profit so
let's do that now you see the top most
value is the lowest value per state
within home office segment now what we
also want is we just want one value per
state so how do we do that so we can
just go for filtering go for top 10
values I am interested in bottom value
and in that also I am looking for only
the
lowest value so let's select one
say okay and now you see we have data
for home office segment
per state
customer who has made the lowest profit
so we have easily answered this question
using our pivot table now say for
example we have a question which says
find the sales made in each quarter of
2016 for all the regions
so the data has to be divided quarterly
and use order here as a slicer we can do
that by selecting what data we would
want to slice and then we would want to
create a pivot chart also so for example
how do we do that so for example I will
get rid of this
I will get rid of
this my Pivot chart which we can
recreate so find the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions so
this is what we want now how do we do
this so for example let's select this we
will do a insert pivot table we will
basically say existing worksheet and
then I can select this particular cell
I'll say okay and now I am interested in
data quarterly so first let's select
are filled here so we should basically
have
if all our fields are selected say for
example if I say order date
now
you see we have quarters and years which
are selected now we could be selecting
these fields which says
quarters years and if I would want data
to be filtered based on years I could do
that or I could get rid of here so I
have quarters I have ordered date
so
that's being already selected now what
else we need we need to find out
for every region so let's select the
region and we can also add region as a
column here so that will basically give
me all the regions as different columns
and then finally we want the sales so
let's select this
and now let's look what we have so if
you see here
we have our data which is
for each quarter
it gives me the total data but what we
would be interested in is not looking at
the total data but we are only
interested in quarter of
2016. now how do we do that so what we
do here is we have row labels so let's
click on this so we have date filters
and then in date filters we can go for
between and then we will say
2016 and the value has to be 1 and then
let's select this and let's change this
to 2016.
and this is 12th month
and then we can say 31
so we are saying the date has to be
2016.
and it basically says not a valid date
so let's select
let's select a particular date and see
so the month has to be here
so let's see in this and let's make it
date and say okay and now we have our
data which is
foreign
2016. so for example I could basically
select this and here I could be looking
at
what are the filters we have so it says
clear filter from order data so we have
applied the filter on order date and
these are your date filters which is
basically
date 16 or this is wrong so this one has
to be changed to 2016. so select this
and now we have our data for 2016.
so we have found the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions the
grand total
for a particular quarter if we are
looking at the value or for individual
months in a particular quarter and we
have sliced the data now we could have
also introduced a slicer by
selecting
which field we would want to implement
so for example if I would select a
particular field and then I could click
on slicer I could choose I would want to
slice the date based on order date and
then could have done it or we have just
given the
date for 2016. now we just need to plot
a graph for this and that's very easy so
you just need to select the complete
pivot data and here you have the chart
options so let's go for line chart and
that basically shows me the line chart
so we can select this we can just drag
and drop it here and then we can
basically check if that is showing us
the data so if you see here this is line
chart where it has divided the regions
in different colors so we have all the
regions we could filter out in pivot
chart a particular region we have the
quarterly
time here in order data the filter is
applied it says it is
2016. in quarters it tells me it is 16.
so we have our data we have created a
pivot chart and basically we have sliced
the data for 2016.
let's answer one more question and
that's finding the profit made in each
year for all the categories of products
in east and west regions only and then
we would want to create a histogram for
the same pivot table so histogram
usually gives us the frequencies so
let's look at how do we calculate the
profit made in each year for all the
categories so what I can do is I can
basically
select my row ID here and now I'll do a
pivot table so the data is already
selected I'll choose existing worksheet
let's select this particular cell say
okay now what are we interested in now
if you look at the fields we don't see
any years or quarters and so on so for
example here I can just choose order
date
and then basically
I can choose say for example years or
quarters the data which is coming out
from my order date so here I will just
select years
now
then I have my order date so
we are interested in the Years orders
and
we are interested in
let's look at our column or the question
what we had here
so we have years
find the profit made in each year so
let's select profit so that basically
says sum of profit but then I'm on also
interested in
for all the categories of products so
what I can do is here I have my field
which is category and that I'll add to
the columns so that shows me what are
the different categories
and this looks fine now I'm also
interested in east and west regions so
that is basically in the region so
either we could add a slicer or we could
do a filtering here by adding the
filters so first is I'll click on region
and here it says select all I'm only
interested in east and west so let's
select this
take this put it here
let's say okay and now we have the data
which has been filtered based on the
region so here we have region so you can
always look at the filter it is east and
west and we have our year data per year
we have different categories you can
always look at what are these column
labels so this is my different
categories and this is the profit per
category
and then you have your grand total so we
have already our data now let's say
close this so we have our data for all
these years different categories the
profits made per year and if I would
want I could go into an year and I could
look into different months so that also
is showing up and now we would want to
basically plot a histogram with this
data so I can just place my cursor here
I can select this and then I can go into
insert and here I have different options
so we can go for bar chart we can go for
insert hierarchy chart
we can go into waterfall funnel stock
surface or radar chart so there are
different options what you have here and
we will go for a simple histogram which
is two dimensional let's select this and
here you see you can obviously select
different regions
you have your ears which shows up you
have your order date
and then you have your categories which
can be chosen for your histogram or for
your bar chart and that basically is how
you use your pivot table you use some
calculations and then you can plot your
needed graph to visualize the data and
understand it in a better way let's look
at an example of one more useful
function in Excel and that is vlookup
now vlookup is used to see if a value
exists in a range of values and we can
create a range of values which is
nothing but a block of cells which has a
name and can be referenced so mainly to
use vlookup we need to create a named
range and that can be referenced
anywhere in the workbook or the other
option is you can always drag and select
the range of data in which you would
want to search something now there is
also a of other functions such as Edge
lookup which pretty much does the same
thing however it does it horizontally
that is left to right instead of
vertically there are other functions
like lookup and X lookup and so on so
when we talk about vlookup let's see how
we do that so for example this is the
range of or this is the data which has
been given to you and here is the
question find the employee name with
employee ID 107. now assume that you
might have huge amount of data and you
may want to search something so how do
we do it now here I have created some
column and then some basic formatting I
have given it as an employee ID I've
given the employee name now what I can
do is I can create a range of data now
how do I do that or a named range so
what you can do is you can select the
data and then you can do it right click
now here you have something like get
data from table range so you can do that
you can define a name so you can click
on this and here you can give a name to
the range what you would want to call it
so for example let's say our search now
that's the named range I'm creating and
just say Okay so the scope is workbook
and I have created a named range which
you can see here so it shows for search
our search so you have created a named
range now how do we do a vlookup here so
for that we can use a formula so for
example I would want to search for
employee name where employee ID is
whatever you would want to search for so
employee ID we can give here one zero
seven now that's what we would want to
search the employee name for and
employee name is what we are interested
now what we can do is we can use the
function option here I can do a insert
function and that shows me different
functions which are here now vlookup is
showing up because I have recently
searched for it or you can basically
just type in here look and you can do a
go so that shows you all the lookup
options what you have like look up Edge
lookup match vlookup and so on so we
would be interested in vlookup so let's
select that and click on ok now that
basically opens up this function of
arguments and it shows what does this
function do so it says looks for a value
in the leftmost column of a table and
then returns a value in the same Row
from a column you specify by default the
table must be sorted in an ascending
order now you can basically say this is
what you would want to search for what
is the lookup value if you place your
cursor here it says what is the table
array that is nothing but the range
which we can use our named range here we
have the the column index number which
basically tells me what is the column
number in the range which we want so
what is the value we want from which
column and then basically you have range
lookup which basically is the fourth
option and range lookup is nothing but
it can have two values so true or false
so true basically means closest match
and then false should be an exact match
so let's do that so for lookup value we
would want to give a particular value
which is nothing but
we would be interested in say employee
name so I can basically
search for a value based on the lookup
value now how do we do it so we are
saying we would want to search for
employee ID which is one zero seven so
what I can do is I can select this
cell here which tells that this is the
value
or employee ID for which I would want to
search the employee name I could
actually select the cell here which is H
so that whatever value you feed in here
you can search for that value so maybe
we can select this one which is H6 and
whatever value we key in here we will be
searching for employee name for that
employee ID now table array is we would
want to give a range so what we can do
is we can give our range so for example
we had selected something like our
search
and if you see here that already selects
or shows me employee ID employee name
email address so it gives me the range
now column index number so which
column are we interested in that means
what is the value we are searching for
so we are searching for employee name
which is the second column so I can just
say 2 and that basically is the column
number and then you have to give a range
lookup which is a logical value so
either you give an exact match or you
can basically give a closest match so we
can say for example do a 0 which
basically means false or you can say 1
which is true so let's go for zero now
that's our formula so it says vlookup
you will search for the value as per at
6 in the range and then you are looking
for employee name which is column number
two and then true or false so let's
click on okay and that basically gives
me the value which is parallel
bunch
so here I'm searching for employee name
and you can basically drag this for
other columns and you can do that so if
it finds employee
ID here now say for example if we had an
employee ID somebody enters an employee
ID which is not in the range for example
let's try 121 and then you see this is
basically an error right because it does
not have any employee ID with 121 now
how do I take care of this so there is a
Formula which is called if error and
that can be used to take care of this so
if the value is not found then it will
show whatever I would want to
show here so what I can do is I can
still select this and what I can do is I
can search in function say for example
this is the function we are looking at
but what we can do is
we can test it here so for example if I
look in function and if I search for
error and so
go so there are lots of functions here
and this is the function we are
interested in if error so if I say okay
now this takes the value and what is the
value if error so for Value what I can
do is basically I can select
the value from here which is nothing but
our vlookup formula and value if error
so for example I will basically say for
example not found so we can try this and
we can say okay now here it says not
found so whenever it is n a it is not
found now
if we look at the formula here it says
if error it takes the value of H7 which
is nothing but our vlookup and then it
is
showing us the value which we have
entered so for example if I would say 1
0 7 like earlier and then hit on enter
so it says panel of cruise and it shows
us the value
right and if we enter something else
then basically
here it shows n a and it shows not found
but what we want to do is we want to
merge these two so what I can do is I
can get rid of
or I can basically take this one
now what I would want is I want this
formula to be here so what I can do is I
can say if error and then basically
given your vlookup option or function
here and then say for example not found
here not found now that basically will
take care of any kind of error if the
value is not found so when we say 121 it
basically says not found but if I say
107 which is found then it shows me the
value so we are using vlookup but when
then we are also using IF error which
will take care of our error message or
basically the not applicable pound not
applicable replaced with whatever value
we key in similarly we can do the same
thing here so we have the find the job
title so we are interested in finding
about the job title once the employee
name is given now employee name can
basically have a value from the cell or
whatever value you would want to key in
how do we do it so we basically start
with are we lookup so that's the
function we are interested in
so you can just do a double click now
you are interested in finding out the
value whichever is given here so that's
the lookup value and then you are
interested in finding out the job title
from the range so I will still give our
range which basically
also shows for example let's do a
double click here and that basically
selects the range and now I am
interested in finding out the job title
so that's column number four
and then I can just give 0 which is for
false so now we have given our vlookup
but that shows not applicable because we
have not given any employee name so we
can key in the value here which says
Fred Stone and now if we are basically
giving the value so Fred Stone now we
will have to search if there is any job
title which is Fred Stone so here is the
value so that should be showing up let's
check what has gone wrong so we are
giving our range we are interested in
finding out the value but what the
mistake what we did here was that when
we want to search for a value say for
example let's take this vlookup and
let's replace this value of H to L with
the value here so Fred Stone and then
basically we will give our range we will
save which is the column we are
interested in and then give true or
false so we can also basically take care
of this error message so for example
let's take this complete formula from
here and just
just copy this formula
and now we can put in here the formula
but then this is where we were searching
for H6 which was employee ID now that's
not what we are interested in we are
interested in finding out the value so
let's take this one and replace this
with the value given here
and then I give my range I say which is
the column I'm interested in so I'm
interested in looking for job title and
then let's search so it basically tells
me not found so let's check this
now the error which we were facing was
because when we talk about your vlookup
let's look at the formula again and here
say for example I go for function and
then I select vlookup and say for
example I say okay now just look at the
description here looks for a value in
the left most column of a table now
earlier the range which we had selected
had the leftmost column as employee ID
and that's why it was giving an error so
how do we fix that so for example let's
basically
remove this function from here now what
we want to do is we would want to search
for the stock broker now if you see here
I have given a range which is b 1 to D21
so we would want the value for what we
would want to search say employee name
that should be the leftmost column so
so that's how
we have our function so let's do that so
say for example the name is given here
so we want a range so either we can
create a range like earlier by selecting
say for example this data now am I
interested in salary no I am interested
in job title right so I can basically
just three columns and then I can define
a name so I can say our
search to and let's give a named range
and that's only because we would want to
easily reference or use that named
search or name range now here we would
want to use vlookup but we would also do
an if error
now within that we can say we look up
and then you need to
select what is the value what your
function takes so basically this is my
function we will say if the value is not
found then we will give this so you can
create an external structure and then
within your vlookup we will say the
leftmost column which we are interested
in so that's your employee name
so in employee name we have the value so
either I can directly select the value
here in the column b or I will give the
value whichever is fed in here the
employee name
then I need to give a range so let's
select our range so that's your our
search too and then you need to select
the column number
so we are interested in finding out the
job title so that's the third column so
let's say three and then just give it 0
and then hit on enter so it says not
found because you have not given any
employee name now let's
try to find the job title of Fred Stone
so I can just select or I can say equal
and then I can just given a value and
that basically shows me the job title so
this is how you use vlookup we have also
used if error which basically takes care
of error message if the value is not
found so for example we can test this
here we have Fred Stone
so for example if I just empty this and
I point it to something which does not
exist so that shows me not found or if
you just select this and then key in a
value it shows you this might be we can
just type in so if I say Fred then
basically it says not found because we
are looking for exact match now if we
had changed this to the closest match
something like this then it would have
tried to find something but then we
don't have anything which is just with
this so there are different ways of
doing it so what we can do is we can
always go for the exact match
and that's basically the value
and here we can basically key in any
value for example I would be interested
in finding out
this one and let's give this so you can
search in this way so you can also have
statements which can be searching one
related to other now here the question
was to find the job title of Fred Stone
so let's type in Fred Stone and that
basically shows me the job title which
we are interested in so let's search for
job title let's go for exact match and
then search so it is stock broker so if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now that we have looked at vlookup it
would be interesting
how horizontal lookup
works in the on the same lines but here
instead of vertically searching through
the columns the range is more of
horizontally defined so we search in
rows rather than in columns so for
example this is the data which has been
given to you and you have various
columns so you have employee ID you have
your employee name you have employee
email address
you basically have the job title of
different employees and then basically
you have the salary so this is the data
which has been given to you and you are
asked to search or you are interested in
finding out say the salary based on
employee name or job title based on
employee ID so what we need to do is we
need to define the range here now range
can depend on what you are searching for
so for example when I'm searching
employee name and salary so I am
interested in these four rows when I am
saying employee ID and job title then
might be this is the range and I don't
need salary so I can create a named
range if we are interested in so that we
can easily search for it or we can
straight away give the the first cell
value which is basically A1 here and
then the last value here which is G and
then you can give 5. so you can do that
or you can create a named range
whichever way you would want to do it so
for example we would want to create a
named range for our first question which
is find the salary of Eden Cornell using
H lookup so we are interested in this so
let's select
these four rows all the way for your
columns now like we did earlier we can
just Define a name might be we can call
it our search 3 and we can just give
okay so that's the named range which we
have created
now what we would want is we want to
search for the salary based on employee
name so here we can insert our function
so let's look up and let's search for
look and just click on go so here you
have hlookup and basically that's the
function I'm interested in say Okay so
this says what is the lookup value which
you are interested in so we are
interested in finding out the value
based on the employee name so for
example let's select this cell that
gives us more dynamism and you can add
in any name and you can search for the
salary
or you can basically give the employee
name exactly from the employee name
value here which is D 2. so we can give
Eden kernel from here so let's select
this now table array so we need to give
our range so let's say our search three
then you need to give the row index
number now this is different than
vlookup in vlookup you have column index
number and here you have row index
number so what are you interested in
searching for so we are interested in
searching for salary now in our range
that is basically the fourth row
remember we created a range from
employee name to salary so let's give
the row index number which is 4 and the
range lookup will say 0 which is
basically exact match and that completes
our formula so click on OK and that
basically gives me the salary for Eden
kernel now that's basically because we
have fed in the value here
and that is basically giving me this so
I can again do if error if I would be
interested in to basically take care of
error message if the value is not found
for that you can look into the previous
example which is vlookup now similarly
we are interested in finding out the job
title for employee ID
105 how do we do that so we need to use
Edge lookup well we could have done with
vlookup but here the data is more
arranged in the form of rows so how do
we do that so we can again use Edge
lookup but and we can give a range or
named range or let's for this time let's
basically key in our range manually so
we can do that so let's go for H lookup
now what do we want to search for so we
will say this is the value then we need
to give a range now as I said if you
would want to give a change manually so
for example I'll say a and then I'll say
a 1.
colon and then I'm interested in G and
then the row will be 4 so salary row is
not what we are we are not interested in
so let's say G and then we can give 4 so
that basically gives me the range right
instead of having a named range so we
can do that and then we need to give the
row index number so we are interested in
finding out the job title which is
basically in our range the fourth row
and then give 0 for true or false so if
you see here it tells if it is 1 it is
approximate match false is an exact
match and we can close this bracket that
completes our formula it takes the value
which is given in employee ID and then
it will try to search for the job title
so that basically shows wherever the
employee ID is 105 the job title is
fabricated again you can use if error
wherein your if error can then be
working on hlookup and can take care of
error so that if an employee ID is keyed
in for which there is no matching value
then it will not show you a not
applicable error in instead of that it
will replace with the word whatever you
have specified so in this way you can
easily use Edge lookup to search from
the range of data which is horizontally
arranged and in the previous example we
were seeing how you use vlookup when the
data is arranged vertically
so we have looked at the vlookup and
Edge lookup and what we have seen is
vlookup has a limitation in one way that
we need to basically give a range where
the leftmost column is the one which is
used now instead of that we might be
interested in searching in specific
columns and not all the columns well
that can also affect the time taken to
search for the data
wherein we can select particular columns
or particular ranges rather than
selecting all the data which has to be
searched for so for example we have this
question find the salary of Hank
Saunders now that's the employee name
which we have here and we would want to
find out the salary so what are the
columns we are interested in so one is
your employee name and one is your
salary and these are the only two
columns which we are interested in so
instead of using vlookup now like I've
shown earlier you can create a named
range for these two columns and you can
use that or we can manually give the
range here so let's go for lookup
function here and lookup function will
basically help us in searching what we
are interested in so we are interested
in finding out the employee name
and we are interested in finding out the
salary based on the employee name so how
do we do that so here in lookup I can
first give the value which is here
employee name now whatever
employee name is keyed in here we will
be searching for salary of that employee
now lookup function needs a lookup value
so we are searching
based on employee name then it says
lookup Vector so we will basically then
say what is going to be our lookup
Vector so here we need to give a range
so what are we interested in we are
interested in finding out the salary
based on employee name so first goes our
range
based on which we need to search so
that's your employee name so let's for
example select this one so that's our
range B1 to B21 so that will basically
have the employee name in which we will
be searching for and then we are
interested in searching out the the
result Vector that is basically the
column from which we want the value
that's our salary column so let's select
this and that completes our lookup
function so now if you hit on enter it
shows that for this employee where the
name is hunk Saunders the salary is 5400
now you can test it by basically giving
some other name so for example if I
replace this with say Fred Stone
and that basically shows me the value
for Fred Stone we can replace it to the
question which we have that is Hank
Saunders and that shows me the salary so
that's a simple example of Lookup which
allows you to search by selecting a
range of columns rather than having the
leftmost column which has to be
referenced similarly we have one more
question find the employee ID of this
particular email ID so we need to again
use our lookup function so we'll say
look up now what are we interested in we
will search based on this email address
so I will select this then I need to
give that based on email address we are
searching the employee ID so email
addresses in this column so let's select
this range and then we are interested in
employee ID so then goes our result
Vector so select this column and that
basically completes your formula so
close this bracket and hit on enter so
that base basically shows me the
employee ID for an employee with this
email address so this is how you use
lookup now as I've explained earlier you
can be using the if error and you can
basically see how
your index match can be used now here is
an example of if error so basically this
shows how if error helps so say for
example as I showed in your employee
James Bond if the value is not present
display not found then what are we doing
we are basically nesting our vlookup
inside if error with a not found option
which basically says if the value given
in the cell Edge is not found then
basically
it will
display not found so here you also
notice that the range which has been
given has been selected that is B1 to
c21 now we could have used a named range
which basically helps us in searching
for multiple functions we are searching
for 2 that is the column number 2 here
that is employee name so check for
employee James Bond if the value is not
present or no so we are basically just
searching for employee name here and
then give your 0 or 1. so that's
basically usage of your if error which I
have shown earlier and the same thing
can be applied for your Edge lookup also
now suppose you have been given some
additional questions for example you
know instead of using your vlookup or
hlookup or lookup examples what we have
seen say for example you are asked to
find the salary of Peter Daniels now we
already know how to find that using
vlookup right so for example we want to
find out the salary for this employee
name which is Peter Daniels I can use a
vlookup however sometimes we may also
want to use a index match an index match
is also one useful function to do that
so we can basically search based on that
so we have to define the range of data
we have to then say what do we want to
match so that's basically an employee
name and then we are interested in
finding out
say for example based on the range of
employees you would want to find out
the value of salary so we are then
giving a range and doing it how do we do
that so for example here I can use a
function which is called index and if
you see here it says returns a value or
reference of the cell
at the intersection of a particular row
and column in a given range so this is
where index function can be useful now
we can start with this function it says
it needs an array that's nothing but a
range so we can basically select all our
data so I can say A1 all the way to E21
so that basically is my range now I
would want to find the salary of this
employee name which is Peter Daniels so
I can use internally here
basically you need to give a row number
so what we can do is we can do a match
so we can use an internal function match
now we need to basically give it
correctly so we need to say match now
how does this match function work so we
need to basically match for a value so
for example we will select whatever
employee name is given here so that's
Peter Daniels now that's basically what
we would want to match
now where do we want to match this so we
want to match in the column B which has
employee
names so we can give a range which is B1
to B 21 so that's basically within the
employee names we are looking for a
match which is given here that's in H6
and we want to do a match so we want to
do a exact match so let's do a comma 0
and then we are interested in finding
out the salary
based on this match and salary is in our
fifth column so let's basically give the
column number here and then just close
this bracket
so that basically completes your
function and just hit on enter so that
shows me the salary of Peter Daniels
right so this is an easy way when you
can use the index function remember
first you give the range
and then you need to give your matching
conditions So when you say match I would
take the value whatever is given in this
cell I will search in the range of
values which is employee names I will
find an exact match and what I am
interested in is finding the salary for
Peter Daniels now similarly say for
example you have been given a question
find the employee ID with salary 10 000.
so you want to find out the employee ID
wherever the salary is ten thousand so
we are obviously looking for an exact
match now how do we do that so we can
start with our index function and within
index function we need to give a range
so for example I am interested in
finding out say for example our range
which is a 1
two e 21 so that's what I'm interested
in or you are actually interested in
searching based on
save your salary so you are interested
in searching the employee ID so maybe if
I just do a 821 let's see what happens
here now then I can just do a match
so match will be now done based on the
value which is here H 13 so I will do a
match for this one now I need to give a
range
so let's basically give a range which
will be we are interested in
searching employee ID based on the
salary column so that's your e column so
I will say E1 to E21 that's what I'm
interested in searching
finding a match for this salary we want
an exact match so first let's close this
one now
that's fine I mean we are interested in
finding out the employee ID based on the
match which is within this range
and then what we would want to do is we
would want to basically find the
employee ID employee ID is in my column
A so what I can do is I can additionally
give a match here and then I can say I'm
interested in the finding out the value
for employee ID
and that basically needs a range so the
range here will be just the
the column headings so we will give A1
all the way to E1 so that's the range in
which we would want to search and we
would want to find a match for employee
ID we want an exact match so let's close
this one and that basically closes my
match and we need to close our index
function so now that shows me employee
ID where the salary is 10 000. so this
is how you can do your index matches
where you can give a range then you can
say what you need to match
within which particular column whether
it is an exact match or approximate
match and then the column from where you
are interested in finding out the value
so same thing we did here we basically
gave a complete range and if you closely
see we were only interested in finding
out the employee ID so here I give a
range A1 to a21 which is basically this
particular column so that's where we are
interested in finding out match
basically will give your lookup value so
that's h13 then we gave a range which is
salary that's what we are interested in
and then we said when we are doing a
match we are only interested in finding
out the employee ID
which is in a range of column names and
then doing an exact match so this is how
you can use index match instead of
lookup which can also give you uh some
exceptions in searching for specific
columns or specific rows now if error we
have already discussed where you Nest
your vlookup or hlookup inside it
so this is how you can use your lookup
functions Edge lookup vlookup lookup or
index match to search for data some
function like this which shows up
xln.xlookup and then you're trying to
search for something so don't be
surprised with that so xln is basically
a prefix added to functions that don't
exist in the version of excel you are
using you have Excel 2013 and say your
friend has a new version of excel say
Office 365 or Excel 2016 and basically
he uses a new cool function and sends
the file to you so that's where you will
have this excellent prefix as I'm
showing up here so for example what is
the job title of Xavier power is what
you would want to search and here the
function which shows up Excel and X
lookup and then you are searching so
this is is basically something which is
the function now if I just select what
it has selected here and if I hit on
enter it shows that this does not work
in my Excel here and that's because of
the version but what I can do is I can
fix this by removing this
details here and that basically shows
lookup we are searching for job title
based on employee name which is in this
field H6 and then we need to give a
range so we need to give a range of
names employee name and then basically
the job title range which is basically
the job title so now if I just hit on
enter it gives me the value so it's as
simple as that similarly here what is
the employee ID of the person with this
email we have already looked at the
lookup function so if it shows your xln
X lookup all you need to do is remove
this and then keep the lookup function
searching for the value based on the
range of values and then searching for a
value within a range of values so just
hit on enter and that gives you the
value and same thing goes for this job
title so what is the job title and
salary of employee name so we have this
function now what I can do is
here I am interested in finding out the
value for this particular function how
do I fix this I can basically select
this and then just do a lookup based on
the values and it basically says you
can't change part of an array so we can
fix this now what we need to do is we
need to basically search based on this
particular value so we will basically
say I want to do a lookup now lookup
should be based on employee name
whatever name is given here then you
need to find the job title and salary so
for job title I want to find based on
employee name so I will give a range
and then basically I will say I'm
interested in finding out the job title
so I will give a different range
and then basically close this so that
basically shows now this is basically
because of the function which we have
here so basically to fix this what we
will have to do is we will have to
delete all the columns here which were
selected such as employee name job title
and salary because that was giving you
an error you cannot delete a part of an
array now what we want to do is we want
to find the job title and salary based
on the employee name so we can do that
using lookup as we have done earlier so
we will use a lookup function now what
we are interested in finding out is the
job title based on employee name so we
can select this cell which does not have
any value
then we need to basically say from which
range or based on what you want to
search so we want to search based on
employee name
and we want to find out the job title so
we can basically give a range of values
and then we will be interested in
finding out the job title so let's
select the job title range and that
basically completes our lookup so let's
close this and hit on enter now it says
obviously error because this does not
have any value we will fix that by
giving in a value here same thing we can
do for salary so for example I can just
drag and drop it here and in this one
instead of
basically having a range which is your
we will be interested in finding out the
salary so
let's see what is the range we give so
the range should be employee name
so we will basically select employee
name as the range
and then we are interested in finding
out the salary so we will select this
particular range and what we are
interested in finding out is basically
employee name or we are interested in
finding out based on employee name so
let's select
this particular column and then hit on
enter so both of these are any values
now just feed in an employee name so we
will say for example Eduardo and that
basically gives me the job title and
salary so that's how you can fix your
Excel FN error so same thing goes here
so it shows you xln is what you would
want to search might be if you don't
find something you would want to
pushing name not found so first is we
will have to fix this part so we will
have to remove this because that's not
supported in my Excel and then I have
lookup I'm searching based on h24 which
is basically employee ID you are giving
a range which is A2 to 821 because we
would want to find name not found
for a particular employee ID so I am
giving a range which is A2 to a21 I am
trying to search for the name which is
from B2 to B21 and then I am giving name
not found so say for example we can do
this lookup but then with lookup you
don't have this direct option what we
can do is we can use if error
if error and then basically try to
search so that gives your lookup value
and then you will have to close this one
and then again if it gives you some
error like this we can obviously go for
vlookup and fix this so here we are
searching for a particular range and
then let's search for this value
and basically to fix this what I did was
I just use a vlookup so we know that
employee ID 121 does not exist so I'm
just using IF error I'm doing a vlookup
where I'm searching for the value given
in h 19 and then I am saying that I
would want to search from a range which
is basically B1 to c21 that is in
employee name and say email address for
example and we would want to basically
search for name not found so we can
instead of giving B21 or B1 to c21 we
can restrict it to just B1 to B21 we are
searching in column two we are searching
for exact value and if it does not fine
then it says name not found and that's
how we do it so we can always replace
and fix this Excel FN errors if
you are using uh some spreadsheet which
was or Excel which was sent by
um someone else who is using a different
version let's quickly see some more
examples of doing data analysis using
Excel and for that we can use some
inbuilt add-ins which can be added to
our Excel sheet so for example if you
would want to do a descriptive analytics
or descriptive analysis on your data say
for example getting your descriptive
statistics such as your mean median mode
and so on so we can do that and we can
use Excel for it so for example you can
if you are given some data say I have
temperature price of ice cream units
sold and I would want to have
descriptive statistics on this what I
can do is I can click on file and here
in file you can click on options and
within options click on add-ins now
within add-ins you have Excel add-ins
which is selected here so click on say
go for example and that shows what
add-ins are available and you can choose
which ones are you interested in so for
example I have chosen analysis tool pack
and solver add in and click on ok now
that basically should add more options
to your Excel so if you click on data so
here you see data analysis and solver
and this is what we would want to use to
get our descriptive statistics for these
three columns so for example let's say
temperature
or you can even give the names later
once you get your descriptive statistics
so for example let's go for data
analysis and here it says what are you
interested in there is a two factor with
replication you have correlation
covariance descriptive statistics you
have histograms so let's click on
descriptive statistics click on ok now
this one basically asks your input range
so while your cursor is blinking here
also it is said grouped by so let's give
it a range so for example I will say say
temperature
now if I do this and I have selected The
Heading just look at that and now you
need an output range so let's just
select this and then you can have your
cursor blinking here let's select say
Fields here and this is where I would
want the output now it also said what
options do you want so it has output
range we can then select summary
statistics confidence level so I will
say summary statistics is what I am
interested in say okay and this says
input input range contains non-numeric
data now why is that because we chose
temperature The Heading also so click on
OK and here we will alter the range so
this one is our range should be only
the values numeric values on which we
would want the descriptive statistics we
have output range already selected we
have summary statistics and now you can
click on OK
and that basically gives your
descriptive statistics for temperature
so here I could basically
given a value for this so I can say
temperature and that's my descriptive
statistics for temperature might be I
can just do some formatting and
that's it so that gives me descriptive
statistics for the values here now
similarly we can do it for price of ice
cream so what we need is we need to
basically go for data
data analysis descriptive statistics say
okay now you need to give a range so
here I will change my range to these
values output range is already selected
now we are interested in summary
statistics click on OK and this says
output range will overwrite existing
data press ok to overwrite data in range
I will say cancel no that's not what we
want to do we need to give a new Range
so let's select our new Range which is
here and now click on OK so now we get
the values which is for your price of
ice cream so again we can basically
select this and say price of ice cream
and we got our descriptive statistics
for price of ice cream and like we did
earlier I can select this I can
basically do a merge and center and that
gives me descriptive statistics for
price of ice cream so we could also
basically change this now I can go into
data and I can go into Data analysis
descriptive statistics so we know that
we had selected this B2 to B8 and this
one which is H6 to h19 we would want to
shift it might be two columns up so
maybe I can just say H5 and I can
manually change it to a 17 and let's say
okay
and we will basically get this and I can
get rid of this so I can have it in the
same range so similarly so this one will
have to be renamed and I can basically
say price of ice cream
and that's basically my descriptive
statistics for my price of ice cream
and similarly we can do it for the third
column which is units sold
so we would want to have this now let's
see we can click on data we can click on
data analysis descriptive statistics so
we need to give the range correctly so
this time our range changes to units
sold
now we can also say labels in first row
okay if we were selecting The Heading so
let's do it in this way so in my range
in my range let me empty this I can
basically select this which we know has
non-numeric data in the first row say
for example I'll say labels in first row
I am interested in summary statistics
and this range will now have to be
changed from H to basically something
like J so let's say J and let's select
these values so that should take care of
things and now you see you have your
unit sold you did not have to manually
rename it
and you have basically got the
descriptive statistic so this is how you
can simply perform analysis using data
analysis here you can basically get your
descriptive statistics for your columns
and then you can do whatever needed
formatting you need to basically make
your data look
in a
good way now let's look at one more
example of data analysis where we may
want to look at the frequency of values
or frequency of values occurring in a
range of values so for example if you
have been given temperatures you have
been given some pins where you would
want to identify how many values fall
into the range of 0 to 20 20 to 30 30 to
40 40 to 50 and the easiest way to do
that would be creating histogram now
histogram is usually used for data
analysis where you would want to look at
different variables or say features for
example temperature is one such feature
might be there might be one more
variable or feature such as sale of ice
cream and you would want to see if the
increase or decrease in temperature
affects the increase or decrease in
sale of ice cream might be a sale of ice
cream is a is a response based on
temperature so it depends so sometimes
you may want to find the relationship
between two variables whether they are
positively or negatively related or you
would want to do different kind of
analysis and in certain cases we may
want to First do analysis on one single
variable look at the frequency of values
might we also look at the defects and
for which we can use something like
parrot or chart so we can go for
histogram and that basically gives us
the frequency of values now how do we do
that so we have already added the
add-in which is data analysis earlier so
we can just use the same thing again
here we would want to create a histogram
so let's say okay now I have already
selected input range so if you see here
my input range is temperature which is
also with the headings and I have bin
range which is basically the range of
values so for example I can select this
and that's my bin range I am selecting
or the option labels because I'm using
the first row which has the heading such
as temperature and pins now we need to
give a output range so for example let's
say I would want my data here and that
becomes my output range so you can have
a sorted histogram or basically a Pareto
chart so if that's what you are
interested in looking at the frequencies
for your different ranges and here I am
also selecting chart output because I
would want to have a visual histogram
which gives us the frequency and it's as
simple as this just click on OK and now
you get your pins so it basically tells
you frequency of values which is
basically 20 but that does not mean it
is only talking about the values 20 it
is basically talking as a range of 0 to
20 so we have 0 to 20 that is 2 so we
can basically say there is 120 here with
the 20 being the maximum value and then
there is one more 20 so that's your 0 to
20 then you have 20 to 30 which shows
three values so might be in that case I
can say 26
is one thing then I can say 30 that's
the second one and then basically I can
look at 22 so basically this one does
not select 20 as the lower range but it
basically selects 30 as a higher range
so I do see 20 to 30 there are three
entries similarly we can see values for
40 and 50 and since we have selected
Pareto or sorted histogram that shows in
a descending order what is the highest
frequency of values within a particular
range
so that shows me highest frequency is 5
and then you have three and three and
then two so this is how we can create a
histogram and we can perform an analysis
on a single variable
now
as discussed earlier as I said sometimes
we may be interested in finding out the
correlation between different variables
such as say here we have temperature
price of ice cream and units sold and we
may want to
find out the correlation between one
variable to another variable or we would
want to find out the relationship
between variables are they linearly
related are they positively related
negatively related and so on and for
that we can use the correlation of your
data analysis add-in so for example you
want to find out correlation of
temperature and units sold and what we
can do is we can find out that using a
formula so for example if I search for
something like Co relation
and let's search so there is a function
called correlation which we can use and
we can use this to calculate the
correlation of temperature and units
sold so for example let's select this
and that's the function so it says give
me and first array and a second array so
we are interested in finding out
correlation of temperature and units
sold so let's select the range of values
for temperature and then I am interested
in finding out the correlation of
temperature in units sold so let's
select this and that basically gives me
a range of values it gives me the
correlation value which is 0.2859 say
okay and that's your value
so similarly we can do it for
temperature and price ice cream so let's
go for
correlation so that's the function we
are interested in you need to give a
range of values so here we are
interested in temperature and price of
ice cream so let's select temperature
and then the second array or list of
values is price of ice cream let's
select that let's close our bracket and
here we have the correlation value of
temperature and the price of ice cream
similarly you may be interested in
finding out temperature and units sold
like what we have done earlier so we can
do the same thing based on function so
this is same as correlation of
temperature in units sold so I can get
rid of this one now how do I do it using
the data analysis add in
so for that what we need is we need to
go into Data we need to go click on data
analysis and here you have the option
called correlation let's select this now
that basically needs an input range so
we need the range now I might be
interested in finding out the
correlation between temperature and
price of ice cream and units sold so
I've selected all the columns here we
will say Group by columns obviously we
need to select labels in first row
because that is basically taking care of
the first row is heading now output
range you can just give one simple cell
and that's where your data will start
from or you can give a new workbook so
click on OK and that basically gives
your
that basically gives you a correlation
of your different variables and what are
the values and we can check these values
based on the values what we have here so
we have basically temperature and price
of ice cream
and that basically shows me
0.96149 you have temperature in units
sold so you have 0.2859 now you can also
look at units sold and say for example
price of ice cream you can look at these
particular values so if I would be
interested in finding out what is the
relationship between these variables I
can easily find using correlation so I
could be basically writing in a formula
here and selecting what are the cells so
here we were selecting A2 and C here we
were selecting A and B now might be I am
interested in price of ice cream and
units sold and if that's what I'm
interested in then I will give a range
of B2 to B8 C2 to C8 and similarly you
can get your analysis or correlation
values so it's very simple symbol in
Excel and you can use either the data
analysis tab and get your correlation or
you can use formulas and do that
now one more important part of data
analysis is doing your sampling now
sampling could be periodic sampling or
random sampling so sometimes you may
want to look at a variable and you may
want to
get some values based on periodic data
that means might be I am interested in
range of values I am interested in
seeing a sample of values for
a particular period which could be
basically
a range of values or you could just do a
random sampling so for example if I go
for periodic sampling so out of these
values which I see here might be I want
to see say periodic sampling that is a
frequency of two values how many times
we have these values occurring here or I
would go for random sampling so
basically randomly I would want to pick
up say three temperature values now how
do I do it so for example here I have
seven values now if I go for periodic
sampling
the sample or periodic sample value
which I need to give has to be lesser
than the total input values
so for example we can do this let's go
in here and let's go for data analysis
so we can go for sampling here click on
OK and that needs a range of values so
we will select a22 A8 now I could have
selected all the values for this one
temperature and in that case I can give
labels which is going to take care of
the first
row now here we can go for
number of samples which you are
interested in or giving a period so
let's go for period and say for example
I have seven values so what if I select
five so for example if I say 5 that
means I could just get one value so
basically when I'm saying 5 out of 7 so
that's just giving me out of five I want
one value so I can then just give an
output range so here I can basically
select this cell I'll say okay and now
you see it just shows me
one value
so out of the first range that is I have
said 5 it has given me the fifth value
that's your periodic sampling so for
example we want more values so let's
reduce this period to might be 2 which
basically gives me every second value so
I can basically say for example 2 and
say OK and then say okay so that shows
me 26 then you have 35 then you have 40
and then well this one does not have any
more values so that's your periodic
sampling now if you go for random
sampling that's basically
randomly picking up values and you can
choose how many values you want so go
for data analysis go for sampling I'll
go for number of samples how many you
want so for example out of seven values
randomly I want three values and I can
just give this say okay and then
we will do a cancel because we need to
change that range so let's select this
and say okay and that gives me random
three values from this values of
temperature so we can use Excel to do a
simple sampling and we can choose
whether we would want to go for periodic
sampling or random sampling now we have
seen a sampling histogram correlation
descriptive stats and now also let's
look at regression now what is
regression so when you talk about
statistical modeling regression analysis
is used to estimate the relationship
between two or more variables and
basically we would want to look at two
or more variables and basically a
relationship of those variables with the
response or the Target right so for
example if we look at our data here we
have temperature we have price of ice
cream and then we have units sold and we
can go ahead and make predictions so for
example when you look at regression here
you see something like this which is
regression statistics you have Anova you
have different plots which we have here
which is X variable X variable 2 and
then you have normal probability plot
now we have already seen how you can
have your add-in that is data analysis
which helps you in doing different kind
of data analysis here right now how do
we do this so we have our variables here
which is temperature price of ice cream
units sold and when we talk about
regression we need to understand which
one of these are independent variables
which one of these are dependent
variables right so when you talk about
your X that's your independent variable
or we can say predictor or explanatory
so when you talk about your independent
variables or as we say predictors or
explanatory variables these are the
factors that might influence the
dependent variable and when you talk
about dependent variable that's your
response or Target that's the main
factor you are trying to understand or
predict so we can plot a scatter plot to
see relationship between variables
if they are linearly related are they
positively related negatively related
and so on we can also get values such as
R square which is coefficient of
determination regression line and then
analyze the relationship between
variables so here is one of the links of
one of my edit other videos where we are
learning on machine learning and also on
regression but that's programmatically
and using a processing framework such as
Spark now here let's see how do we do
this in Excel so basically we would want
to use our variables which is
temperature price of ice cream units
sold and then get these plots so what we
can do is for example I can get rid of
this and might be I can just say
no borders and when it comes to these
plots
we can have them generated again that's
not a big deal using your data analysis
add-in tool so we have been given
variables here now as I said when we
talk about your
regression analysis we need to
understand whether we have one variable
or we have multiple variables right so
you might have heard of univariate
analysis by variate analysis and so on
well
here we are focusing more on using Excel
to do our regression analysis so I will
not go deeper into regression topics but
certain things as Basics should be known
that when we talk about regression
analysis what does it do it helps you
understand how the dependent variable
changes when one or more independent
variables vary and it basically allows
us to mathematically determine which of
those variables really has an impact
so technically when we talk about
regression analysis model that is based
on the sum of squares which is basically
a mathematical way to find the
dispersion of data points so mainly the
goal of the model is to get the smallest
possible sum of squares and draw a line
that comes closest to the data so that's
what we mean by our regression line or
basically looking at the points and
seeing if the points fall on a
regression line if there are residuals
that is points which do not fall on the
regression line and in terms of
statistics
when we talk about uh statistics we
differentiate between a simple and
multiple linear regression so you have
something called a simple linear
regression models which basically gives
you the relationship between dependent
variable and one independent variable
using a linear function and if you use
two or more variables that is
explanatory variables to predict the
dependent variable we are actually
dealing with multiple linear regression
so if the dependent variable is modeled
as a non-linear function because the
data relationships do not follow a
straight line we have to use non-linear
regression
now what we will do is we'll see how we
can work on this so here we have some
variables and if we look at this might
be based on temperature price of ice
cream we would want to find out how many
units were sold now what we can do is we
can basically
start looking in by creating a simple
scatter plot which is quite easy in
Excel so if you have been given
variables what you can do is you can
click on insert you can then choose the
kind of plots which you want then here
you have insert scatter plot so we can
choose this and you can choose the first
option so that gives you a blank layout
and what you can do is now you need to
select data so for example let's click
on select data and then you can say add
so what we would want is we can give a
name so we want X values and we want our
y values right so when you talk about
why that's your dependent variable or
your response or Target so that is in
our case units sold and X values are 1
set of features or variables or multiple
variables so here I can click on this
series X values and then I can select
this
now in y values what I can do is I can
select these and then I can just say
Okay so that shows me that it would be
giving me a regression scatter plot now
let's say okay and we have some points
plotted here now if you would want to
see the impact of one individual
variable such as temperature or price of
ice cream you could as well do that now
what you can also do is you can add more
meaning to this by giving in a title or
you can also go into Quick layout and
you have various options here so you see
it gives you what is the access title
what is the series and I would prefer to
use here
something like this one so that gives
you your regression line that also gives
you your R square and that gives you
your Y and X that is your coefficients
so let's select this one and then we
have some values which we can use to
compare this also shows me the
regression line and you can keep this
for reference if you would want you can
change the chart title to something else
say scatter plot of uh dependent
uh West independent
variables and you can give any name
which has more meaning and we can get
rid of this one so we have series and we
can say what are these points if you
would want to add in Legend if you would
want to do that or I can just get rid of
this and I will keep these values here
which we will
see when we do a data analysis we can
always compare these values so here I
have created a simple scatter plot
and then I can look at dependent West
independent variables
or I could have selected one particular
variable so this is just for reference
now we can add more details we can say
what is my x-axis what is my y-axis so
basically you can hear
say for example just say Y and might be
here I will say x and we can rename that
later now how do we perform data
analysis or get into regression right
now what we would want to do is
we would want to get or we would want to
do the regression analysis to
demonstrate the relationship between
dependent and independent variables so
normally when you talk about your linear
regression equation you might have known
about it so it is basically why when you
say y
equals you can say BX plus a plus c and
this would be normally the
mathematical equation for a linear
regression where X is your independent
variable Y is your dependent variable
your
a is the y-intercept
which is expected mean value of y when
all X variables are equal to 0 so
basically on a regression graph that's
the point where line crosses the y axis
and that's your intercept
when you talk about B that's basically
your slope of regression line which is
the rate of change for y as X changes
and then you also have
your constant right so that's your sorry
that's basically your random error term
right which is basically the difference
between the actual value of dependent
variable and its predicted value so your
linear equation
always has an error term because in real
life predictors are obviously never
perfectly precise right now what we can
do is we can also reduce this equation
to Y is B X plus a and that's the
equation of a line we can look into this
and the linear equation can be
understood mathematically in this way
now how do we do it in Excel so what we
can simply do is uh
here let me
yeah
so we need to get into data and then
here we have our data analysis add in
you can click on this one and from these
different options you can choose
regression so that's what we would want
to do now we'll say okay now here you
need to give your input y range so as I
said you will have to select the
dependent and independent variables
right so we would want to do some
regression analysis here and here we
have your X and Y so y being your target
that's basically your unit sold so we
can select this along with the labels
when it comes to X either you can select
one variable or multiple variables so I
will select temperature price of ice
cream and then since we have chosen the
headings we will go for labels
right now we can always look at the
confidence level we can change that so
you can say whether you want it in a new
worksheet or you can just say output
range and I will probably just click
here and select one of the cell here now
we can also choose the other options
which we would want to see as a part of
this regression analysis so basically we
have selected input y range which is
your dependent variable
you have selected X range which is your
independent variable and if we are
building a multi regression model then
we
have chosen temperature and price of ice
cream both now we can choose the labels
which we have done we can choose your
output range which is basically on this
sheet and then we can select the
residuals so that basically gives you
your residuals now we can also get your
line fit plots which you were seeing
earlier
you can also go for your normal
probability plots and then basically
just say okay
and let's say okay and that basically
gives you your regression analysis
output so we basically have your summary
output we also have Anova we have our
serial output that's from the previous
one and basically we can get rid of this
that's not required
I can get rid of this one
yeah so now we have our regression
statistics we also have our plots so we
can basically look into these so we have
our normal
let's get rid of these
let's get rid of this let's get rid of
this and then what we can do is since we
had some existing data it has
overwritten so let me get rid of this
and I'll repeat this step again
and let's say no water yeah
so now what we want to do is we want to
do regression analysis so we go get into
Data we get into Data analysis we choose
regression
we have already chosen our y range which
is column c x range is multiple
variables we have gone for labels output
range which we would want to select a
particular cell so let me select this I
am going for a serials line fit plots a
normal probability plots and say okay
so now
we have our plots
we can just separate them to have a
better understanding
yeah and that basically shows you the
variables so here it shows me units sold
and then what are the predicted units
sold and here the variable is
temperature here the variable is price
of ice cream right so that's your one
variable and second variable and then
you also have your normal probability
plot now to interpret this or to
understand what we have here where we
look at your
summary output so it is good to
understand what Excel is helping us out
so basically when we do a regression in
Excel it is performing all the
calculations automatically the
interpretation is something which we
need to understand so basically we are
looking at multiple r value here and we
can
let's also fine tune this one
yeah we have our values here and if you
see we have our R square now we can then
basically look at our multiple R so what
is your multiple R that's your
correlation coefficient which basically
measures the strength of linear
relationship between two variables so
this can be any value between your when
you talk about your correlation
coefficient it can be any value between
minus 1 and 1 and its absolute value
indicates the relationship strength
so the larger the absolute value the
stronger the relationship so 1 basically
means a strong positive relationship
minus 1 means a strong negative
relationship and zero means no
relationship at all now when you are
looking at R square that is the
coefficient of determination which is
used as an indicator of the goodness of
the fit so it basically shows how many
points fall on the regression line so
your R square value is basically
calculated from the total sum of squares
when we say precisely it is the sum of
squared deviations of the original data
from the mean
now when we talk about looking at the
value of your R square so it is
basically we can be seeing uh that this
is
0.450788 that's the value which I am
talking about so it basically means 45
percent of our values fit the regression
analysis model so in other words 45
percent of dependent variables that is
your y values are explained by the
independent variables that is your X
values
so normally if you have r squared value
higher then that is considered as a good
fit and here we have considered multiple
variables now when you talk about your
adjusted R square it is the R square
adjustment for the number of independent
variables in the model so uh you would
want to use this value instead of R
square for multiple regression analysis
such as in our case
now we also have standard error so
that's basically goodness of fit measure
that basically shows the Precision of
your regression analysis so the smaller
the value the more certain you can be
about your regression equation so when
when we talk about your R square that
represents the percentage of dependent
variables variance that is explained by
the model and standard error is
basically an absolute measure that shows
the average
distance that the data points fall from
the regression line so you will have to
look back into regression statistics
terminologies to basically understand
more of this and if you're already from
data science background that then you
already know what I'm talking about we
are just seeing how Excel easily helps
us in doing these things now we can also
look at observations here which is
basically the number of observations in
our model which is seven
now when we talk about regression
analysis and if we look at analysis of
variance that is your Anova values here
so we basically see DF you have s s m s
f and significance F now to understand
these so basically what we are doing is
or what Excel is doing is it splits the
sum of squares into individual
components that give information about
the levels of variability within your
regression model so when you talk about
your DF that's basically the number of
degrees of freedom associated with the
source of variance you have sum of
squares that is your SS so smaller the
residual SS compared with the total SS
the better your model fits the data
right now when you talk about Ms that's
your mean Square you have f is basically
the F statistic or you can say uh f-test
for the null hypothesis basically it is
used to test the overall significance of
the model and then you finally have your
significance f
which is the P value of f so uh when we
when we usually talk about scene simple
linear regression the in an over part is
not really used or it's rarely used
right but when we look at the
significance F value that gives an idea
of how reliably or statistically
significant our results are so if
significance f is less than 0.05 that's
5 percent our model is okay if it is
greater than 0.05
we will have to better choose another
independent variables
right now we can also look at the output
of coefficients and that's what we would
want to look at so you basically have
your intercept here so when you talk
about your intercept temperature price
of ice cream so we know we are looking
at our variables and then we are also
locate looking at our intercept which
basically gives you
more details on your coefficients so the
the main important thing when we talk
about regression analysis is basically
your coefficients it basically enables
you to build a linear regression
equation uh in the form of y equals BX
plus a which I explained earlier and
then basically we can understand our
regression analysis
output better now when we look at the
residual output which we are seeing here
so that gives you your observations how
many observations we have it shows what
is the predicted units sold and then it
also gives you your residuals so we can
compare the estimated and actual number
of sold umbrellas based on the
observation so we have
11.209 here and if you compare that's
basically 12 the second one is 15 and
here it is 13.5
you have and similarly you can compare
all the values of actual units sold and
what our regression has predicted
so basically what we can do is we can
compare these and
we will see if there is any difference
or no
right so obviously there will be or
there would be some difference because
independent variables are never perfect
predictors of your dependent variables
and the residuals
basically help us in understanding how
far the actual values are from the
predicted values so that's what we see
here in the residual section so for
example when we look at this one which
is 11.209 and the actual is 12 we see
what is the residual and how far is the
predicted value from the actual value
so similarly we can also look at the
percentile values so that gives you your
probability output and this is what we
have in our graphs
so we have basically our variables we
are looking at our variables and also
the units sold and the relationship
between them we can basically add in
more details to this particular plot and
you also have normal probability plot
which is basically getting your values
from your probability output here so
this is how you can perform a simple
regression analysis and now what you can
do is you can as I said you can
basically be looking at your scatter
plot you can be looking at your y and x
and your R square values right but
remember what are the variables which
you are selecting and then you can
compare these with basically the values
what you see here so remember here I've
chosen my both set of variables and you
can choose
one variable and then basically see what
is its impact on the response or on the
target
so it's pretty simple here you can add
more details to your scatter plot or the
plots what we have created or Some
people prefer to do it using formulas so
basically we have some statistical
functions that can help you do linear
regression analysis such as you have
linuist you have slope you have
intercept you have correlation and so on
so basically you can use these
particular functions and what you will
have to do is
you will have to basically go in for a
function if that's what you would want
to do and then you can search for
functions and say for example I'll just
say lynnest and say go and here I have
my function so if I would want to really
use this one I can do that what I will
have to do is then select the variable
so if you just say okay and that
basically says your known Y is known X
your constants your stats and basically
you can use the formula also but we are
not covering that here might be in the
later videos we can do that so just try
out and perform some regression analysis
and try to look at your different
variables and try to interpret that so
that basically gives you
an easier way of Performing regression
analysis using your data analysis add-in
in Excel well hello everyone this is
ifan Syed from Team simply learn in this
tutorial we will be talking about macros
used in Excel and also the Visual Basic
application programming for macros so
what is Excel macro you do certain daily
tasks and daily reports or monthly
reports that you generate and you use
data from your Excel and you scrub data
and you basically have the same things
performed or done on the Excel sheets
every time and every day or monthly or
bi-weekly or any number of times that
you open your Excel you remove certain
columns you add certain things and you
change certain values and these are the
things that you do and N number of times
on an Excel and this can all be done by
simple automated wave which is macros so
what it does is it is a set of tasks
that you can execute as many number of
times as you want when you create a
macro basically what it does is it will
record all your mouse clicks and
keystrokes basically if for example you
have your monthly accounts report that
is there and it comes every day and you
have to put it in extract certain data
and remove certain columns that you do
every time that you open that sheet for
instance you remove that column I which
has the obsolete values of your of your
accounts or the sheets that you have and
you remove that column and you edit some
names you add such things every time
that you open that report and then you
format it in a proper way and send it to
your management so this can all be done
and a simple running script called
macros so what you do is you record
those
Mouse clicks and keystrokes and record a
macro for it save it and next time
tomorrow when you come you just run that
macros
and this will do everything for you and
you do not have to do that same tedious
task every day so this is basically a
set of code or a task that you can
execute and automate and it can be done
n number of times so it makes your life
easy now
so next thing is how you actually
activate the macros in your Excel it's a
simple tab that you need to add in the
ribbon section which I'll be showing you
across and this will enable the macros
on your Excel so you go to files
good options
and then you need to customize whatever
click customize ribbon and then there is
a developer tab which you see here it
should be activated so you just need to
select that
click on the tick mark and just click ok
so this will add a developer tab here
and
this will enable the macro so now you
you have your data and you can run
macros or record a macro and run it all
on your Excel
there is also an option to do it a
different way right click on any of the
tabs on the ribbon customize ribbon and
you can add or remove your Macros from
here so this is two ways that you need
to that you can activate uh your Macros
so how you record a macro is the next
thing so here I have a work orders sheet
that I receive every day or one of you
will receive every day and how you
record a macro you have certain set of
tasks that you do and you know this
report has so many things that are
obsolete which you do not need which has
to be put across to your management or
your for your use so how you record or
start a macro you go to the developer
tab and start recording a macro as soon
as you click on this record macro button
it will start recording your keys to
Strokes on the mouse mouse clicks
and you can save that and run it as a
script in the next sheet that you do so
this is the sheet that I have and we'll
try to run a macros on this and see what
it does
so here I have and
this actually works this way uh I need
to go to the developer tab and start
recording a macro so when I click record
macro it starts recording my mouse
clicks and keystrokes so in this sheet I
have to you know remove some columns and
the columns that are Obsolete and the
data that looks weird here should be
removed and all what I need is the work
order number the district and the
tactician name and the kind of service
that we provide and the requested
workday the cost
and the payment so this is what I want
and I do it every day when I receive
this sheet and I have to make these
changes and send it across to the
accounts team so what I do is I simply
automate this by running a macro
so I go to
let's see how it records the macro
if I click record macro I'll save it as
work order
accounts and I'll add a little
description like
work order
accounts here
because
click ok
in
see what I do is basically I add the
borders first
so that the data looks proper and then I
do not want this column I delete it I do
not want the number of technicians that
are there I do not want all these and I
also want the laborers the account and
what kind of payment this is very
crucial for the accounts team I do not
want any of these obsolete data
so I just delete this
okay
and then I just want to have some
cosmetic changes done so
and make sure this doesn't have any
border
and that's it this is the task that I
perform
every day I still don't need it
and I go to the developer tab and click
stop recording so now I have the macro
save and when I have it I have you know
automated these all these steps in one
simple click and how I execute it in
another sheet so I will show it across
to you
the next thing so here I have the next
report that has to be uh changed or
formatted and sent it across so I simply
go the next morning and go to the
developer tab and go to the macro and I
have this macro Save which we ran the
just now and I simply with a single
click I will be able to do these daily
tasks and execute in a Flash so I just
click run and it does the rest for me I
have my report ready and is in a proper
format that is required and it can be
sent across so here as we see it is done
in a single click by running a simple
macro continuing our uh to work on macro
we can simply do this by a single click
of a button by adding a button so what
you have to do is go to the developer
tab and in the control section you will
see the insert option option when you
click on the insert drop down you will
see a form controls and you can say
select a button and here I select a
button and the mouse changes to across
and you can add
your macro and assign it
so as we have saved it work order
accounts as a macro and when I just
assign that macro to this button I can
edit the text by
making it as a work order accounts just
to make it simple okay
foreign
it will run the macro
and format RC
So This Is How We Run The macros in a
single click of a button by adding the
button
there is another alternative way to go
to the macros in instead of the
developer tab and you go to the view
button
and then go to macros at the end
you can view macros or you can record
and you can edit your macro so when I
click view macros it will show you what
are the macros that I have and that I
can run and you can simply run it
alternatively and you can record a macro
as well instead of from the developer
tab if you just click on record macro it
will do the same function that we do
from the developer tab
the next thing is to edit the macro how
do you edit your macro you have to use a
simple application in Excel which is
bbba Visual Basic application to edit
your macro you go to the developer tab
and then click on Visual Basic this
literally opens another window
like this and you will see the module
that you have been working on and you
can edit the
macro here
so as we see if you go back to the Excel
we see that our sheet we have been
working on the sheet and it has the
column still K and the actual sheet is
this so if I go to the Visual Basic
editor
and I'll make sure the node I remove the
columns that are existing from the
column m and I just delete that and I
click run
I go back to my sheet and you see these
changes are not there
okay
this is your old macro and this is our
new macro
as we see this sheet has the rush column
which is the priority of my orders so
these are the things that we can edit
with the VBA in this tutorial we will be
talking about the Visual Basic
application programming for macros so
here we are what is VBA Visual Basic
application it is basically a Visual
Basic application language that is used
for macros in Excel
so what it basically does Visual Basic
for application is a programming
language of excel that helps you
automate tasks by writing macros we have
seen how we use macros how it simplifies
our tedious daily task by running a
simple macro now to help us you know
write these macros and help us get the
best use of our abilities to
ease our work and automate a task we use
VBA so why we be there are many
advantages of using VBA and why we
prefer VBA in macros for excel so
basically it is a very simple language
it saves time in performing tedious
tasks you have number of tasks that you
do every day as we have seen in the
previous section how we uh you can
simplify your daily task by just running
a simple macro and this VBA helps us in
performing those tasks in a very simple
manner another thing is it supports
english-like statements there are
multiple statements that you can use and
which are very basic English language
statements and this can help us or it is
very easy to program our code or edit
these commands you can select a range
you can it is like a if an else
statement and things like that we will
look into those in details in the next
sections now one more thing is it
improves the functionality of excel by
allowing you to make Excel behave the
way you want there are multiple
functions that you perform in Excel like
selecting a number of rows or columns or
selecting a set of cells in particular
you do it in a daily basis so these
things can easily be performed and
easily be edited and executed by using
VBA we will look into those in detail
now what is the VBA editor interface
this is particularly uh
an interface which you will have look in
detail bar section of the VBA editor
interface the next thing is the menu bar
menu bar as we all know it is simply it
shows you the menu wherein you have all
the options like file edit view insert
insert is the one very important menu
bar option and when you can insert
different modules and buttons you know
we'll look into those in details run is
one more important thing all these
things fall under menu bar the next
thing is the VBA code window VBA code
window as it says is the code window
where your actual code resides wherein
you can go into it and edit the code or
write the codes and select the different
range of functions that you can perform
and this is basically the VBA code
window where you edit your or write your
codes
the next thing is the project Explorer
project Explorer is simply like a
Windows Explorer but this is in
particular is specific to your VBA
wherein it shows the different options
that are there the of the Excel sheets
or the worksheets that you're working on
or the modules that you have saved and
so on basically it is an Explorer for
your PBA like a Windows Explorer which
is for the file explorer
the next thing is the properties window
properties Windows shows you the
properties of the worksheet that you're
working on for instance here we are
working on the sheet2 and it shows the
properties what are the kind of uh
worksheet that we have the page break
the right to left whether it is enabled
or not the name of the sheet and so on
whether it's visible and things like
that the next thing is the immediate
window and the watch window
now what is the immediate window
immediate window is basically a tool or
a window wherein you can run and execute
simple lines of course individual Excel
code that you can run it will allow you
to test individual lines
which is very useful and handy when you
are writing and debugging course the
output if the lines that you execute can
be seen here in the immediate window
whereas watch Window watch window is
similar to it but it displays the value
of the watch expression in its currently
current state
so this can be extremely useful again
while we are debugging the VBA code
adding a watch is a great utility and we
will see uh the you the advantages of
having a watch window in your VBA
interface
so these are the things that we learn
and look into it in detail in the coming
section now we continue our topic for
Visual Basic for application for macros
and I'm going to show you how to you
know run some codes and run some macros
in the codes and
perform some simple to complex tasks
using the VBA for macros so there are
two ways to open the Visual Basic
application and the first thing is you
can run alt f11 click on the sheet and
then just press and it will open the
Visual Basic for application window or
alternatively you can just go and click
on the Visual Basic I need to open the
sheet for you I mean the code window for
you and as we have discussed before
these are the windows that we see this
is the code window and this is the
project Explorer
and this is the immediate window I will
you can run some testing course
immediately it will show you the uh code
so here we see the project Explorer
window where we see the modules and all
for our Visual Basic for applications
so as we see the code is empty here
we'll try to record a macro and see uh
how the code develops okay so I just go
here and click record macro
and I save it as a format
and columns
[Music]
this workbook can I just save it click
okay and it has started recording so now
what I'll do is as make it simple and I
just delete some columns here
okay I do not need this
I delete this is there a wait I want
this I want the amount of payment parts
cost labor hours I do not want this
number of technicians forget it
okay
and I go further left and see what all
do I need I need I don't need this
I delete all these and
I just expand this so that it's clearly
visible
and then I want to change the format I
mean the hot
so I select this
[Music]
and I change it to timestrone
okay
I'm going to go back to my developer tab
click stop recording it is saved
okay
now go back to my code
and see
the
macro here so we see the macro here and
we can see uh in detail what it looks
like so we see the code what it's doing
and what the macro run has generated the
codeback so we see we have basically the
name of the macro is format columns and
what it is doing we're just selecting
The Columns and
deleting some we are checking the range
on some columns ee select that is the E
column that we have selected and then
again so on and the next thing is the
font selection that is mentioned we are
changing it to Times New Roman size is
11 so it is basically
a basic VBA code so it starts with the
sub and it should end with m sub so this
is the code or a format of the VBA code
that it looks like and we'll try to do
some basic functions with the
VB and discuss this in further details
so for ease of explanation I have picked
up a blank
spreadsheet and I'll try to explain some
basic
functions and the commands and the
course that we use to accomplish the
task that we with VBA
so as we see this is the blank sheet and
I have selected a new module for it
so here I start the code and as you see
is it starts with sub and I am
specifying the
module name as number so I'll just try
to make it quite simple and
you know so we it is as soon as we enter
the sub it sends with the ends up and so
this is the start of the code and this
is the end of the code and whatever is
there should be here and this is the
name of the code of the macro now uh
I'll explain it further about the game
statement why is it used and what does
it use for so dim is basically a keyword
which is the a short form of Dimension
and it is used to declare a variables in
the VBA so here I am trying to specify
uh
a variable called X and how I'm going to
do it I will as it have it as a number
or an integer or anything so here in
this example I'll put it as an integer
or a number okay and as I put as it
populates the prompt so I select integer
and for example I select the number to
be
500. okay and here I'm trying to assign
a variable integer a cell a value of 500
with a limb keyword
so where exactly I want to put this you
will see it when you execute the code
okay range I am selecting it should be
on the course where I'm going to put the
value of x as and I close the bracket
and what should be the value
should be X so now as I click runs up
or you can do it with the by running the
alt F5 key and it will run the
cool so you see here in the Excel sheet
it executes the value of the cell B5 to
be 500 so this is one simple function
that you can do with the dimension
keyboard or dim keyword and you can
assign the value as integers now proceed
we proceed further with certain or
example some more examples and how we
assign the string value as a as a text
or
something else okay
now I'm going to show you what dim can
be execute I mean used as to set
variables then can be used as a
double when double is basically a longer
form of single variable it usually takes
more space but uses needs more larger
numbers okay and then you can set
double and I've just uh Chrome specified
and we can do state
it basically stores the date values okay
and then again string so what string
does if you use string it stores the
text it can contain numbers it will have
some text as calculations or anything
can be performed so these are the basic
thing that I will cover and
you can also use different uh values for
it so I will discuss this in the next
example
okay
so in the next example I'll try to
use a string value for it and
I put it as a string substring
value
this is my name so as soon as I hit
enter it ends with the answer prompt and
now I can get my code so I put the same
book it has
okay now
I'm trying to use
to name a country or put a value of a
country to one of the cells so let's see
how it goes and I select country and in
country I select Mac
okay now what is the value or the cell
that basically takes the or we will put
the name of the country as so I have to
specify a range and as soon as I hit it
goes and I have to specify the
the cell here so here I put it as G
and 4 okay so I close it
and I put a value tree what value I am
going to assign it is a country okay
now I tried to run this code by simply
and see G4 the name populates as a
country here so this is a dim keyword
you being used as a string in our VBA
code
so
we can also use
VBA to you know pop up a message on an
alert or a kind of a button or a message
pop-up pops up when you execute this
code so this basically can be uh
executed using uh the
code here which I'm going to put
and we use the
okay let's give it a value
I'm going to name it as double value and
again the green keyword I'm going to use
the keyword as double
y double is used is basically uh it
gives a longer it can be used for a
longer form of single variable ticks it
usually takes more space and larger
numbers and we'll try to assign it okay
now I'm going to pop up a message in
this which says value of a is so and so
so I'm going to give value of a as
two five zero okay and how I it pops up
a message okay so there is a message box
which you know can be used and it will
give you a value I mean it will prompt
you to enter the value what kind of
button you want and you want you can
enter the text and you can enter right
so here I'm going to uh write a code
which you know which gives a pop-up
message a message box saying that the
value of a is sorry so
the value of a is
I'm going to put it in and percent code
so it actually takes the value of a
okay now that's it and let's try to run
this and you will see a message for
popping message box popping up
okay so the value of e is the message
box pops up saying the value of a is
250. so
in the next example I am going to write
a code wherein you know you can give a
value or a string you can assign it to a
selected cell and this basically used
when you have some you know when you
have a task of you know giving a value
to a particular cell or you have to
assign a text or say something about a
report okay so this let's see how it
goes and we use the
I will say it as
run with some procedures
[Music]
okay they
so here I am giving to I'm going to give
a user input and it will be as a string
okay you can give anywhere I mean any
string or any statement what my user
input will be I will Define it here
[Music]
this is the
report
let's make it simple
okay and where I'm going to put it is
in the active cell or the cell that I
have it
select okay what will be the value
the value will be the user input
I have defined user input as this is a
report for VBA so this cell turns into
you this is a report for VBA
I run this and you see this
so in some cases you need to run this
and you know it makes life quite simple
when you use VBA for this as we have
seen before we have used message box now
I'm going to use the same message box
to display my name or you can use it to
display your name so let's see how it
goes I'm going to name it as
name
okay and it's very simple you have to
define a message box
which displays your name
and I'm going to put it under course
that my name is
and we'll try to run it
see here
so it pops up a message saying that my
name is Advanced so this is a message
box that you can display and I can do
anything with this uh
this is a PBA okay
[Music]
okay I run it again and it pops this
message so these are the things that you
can use to customize or you know when
you open an Excel sheet or try to run a
Workshop or a report and it pops up a
message customary welcome messages that
you can customize or you know Define a
report or kind of
data in it and this can be used using
run using the message box
now I have another good example wherein
you know you can write a code to
tell Excel what is the value of
a cell or what is the number that is
there in the cell so here it is
I'll put it as sub
number
and it will again populate a message box
which
will set it to
the
the entered
value
is
tell me
which or I specify which cell it is that
we are going to find the value of okay
so I gave a range
of
I have to give it in codes
I'm going to
foreign
[Music]
of the number that is present in the
cell A1
okay
it ends let's try to run it
run it and it will give me the value so
this is how we can use Excel to
determine or show or populate a message
box which will give us the value of the
number that is there in the cell so here
I can change it to
a
as well and try to run it and it will
give me the number so this is a simple
way of you know populating a message box
which will tell us the
value of a uh let me show you one more
simple example where in a message box
pops up or a welcome message that can be
power set when you open the Excel or
worksheet so
so let's
name it as Auto
open
[Music]
and then again message box I wanted to
populate and what does it say
I put it in quotes welcome
[Music]
Workshop
it's very simple you just run it and
see it pops up a message saying it
welcome to a workshop so these are the
one more this is one more way where you
can you know run a code or do simple
welcome message on Excel
next I'm going to show you a code
wherein you can give a value or assign a
value to a particular cell by simple
curved
so we name it as add value
now I specify the range I mean where I
am going to specify a cell
where the value will be given to the
[Music]
I'm going to give it as B5
okay to put it as curves close the
parenthesis
what is the value that I'm going to give
value equals
2 5 0. okay so now with this code I mean
I'm going to assign a value of 250 to
the cell B5 let's see
run it see
again I do it to be 10.
okay
so this is how you can assign a value to
a particular cell
now I can run the same thing and give a
range of cells I mean let me make it
very simple here
I give it as B1
through b
as
four five zero so let's see what it does
see here I'm going I'm specifying the
range to be B1 through B5 so it is doing
it for the whole range
okay and
then I can give another set of range
here
like let me specify it
[Music]
c one
of course give me an error single colon
C4
and I separate it with a comma and I can
specify another range so the next one
will be D1 to D4
and then I close the codes close the
parenthesis I ordered the value that I
give is
let's say
two three zero
and I try to run it
so it gives the value of c 1 through C4
and D1 through D4 as 230 as we specified
in the
code
so this is one of one more example
bearing you can assign values to the
uh so range of cells or cells and with
the VBA
one more thing I can you know assign a
value to a particular cell by specifying
these cells it's a very simple just
specify the cells like
oh six
comma seven okay
and I close the parenthesis I assign a
value to it value equals
10. let's see
see
here it assigns the value to that
particular cell that we have specified
Root 6
and concept
okay so this is one more example wherein
you can assign values to particular
cells
okay in the next example uh there will
be a scenario wherein you need to select
a
range of cells in the sheet so this can
also be done this task can also be
performed using VBA so I will show you
how
this is our let's say selector
range
okay and
and I am going to set a dim variable as
a example okay let's say it has example
and what I'm doing is I'm specific range
because I'm going to select a range of
cells okay now I'm going to set the
variable as
set example where I am going to define
the range of the cells that should be
selected so let's say a one
to D
okay this will be the selection
and what I'm going to
set the value okay I am going to set a
value
example
I'm going to give it a value of
256 so
let's see how it pans out
okay so here I'm selecting a set of
cells a range of cells and I'm going to
assign a value with this function so
this makes it quite simple and this will
be used in a regular daily task when you
know there is there will be a scenario
where you have to select a set of cells
and given a give a value to it so you
can do it with the click of a button of
the VPN
now I can simply tweak this with the you
know by just selecting it so there is
I'll remove this
and instead of assigning a value I'll
just
put an option to select it
now let's just run it and see what
happens next
okay so this is one way of you know just
selecting it
and then it's it becomes easier for you
to copy paste and do some functions so
you can select this and you can assign a
value and you can also give a set of
values to a particular range or cells
with these codes
now what if I want to do a selection of
the same rows and columns in the next
sheet and I can do this with the
setup another set of commands so I will
show you how
so here let's say you know we set the
same thing and we specify the worksheets
okay the worksheets
I want it in sheet 2 okay so I just put
it as sheet and I activated basically
activating it and now I am going to
specify the worksheet
2 and what is the range that I am going
to select the same thing okay
the range will be
will be
A1
to
D Phi
okay
what I'm going to do I am going to
select it
okay and see what happens here
okay okay
so here I am selecting the worksheet too
and I'm activating it and I'm going to
assign range and I'm going to select it
so I can just copy the same or select
the same set of cells in the next sheet
okay now when there will be as I said
there will be a you know by requirement
where you need to copy some cell
contents and paste it to another
location so how you do that is again a
simple code that you can write and let's
say
let's say it has a copy and paste I'm
just making it simple by giving
something that we can understand and
relate and
copy
[Music]
okay so what I'm going to do is I am
going to select this range and I'm going
to copy it and paste it somewhere here
okay so let me just remove this
and actually first we have to specify
the range where you want to copy the
cells okay so let's say it is again A1
it should be in codes D5
of course
and I am going to select it okay
then what I'm going to do is uh once you
select this the selection that you have
should what should be the function and I
am going to specify the selection and
the function should be copying it
okay so I just said that and where I'm
going to paste it so I have to now
specify the range where I have to raise
this selection and you can just mention
the
column here let's say G
uh
10.
okay
close it
I'm going to select it and then where
I'm going to paste it I can do it in
this sheet okay active sheet foreign
selection and that selection what we are
doing is we will copy it and now we are
going to specify the range where you are
going to
select it and then paste it quite simple
let's
okay see
and
you can just change it to so it is
visible on this
file okay
so this makes uh quite easy and you can
run it
the next scenario will be like when you
need to get the count of the number of
cells like you have to have a selection
and you need to count the number of
cells so this can also be done and it's
quite easy
I am going to show it to you
let's say the summary account
sales
should always be relatable so that you
know you remember and you understand
what is the output and why you are using
it and I'm going to set a variable let's
say I'm going to set an example for this
and what we're going to do is we are
going to specify a range first okay we
will specify the range of
the cells that we are going to that we
need to count basically so I'm going to
set a variable as a range and then
what we are going to do is
specify
despite the range or your selection
where you count the where you need the
count of the number of cells so even
if the high hopes
and now how you want the output you want
it you want a message box to pop up so
you will set a message box
and
what should it give it will give you the
count of the variable that is the
variable is here is examples Okay so
it will count the number of cells in
this area
okay uh let's see it says
okay here I think and list it so I just
specify the number here and let's see so
it gives you the number of
found in this event okay
now let's see I want to
selection so it's quite simple it will
be very useful in our daily task and
wherein you need to count the number of
cells so this is one way to get it
uh well I can further tweak this and to
determine the uh the count the number of
rows or columns so it's again very
simple I just need to do some changes
here I have to set the
column count
so if I want to
calculate the number of columns
just
let's see how it should calculate or
give the message the number of columns
yet
see it gives there are five columns okay
one two one two three four five okay so
it gives us the number of columns here
if I change it to should give me
for foreign
so this way you can calculate the number
of count the number of cells number of
columns number of rows
with this
the next thing I'm going to talk about
is the if statement if statement is one
of the most widely used statement and
one whoever is in programming are very
much familiar with this function so what
it does is we specify a condition if a
condition is met then the output output
should be such and such we can specify
the condition and it will check
whether that condition is there and if
it is
space I mean if it is achieved then you
will have to specify the output as well
so this can be achieved with the if
statement
okay and it is very easy because it is
it understands the basic uh English
language so it's not very complicated
and I'll show you how
so the syntax can be like this if
suppose you specify a condition and if
that condition is met then the result
you specify the condition and the result
port okay so this is one thing and then
you can specify the s or else condition
where you know you specify the condition
two then the result should be
this
so here you are going to specify two
conditions or multiple conditions where
you specify
this and if it is there then result will
be this if it is this condition and then
the result will be something else
let's take an example wherein you have
to you have some scores or Maps
and you have to select the result you
can do this manually
entering so just you can write a code
suppose for example
I have it here
let's
go and
I specify as
okay
statement
okay now I have to specify the variables
now I have two variables I have a score
and I have a result and the score is an
integer the number and the result is a
string pass of a so I specify this okay
dim
score
as specified as integer okay
and then there's another variable that I
have to set result
as
a string
okay
now what the score will be the score I
have to specify the range
core I'm giving it as a range
it's in my
cell A1
okay
I specify the range
what is it it is a value
okay
should be alert
and then I'm specifying a condition here
if
core value the variable
is greater than or equal so as I said
it's quite simple and it takes the basic
English language functions available and
then
the result result is another variable
that I have said result what it should
be it should be
in codes
okay so if this condition is met then
the result will be this okay
and now where I want to specify my
result I should give
so I give it in the next column or
anyone
this is the basic example
value should be the result
okay let's see how it runs
see
space pass
to 40
.
it doesn't give me anything because I
have specified only one condition here
okay
kind of 75 let's see how it turns
see so this way it's very basic
condition that you are specifying you
are specifying two variables the score
and the result and then you are giving a
value for it and you are specifying the
condition if the score is greater than
then the result should be passed
now in the next uh section uh we will
simply tweak this and use an if then
else statement we'll attach an else
statement with it and see we'll specify
another condition and see so here again
we'll use two variables that is the
score as integer and the result as a
string and let's stick to the same
values
and now
um I'm going to specify it and if the
score is greater than 60
then the result
so the result will be pass as it is
before and then
I'm going to specify another condition
here else
the result should be
it should be
okay
foreign
and now I have to go to laser and if
statement I have to specify the answer
and the result will be again in the
value I mean the range will be V1 so
let's see if it is more than 60 then it
is passed otherwise it is fail
okay please pass let's see
40 and
run it again
so okay so we are specifying two
variables again we are giving it a range
and we are specifying one condition if
this condition is met the result is
passed otherwise else it is fail
so another set of example
the next statement that we use uh or we
are going to discuss is the Loop
statement that is the for Loop statement
and why we use it there are there are
situations and uh tasks that you need to
execute and you need to do it several
number of times these are basically
executed sequentially it means one after
another so the first treatment or the
function is executed and the next is
taken up so and then the next and so on
so these Loop statements allow us to
execute a statement or a group of
statements multiple number of times many
number of times and this happens only
when the first task or the first task is
done
and it executes that and it goes to the
next one so here we will discuss a
simple example of the for Loop statement
so let's see how it
works and I'm going to set up a
Loop statement okay again the I'm going
to make it as Loop one so here it is I
have to specify the
variable that is dim
and I'm going to specify X as an integer
okay I'll try to execute it and then
explain it what happens and how it is
okay for x equals to 1 2
94 okay let's see
and I'm going to specify the range
as
so what I'm going to do is basically I'm
going to fill the column A from 1 to 24
with some value not from 1 to 24 with
the values of 1 through 24 okay
so I'm setting up a range
and How It Ends is it gives me a value
now it excuse this and goes to the next
one I'll explain you how so we are
setting up a loop we are setting up a an
integer a variable X as integer and we
are setting the value of x to be 1 to 24
so here for 1 it executes the first
thing is it it takes X as 1. and it
fills in A1
and then the next value of x will be 2
and it goes to A2 and fills the value as
2 so just let's try to execute this and
you will see the
row column A filled with 1 through 24.
see
it's quite simple it executes one
condition
and then goes to the next and we are
defining it with the number of values
and the variable as X
and the number of values is going to be
24. okay so this is one basic example of
a Purdue statement
now let's do some more addition to this
uh
example by you know executing another
sector called Loop and giving the output
and we'll put the output to be the color
code advance in the column B so how we
do it it's a basic simple example that
I'm going to take and again what I'm
going to do is I will have this values
here and I am going to convert the
B column with certain color index for
each number there will be a different
color so let's see
in
what I'm going to do is I'm only going
to change the B
and what action is going here we put a
value now we are going to select it and
with this selection
what I'm going to do is it should select
it and it should color the interior with
what
the color index okay
and the value of x
and then I'm going to specify the
pattern what uh pattern it will take for
the
box to be colored and I'm going to put
it as a solid
you can fill the whole thing with the
solid
and then I just execute it see
it takes this
color B
and let's code it like this
so these are the simple things that you
can set up with the
codes and for Loop statements so there
are numerous examples and exercises that
we can perform tasks we can perform with
the VBA and this can be found in detail
in our next process Advanced courses in
this video we'll be creating two
dashboards using a sample sales data set
so if you want to get the data and the
dashboard file that we'll be creating in
this demo then please put your email IDs
in the comment section of the video our
team will share the files via email
now let's begin by understanding what is
a dashboard in Excel
a dashboard is a visual interface that
provides an overview of key measures
relevant to a particular objective with
the help of charts and graphs
dashboard reports allow managers to get
a high level overview of the business
and help them make quick decisions
there are different types of dashboards
such as strategic dashboards analytical
dashboards and operational dashboards an
advantage of dashboards is the quick
detection of outliers and correlations
with Comprehensive data visualization it
is time saving as compared to running
multiple reports
with this understanding let's jump into
our demo for creating our dashboards
we'll be using a sample sales data set
let me show you the data set first
so here is the sales data set that we'll
be using for our demo
so this data set was actually generated
using a simulator and is completely
random it was not validated though we
have applied certain transformations to
the data using power query features
so this data as you can see has
1000 rows so using the simulator we had
generated thousand rows of data
similarly if I go on top you can see
this data set has 17 columns
now let me give you a brief about each
of the columns so first we have the
region column so we have Middle East and
North Africa there's North America Asia
sub-Saharan Africa and others
similarly we have the country names from
which the item was ordered
the third column is the item type so we
have different items Cosmetics
vegetables there's baby food cereal
fruits
Etc
then we have the representative's name
or you can say this as the customer name
who ordered the product
then we have a sales Channel column so
there are basically two channels whether
the item was sold offline or online
next we have the order priority column
now here C stands for critical
then we have H which is for high
priority orders then we have M for
medium priority orders and finally we
have L which is for low priority orders
you can see the order date column then
we have the order ID the ship date next
we have
units sold
which is basically the total number of
units sold for each item
then we have the unit price column this
is the price at which each product was
sold
then we have the unit cost column which
is basically the production cost for
each of the items
next we have the total revenue the total
revenue is actually the product of units
sold and unit price
then we have the total cost column
now the total cost column is actually
the product of units sold and the unit
cost
similarly we have the total profit
column so total profit is the difference
between total revenue and the total cost
and finally we have created two more
columns that is order year and then we
have order month now these two columns
were actually generated using the power
query features so we use the order date
column which is this column and
extracted order year and Order month
so first we are going to create a
revenue dashboard where we'll focus on
generating reports for Revenue by order
year Revenue by year and region Revenue
by order priority and much more
we'll create separate po tables and po
charts and format them to make them look
more interesting and presentable
we'll add slices and timeline to attach
posts in order to filter it based on
specific fields
now let's create our first report to see
the total revenue generated each year
so we need to create a pivot table for
this I'll click on a cell in my data set
and then I'll go to the insert tab here
we have the option to select the pivot
table
I click on this
you can see
my table range is selected
next I want to place my pivot table in a
new worksheet
and let's just click on OK
there you go so we have a new sheet
where I can place my pivot table
so first I need to find the total
revenue generated by each year so what
I'll do is
I'll drag my order here column
under rows and then
I'll select the total revenue column
under values
you can see I have my Pivot chart ready
now if you want you can sort this
so from the data you can see we have
order Year from 2010 to 2017.
now based on this data let's create our
pivot chart so I'll click on any cell
go to insert and here you have the
option to select recommended charts I
click on this
now actually I want a line chart so I'll
click on
line here and select ok
there you go so we have successfully
created our first pivot chart
now let me show you how you can format
this chart to make it more readable
so first let me delete
these so I'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart so
this will delete the buttons present on
the chart now let me go ahead and edit
the chart title
so the title I want is total revenue
I'll type it down
by year
all right
next
let's do a few more transformations
so if I click on this plus sign
which is actually for chart elements we
have some options like to add access
access titles chart title data labels
this grid lines Legend and others
Okay so let's remove the legend now
you can see the total Legend is gone
now let me
add access titles so we label our x-axis
and y axis so here under x axis
I can
write it as
year
similarly on the y-axis I'll put Revenue
okay now you can move a bit
all right now
let me select this chart Style option
and go to Colors first
here I'll select yellow color okay
and then let's go back to style
let's select a new style from this
I want
this die
okay
now you can also add
data labels so I'll just click on data
labels
you can see we have
the revenue for each of the years now
this is not readable at all so we'll
format this a bit
if I click on this Arrow here I have
more options
if I scroll down you can see we have
something called as number here
I'll expand this
and under category I'll select custom
now here
will give a format code
which is a bit different
so this is actually a kind of a formula
so I'll write if my Revenue value
is greater than
let's say
9 lakhs
000.
let me make sure there are six nines
here so one two three four five and six
okay we are good to go
I'll close the bracket
I'll give a hash
give two commas
so if the revenue is greater than 9
lakhs 99
000 I'll put it in the format of
millions So within double quotes I'll
write m
I'll give a semicolon
followed by
another hash
and if the value is less than
the desired number
it should be 0 million let me click on
ADD
all right you can see how nicely we have
formatted our data and you see here we
have
added the new format which is in
millions
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and adjust the
boxes let me move this a bit up I'll
delete this
now if you notice this line chart you
can make a few conclusions for example
if you see here in 2010 the total
revenue generated was nearly 175 million
now this came down to 150 million in
2011 then the revenue constantly grew
from 2011 till 2014 it reached 195
million
and after 2014 it again came down to
180 million and the revenue dropped
significantly between 2016 and 2017. in
2017 the revenue was just 96 million
now before moving ahead to my next chart
let me just rename this sheet so I'll
write it as
Revenue
by year
all right
now
let's analyze the revenue generated each
year in different regions so for this
we'll create another pivot table
let me close this
I'll click on any cell go to insert and
select pivot table
I just click ok so that my pivot table
is placed on a new sheet
all right
now this time we want the revenue by
each year and region so first of all
let's drag region to columns
then
let's drag the ordered ear column under
rows and then
I'll select total revenue onto values
so here you can see we have the pivot
table ready so for 2010 you can see in
Asia
this was the revenue generated
similarly if you see for 2013 this was
the total revenue generated in Europe
and we have for other years as well
now let's create a line chart based on
this pivot table so I'll select any cell
in the pivot table I'll go to insert and
I'll click on recommended charts from
this list I'll select my line chart and
click on OK there you go
so we have our next pivot chart ready
so
on the right you see the different
regions that are present in different
colors let me just expand it so that you
can see all the regions we have
so in total we have
seven regions
and each of the regions have been
represented in different colors
so if you notice this graph
for the sub-Saharan African region
in 2012
sub-Saharan Africa meet the highest
amount of sales
now from the sample data you can also
tell
that the revenue for North America has
been significantly low compared to other
regions
similarly if you see
for Europe
this was the revenue Trend between 2010
and 2017. so if you see here in 2011 the
sales
where at this level then it
significantly dropped in 2012 then in
there was a huge Spike and then in again
came down in 2015 and so on so you can
make your own conclusions by looking at
these line charts now let's
format this chart so first of all let's
delete the field buttons present on the
chart and we'll also
delete the Legend all right now let me
just reduce the size of the chart
next we'll add a chart title so
will
give the title as
Revenue
Buy
year end
region
okay
you can also format the
y-axis in terms of Millions
so I'll right click on this axis and
I'll select format access
I'll scroll down and here we have
the number drop down
let me scroll again
under category I'll select custom
and
we will use this format that we created
for our previous chart there you go you
can see
our access labels have been changed in
terms of millions now
so let's close this and let me save it
now you can reduce the font size or
increase the font size let me just show
you suppose you want to increase the
font size of the chart title so you just
select it and from here you can either
also move it to left or right or you can
place it in the center as well for the
time being let me just keep it to the
left
all right
now
will see the revenue and total cost by
each region and will create a combo
chart for this so let me show you how to
do it
I'll go to my data sheet
I have my cell selected
go to insert and click on pivot table
let me just click on OK all right
so for this
I'll select
my region onto rows
and then
I'll have
two columns under values the first one
is going to be total revenue
and the next column will be the total
cost column all right so here we have
the pivot table ready now based on this
pivot table let's create our pivot chart
so I'll go to recommended charts and if
you see below
at the bottom we have combo chart so
this is the preview preview of the combo
chart
all right now let me just click on OK
there you go so we have a nice combo
chart ready here
now the way to look at it is the bars
represent the total revenue which is
this column
now
the line represents
the total cost
so let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so first of all let's delete the
field buttons all right and let's also
remove the legend from here
next we'll add data labels so I'll click
on data labels here okay so these are
the data labels for
the bars or the revenue column
now
let's format the data labels in terms of
millions so I'll click on this Arrow go
to more options so I scroll down
I have number
from here I'll select custom and
I'll choose my type that is in millions
all right so you can see we have
formatted our data
next thing we'll add a chart title
so here I'll write as
Revenue
by
region
it's actually revenue and total cost
by region
before moving ahead let me
rename the sheets as well I'll write
revenue and
total cost
similarly
sheet 3 also I am going to rename it as
Revenue
by
year and region
so this makes your sheet more readable
all right
now moving ahead
next we are interested to get the
revenue generated by order priority and
for this we are going to create a pie
chart
so let's go to the data sheet and create
our pivot table first
I click on OK
now
I'll select order priority under rows
and under values I'll select total
revenue
so this is a very simple pivot table so
you have your order priority so C is for
critical H is for high L is for low and
M is for medium now based on this let's
create a pie chart so I'll go to
recommended charts and here you have pie
chart
I want to select this 3D type of pie
chart and I'll click on OK all right so
we have our pie chart ready let me just
resize it
and from here I'll remove the field
buttons
and I also don't need the Legends I'll
delete this as well
all right now let's give a chart title
so this is going to be
Revenue by
order
priority
now let's add
our data labels
I'll check this option
okay now let's again format this in
terms of Millions
so here
I click on the last option I'll go to
numbers
under category I'll select custom and my
type is going to be in terms of millions
there you go
let me close this
I will just
move this
to the center
all right
now if you want you can change the color
of the text as well
so let's
have it in white color and see how it
looks okay so this looks pretty decent
cool
now
moving to our next report
so this time
we are going to find the total revenue
by countries so we have multiple
countries present in our data set we
want to visualize the revenue generated
in each country
so for this we are going to create a
horizontal bar chart so let me show you
how to do it but before moving ahead let
me just rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue
by
I'll just put op which stands for order
priority all right
now let's create our horizontal bar
chart I'll go to insert click on pivot
table
and select ok
so I want my Revenue based on different
countries so I'll select country and put
it under rows
and then I'll choose total revenue and
place it under values
so here you have the different country
names we have Afghanistan this Albania
let me scroll down you have Bangladesh
there are
a number of countries you have Czech
Republic there's Estonia France Gabon
similarly if you scroll down
we have India this Jamaica Italy and all
the way to the bottom if you go we have
New Zealand this Netherlands Philippines
Portugal
we also have
Singapore
lots and lots of countries
we have the UAE United States of America
Zimbabwe and others
all right let me go up
So based on this pivot table let's
create our people chart so I'll go to
insert and select recommended charts
from here I am going to select the
column chart you can see the preview
here and let me click on OK
all right so here you can see
the different country names at the
bottom and the revenue for each of the
countries
let's go ahead and edit this chart so
first of all I'll delete
the field buttons okay and let me also
remove the legend
here I'll write
Revenue
by
countries
this is going to be my
chart title
okay
let's format this chart a little more
so I'll click on this option
and we'll select a new style let's say
I'll select
style 6 okay
and
let me now go under colors and we'll
select the color of the bars so let's
choose this color okay
so you have
a horizontal column chart ready
and at the bottom you can see the
different country names and we have the
Revenue
cool
now
let me go ahead and
rename this sheet so I'll write Revenue
by
countries
and hit enter
okay
and finally we'll create another report
which is going to be part of our Revenue
dashboard and this is revenue by items
so we'll visualize
our revenue for different items present
in the table
so if you see this we have Cosmetics
vegetables cereal fruits this cloths
snacks households and other products as
well so let's check the revenue for each
of these items
so we'll continue the same drill I'll
create my pivot table on a new worksheet
and this time I'm going to drag
item type under rows and
will have the total revenue under values
so here on the left of the table you can
see we have the different item names and
then we have the
total revenue
so let me just
sort this
total revenue
from largest to smallest so you can see
here office supplies meet the highest
amount of Revenue followed by household
then cosmetics and fruits meet the
lowest amount of Revenue
and click on this go to insert and
select recommended charts
this time I am going to create a bar
chart so this is how my bar chart is
going to look like
I'll select OK all right now let's
format this chart a bit
I'll delete the field buttons and I'll
delete the legend as well
and
let's edit the chart title so this is
going to be
Revenue
by
items
cool
we also want to change the
color of the bars so I've selected all
the bars I'll go to my home Tab and here
let's say I want to select green color
all right
I have edited my chart a bit now
let's
make it
and I'll remove the Bold
okay
here if you want you can change the font
Also let's keep it in blue color all
right
finally
let's rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue by
items
cool
finally
now it's time for us to merge
all the charts that we have created
to our dashboard
so let me show you how you can create
the dashboard
I'll create a new sheet
and first thing I am going to do is
I'll click on The View Tab and uncheck
grid lines so this will remove
the grid lines present in the worksheet
next
I am going to insert an image so we'll
have a background image on our dashboard
so the way to do is I'll go to the
insert Tab and under illustrations I
have the option to select pictures or
insert pictures so I'm going to insert
picture
present on the device that is my
computer
I'll go to desktop and here I have a
folder called Excel dashboard files
and I'll select this dashboard
background and hit insert
so this is going to insert an image now
let me just
drag this image so it covers a fair
enough portion
so I'll hit shift and I'll drag it
all right
so you can see I have successfully added
a background image if you want you can
still
expand this background image
a bit to the right
cool
now the next thing
is going to be
the title of the dashboard so I'll click
on insert and here
I have the option to select a text box
so
I'll click on a text box and
I'm going to place text box in the
middle
and I'm going to name this text box as
Excel
Revenue dashboard
on sales
I'll
Center Line it
let's do some more formatting so I'll
select this text box on the top you can
see ship format
here I'm going to expand this shape fill
and I'll select no fill
so my text box is transparent now and
I'll also remove the outline
all right
now let me just double click on the
title of my dashboard and I'm going to
select
a font you can select whichever font you
want
let me stick to Britannica bold
and I'll increase the size to let's say
30.
all right I'll just
drag the text box
I'll make the text as white instead of
black
all right so we have our
title of the dashboard ready
now if you want you can also insert some
icons to this dashboard so I'll go to
insert and I'll click on illustrations
again and select pictures
I am going to add
these two pictures which is of a store
and a cart
to make it look
visually appealing so I'll
place the icons
here and similarly let me just copy it
and I'll place the
cart and the store
to the right as well
all right
next
the idea is to
bring in all the charts that we have
created and place it on the dashboard
so let me copy
each of the charts and
place it
on the dashboard so I'll hit
Ctrl V to paste it
and we'll resize this as well
all right
similarly let me bring in all the other
charts as well
all right so now you can see I have
added
all my charts and graphs to this
dashboard
so you can see here we have
our line charts are
column charts the combo charts the Spy
chart
and others
now let me go ahead and format these
charts a little more so you can see this
looks a bit cluttered so let's adjust
the labels let me bring this down
similarly I'll bring
190 million
a little below
all right this looks fine now
one more thing we are going to do is
we'll remove the white background from
each of the charts and make it
transparent so let me show you how to do
it so I'll select this chart
then I'll right click and go to format
chart area
here on the right you see we have an
option called No fill so if I select no
fill you can see the white background
is gone now similarly let me also remove
the grid lines so I'll select the grid
lines and hit delete so you have also
removed the grid lines from here now
let's also remove the white outline that
we have so I'll select this chart go to
format
and here
I'll go to shape outline and I'll select
no outline you see this so we have our
total revenue by year which is a line
chart and this is completely transparent
now now what I'm going to do is
I'll place this chart over a box
so I'll go to insert and in insert we
have the option to create a shape
so I'll
click on illustrations and here I'll
choose a shape and let me select a
rectangle
so I'll just
create a rectangle here
all right and now
what I'll do is
I'll select this and bring this to front
I'll right click and choose
bring to front
and I'll place this shape
below it
all right now the next thing is to edit
the shape
so first I'll change the color of this
box so let me select this blue color
and and let me increase the transparency
so I'll
right click and go to format shape
here I'll increase the transparency
let's keep it to
25 percent
or let's say 20 percent all right
next thing
we'll just convert all the
font to white color
including the axis labels
the chart title
will also
convert all the
access labels to white color so it looks
better now we'll just adjust our
chart over here
next thing let's just
remove the outline so I'll go to shape
outline and I'll select no outline you
see
we have now formatted our chart let's
just
pull this a little up
all right now we'll add this blue
background to all the other charts so
we'll first add the background make it
transparent and then we'll convert the
font text to white color to make it more
readable and visible so
for the time being I'll just pause the
video and come back again
all right so now you can see on your
screens we have nicely formatted our
dashboard so I've added a few logos for
each of the charts you can see the logos
here so for
Revenue by countries we have a globe
then if you see here this is kind of a
map or a location
similarly we have all formatted the
color of the bars
then we have also formatted the labels
in terms of Millions
if you look on the y-axis even the
revenue for year and region are all
formatted in terms of Millions
if you want this you can also format the
total year by Revenue in terms of
millions so the way to do is you can
select this graph
right click and go to format access
here if I scroll down
you have numbers
and under category I'll select custom
then I'll select my type as
this format which is in millions
and you see here we have successfully
formatted our
y-axis labels
all right
so the next thing
is to add slicers and timelines to a
dashboard now slicers are used to format
your data based on a particular column
suppose if you want to see Revenue by
certain items you can add item as a
slicer and you can view the entire
dashboard similarly
for timelines you can add date columns
so if you want to see what was the
amount of sales or revenue generated on
a particular year or a particular month
you can do that using a timeline
so I'll select one of the charts
and then either you can go to the insert
Tab and here you can see under filters
we have slices and timeline or if you go
to the pivot chart analyze tab here also
you have insert slicer and timeline
option so I'll select insert slicer here
first now it's giving me the list of
Fields present in the data set so I'll
select
country
region and let's say we want to
know by
item type and sales channel so these are
going to be my four
slicers I'll click on OK
you can see it here we have our
four slicers here and these are the list
of values under region we have Asia
this Europe North America and others
similarly we have the different country
names for Country slicers
and then for item type also we have all
the items that were present in our data
set
now
moving ahead we need to connect
all the slices to a dashboard so what
I'll do is
I'll right click
on this option
and I'll go to report connections
okay so under report connections you
have
all the pivot tables that we created
you currently see only one of the pivot
table is selected so we need to
select all the pivot tables so let me
check
all the pivot tables present in this
workbook and click on OK
all right now that we have connected one
of our slices we'll now connect the
other remaining slicers so I'll right
click on this go to report connections
and I'll check
all the pivot tables present in this
worksheet
click on OK
similarly let's do it for the country
slicer
I'll go to report connections and let me
select
all the pivot tables
and finally we have the item type so
I'll right click
good report connections and then I'll
select
all my Pivot tables
and let's hit OK
all right now let me just organize this
a bit so I'll
place my Pivot tables
to the right
I'll just reduce the size
let me scroll down
I'll add
my region slicer here
similarly
I'll add my final slicer that is sales
Channel
now in our next dashboard which is going
to be the profit dashboard I'll show you
how to add a timeline
all right
now I have arranged all my slicers
so let's see you want to find the
revenue that was generated for an item
type let's say
beverages so you can just select
beverages here
and
all your charts
show the respective revenues so you have
the total revenue by year for beverages
only
similarly here you can see the revenue
by year and region only for beverages
item type
if I scroll down
now this chart represents the revenue
that was generated in each of the
countries only for item type beverages
let me just uncheck it
all right
let's say you want to see
the revenue generated for a country like
India
so I have selected India here
and now you can see
My Graph has changed only for
country India
you can see here it is showing only for
India now
similarly you can also filter your
revenues based on the different regions
let's say you want to know the revenue
generated based on sales channels so we
have two sales channel that is offline
and online suppose we want to know the
revenue generated offline so I'll just
select offline you can see the values
have changed so these were the revenues
generated for each of the items only for
this is
our entire Excel Revenue dashboard on
sales
we created multiple charts and graphs
then we applied different formatting we
added different icons then we formatted
the labels also
next we added slicers and
finally we saw how we could filter our
data based on these slicers
likewise now we are going to create a
profit dashboard based on the same data
so before moving ahead let me rename
this sheet as
Revenue dashboard I'll write Rev
dashboard okay
now we move to our data sheet and
start creating your pivot tables and
pivot charts for the profit dashboard
all right so let me go ahead and create
my first pivot table so
I'll create a new worksheet
this time I'm going to create a line
chart
to visualize the profit for each year
so I'll drag my
total profit column two values and my
order here to rows
so here you can see we have our
pivot table ready
now you can sort this data
to get an idea as to which
year had the highest profit and which
year had the lowest profit so from this
pivot table you can see since I've
sorted this data in descending order so
had the maximum amount of profit and
2017 had the least amount of profit
I'll just do Ctrl Z to undo it all right
now based on this pivot table let me go
ahead and create my PO chart so I'll go
to recommended charts and click on a
line chart so this is the preview of the
chart
I'll click on OK
let me close this similarly
we are going to
edit this chart now so first I'll hide
all the field buttons present on the
chart and I'll
rename the chart title as total
profit
by year
next I am going to remove the legend so
I'll delete this
let's do some more formatting
so I'll go to style
and
this time
I'm going to select
my style type okay
and if you want you can
choose the colors as well for the timing
let's have
this yellow color
next let me add the data labels so again
if you see here this is not formatted
properly so let's go ahead and format
the
data labels so I'll click on number
and I'll select custom here
and the type I'm going to select is in
millions and I'll click on
close so here you can see we have our
line chart ready which shows total
profit by year
let's
rename this sheet as
profit
by
year
all right
now let's move back to our data sheet
again
next